Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Wie war es auf der Berlinale?
Ich war in Zürich.
Das heißt, für dich Filmfreak ist das Fernsehen die Nummer eins?
Meinst du.
Du liest lieber im Fernsehen Bücher, als dir Filme auf der Berlinale anzugucken.
Richtig, ich war im Literaturclub zu Gast, wäre aber auch sonst nicht zur Berlinale gegangen, da ich ja nicht so im täglichen Geschäft drin bin, dass ich jetzt Berlinale Berichterstattung machen muss. Insofern ist das Festival für mich nicht so interessant, zumindest nicht diese Wettbewerbsfilme. Vieles davon kommt ja irgendwann mal oder gar nicht ins Kino, sind auch eher Filme, die ich nicht bespreche. Und dann sitze ich doch sehr viel lieber im Literaturclub in der Schweiz. Zudem konnte man ja Berlinale wie selten erleben, nämlich diese Debatten.
Selbst ich habe Berlinale erlebt.
Ja, diese Debatten haben mich ja sogar dazu geführt, in Deep Dive zu machen zum Thema Berlinale und politischer Film und all das. Das heißt, man kann wirklich sagen, dieses Festival hatte plötzlich eine Diskursrelevanz, wie das selten der Fall war.
Und was lernt die Berlinale jetzt daraus? Sie machen es nächstes Jahr wieder oder tun alle was dagegen?
Naja, man kann ja in dem Sinne nichts dagegen tun, es sei denn, man möchte sagen, wir schotten uns jetzt völlig ab und machen kein internationales Filmfestival mehr, sondern wir machen ein Wolfram Breimer Filmfestival. Dann kann er mit den seinen Filme und Filmemacher auswählen, die vorher schon abgeklopft sind auf alle Positionen, die es so gibt. Dann kann man das da veranstalten, dann ist das eine recht kuratierte Reihe. Aber das internationale Filmfestival müsste ja eigentlich genau der Ort sein für diese Auseinandersetzung. Denn sonst braucht man das ja gar nicht zu veranstalten. Aber es ist interessant, dass wir zum einen immer diese große Klage darüber haben, alle sind zu unseren Filterbubbles gefangen. Ist es dann mal so, dass verschiedene Positionen aufeinandertreffen? Um Gottes willen, was können wir denn dagegen tun? Also bis hin zu einer Kulturzeitberichterstattung, in der auch die Moderatoren nochmal besorgt nachfragt, wie kann man denn dagegen vorgehen? Was kann man denn da machen? Wie kann man da Abhilfe schaffen, dass die Berlinale nicht so ins Gerede kommen? Dann denke ich, ja, das ist ja eigentlich eine große Chance. Es müsste nur eine Gelassenheit dann von den politischen Akteuren da sein, dass man nicht gleich sagt, wie kann man mittelkürzen? Brauchen wir eine neue Leiterin? Was auch immer. Sondern man könnte einfach sagen, ah, da gab es also konfligierende Positionen.
Aber ich habe dich ja stundenlang verfolgt in Tim Gabels Podcast. Und da hast du ja sehr ausführlich über den Film und die versteckte Ideologie, die Latenz und deine Bemühung, es dann mal manifest zu machen. Und wenn diese Manifestierungen schon auf der Bühne nach der Präsentation des Films stattfinden, sei es, dass auf der Bühne noch mal jemand sagt, ich bin der Künstler und ich meinte das. Und dann kommt das Publikum und sagt, na nein, das kann man auch so sehen, wie auch immer. Und dann wüscht sich noch später jemand ein. Dann ist ja genau dieser Latenzschleier über der Ideologie mal enthüllt und alle haben mal klar gesagt, was sie eigentlich wollten in diesem Business. Auch nicht schlecht, oder?
Ich finde es auch sehr erhellend. Also ich habe nicht den Eindruck, dass es, weil das jetzt auch so herbeigeschrieben wird, eine Krise dieses Filmfestivals ist. Die Krise haben wir lange Zeit unter Dieter Koslik erlebt. Da habe ich die Berlinale ja auch noch besucht und war dann wirklich zehn Tage dort, dass man eigentlich nur darüber sprach, dass die Programmhefte jetzt auf Ökopapier gedruckt sind und dass man auch vegan essen kann während den Pausen. Das war das Inhaltliche, was man bieten konnte und die Filme waren total langweilig. Jetzt weiß ich nicht, wie die Filme sind. Ich war ja, wie gesagt, nicht da. Jedenfalls ist die Debatte doch politisch jedenfalls spannender geworden.
Ja, sehr gut. Also ich habe nur gestern in einem Newsletter zu Veranstaltungen in Frankfurt am Main gesehen, das natürlich jetzt, und das erinnerte mich dann an, wir haben eine Babo-Haftbefehl-Doku. Und dann später heißt es, und diesen Sommer im Stadion World Club Dome mit Headliner Haftbefehl. Also, dass es gleich vermarktet wird. Und der Aufmacher dieser E-Mail gestern, die ich sah, war natürlich das Wim Wenders. Jetzt das Deutsche Filmmuseum besucht demnächst.
Und dann gibt es hier eine ganze Festwoche nämlich auch.
Und da hat wahrscheinlich, also ich habe natürlich, ich weiß nicht, wie andere Leute diese Newsletter lesen, aber in meinem Kopf ist dann Wim Wenders, ach ja, das war ja der mit der Berlinale. So ungefähr, der sich die Frage von Tilo eingefangen hat. Ja. Und damit ist das Marketing natürlich wieder gemacht. So, Thema Nummer eins heute ist Reichtum. Ich hatte ja angekündigt, dass wir ganz viel über Kommunalwahl reden. Die finden ja in Hessen und in Bayern statt. Ich will es dazu sagen, unsere Service in Hessen am 15. März und in Bayern am 8. März. In Bayern werden auch die OBs und so mitgewählt. Hier ist die Gemeindeordnung ein bisschen anders. In Frankfurt ist sozusagen Midterm-Election für Mike Josef. Wer sich dafür im Detail interessiert, ich habe mit Collier Müller eine Stunde lang hier an diesem Tisch eingeweiht, um hier aus dem Bahnhofsviertel heraus mal die Frankfurter Sachen zu besprechen. Ich wollte eigentlich viele Clips davon spielen, aber einen spiele ich jetzt, damit wir heute unsere anderen Themen unterkriegen. Ich will jedenfalls alle Hessen, alle Bayern unter uns aufrufen. Ihr wisst, was zu tun ist, es findet eine Wahl statt. Und jetzt ist die Frage, um was geht es denn bei dieser Wahl? Und typischerweise haben wir ja im Journalismus immer nur Bundeskanzler. Es wird dann das Tagebuch des Bundeskanzlers erklärt. Friedrich Merz war mal wieder irgendwo. Und in diesem Fall war Friedrich Merz im Machtwechsel-Podcast. Das haben wir natürlich alle mitbekommen. Denn Machtwechsel kommt jetzt zweimal die Woche. Ich möchte es ein bisschen, wirklich, ich habe es schon mal gesagt, auf meine Kappe nehmen. Denn ich war ja bei Hart aber Fair mit Robin Alexander und habe ihn gefragt, was ist mit diesem Podcast? Er so, nein, wir haben so viel zu tun. Das ganze Geschreibe und ich so, niemand liest. Und jetzt, ein halbes Jahr später, zweimal die Woche Machtwechsel, kein Geschreibe mehr. Es ist Marktforschung eins zu eins, die ich ihm geboten habe.
Wenn ich immer noch gerne mal wissen würde, und das werden wir jetzt nicht so schnell nicht erfahren, wie diese Konstruktion mit Springer ist, also inwieweit Springer noch mit investiert ist.
Ich glaube ja nicht.
Wie unabhängig das ist, in dem Sinne, dass man sagt, ihr seid journalistisch unabhängig, das glaube ich auf jeden Fall. Aber ob es noch finanziell da eine Verstrickung gibt, nämlich das ist ja eigentlich der logische Gedanke, also ich gehe jetzt nur von Springer ausdenkend. Heute ist es ja so, dass sehr viele dieser Medien Gesichter nach vorne bringen, die eine Berühmtheit erlangen, die dann eigentlich größer ist, als das, was man verdienen kann, wenn man dort normale Angestellter ist. Selbst wenn man der bestbezahlte Redakteur ist, dann ist man eigentlich als so ein News-Influencer besser bedient, wenn man es selbstständig macht. Das heißt aber, diese Springer-Plattform war ja doch entscheidend dafür. Und die Frage ist, ob man eigentlich jetzt bei den Medienhäusern zunehmend so etwas erlebt, wie im Künstlermanagement, dass man sagt, also wir haben hier so eine Grundplattform und da machen wir auch hin und wieder mal so eine Bildgala, da kommt ihr dann auch nochmal dabei. Aber eigentlich vermarkten wir euch dann darüber hinaus und ihr gebt uns 15 oder 30 Prozent. Also, dass es solche Konstrukte sind, die mehr werden im Journalismus, weil anders diese Leute nicht zu halten sind. Sonst sagen die gleich, ich mach mich selbstständig, ich mach jetzt Hubstack oder was auch immer.
Also soweit ich das jetzt im Ohr hab, kommt am Ende dieser Dings hier Studio Bummens und so.
Ja, ja, das glaube ich auch.
Und die machen sehr viel, finanziert uns über Campfire. Ich weiß nicht, ob man das auch schon finanzieren kann oder wie auch immer. Wir hatten ja schon mal diskutiert. Meine Vermutung bleibt weiterhin, Springer hat dieses Angebot gemacht, ist so zu gestalten, wie du es vermutest. Und wir sehen aber die Absage davon.
Sie haben ja den Namen behalten und so etwas. Das ist schon etwas, was nicht so ganz billig ist. Das heißt, es wird nicht einfach nur so sein, wir gehen da mal raus.
Oder man wollte halt den großen Streit vermeiden.
Nur denke ich, dass wir generell das mehr so erleben, dass diese Medienhäuser jetzt bei einzelnen Journalisten, früher hatte man sie Edelfedern genannt, dass man bei diesen dann möglicherweise mehr so ein Künstlermanagement macht und hat da eine andere Konstruktion.
Mal sehen, aber am Ende kriegen wir einfach zweimal die Woche erstmal ein Podcast und hören uns das so an.
Das ist ja für dich ganz wichtig, dass du noch ein Podcast mehr holen kannst.
Ja, das ist der 221. Podcast in der Liste. Der ist natürlich zu hören. Jedenfalls war dort Friedrich Merz zu Gast. Und während wir uns Anfang des Monats vor dem Salon noch darüber freuten, dass selbst Robin Alexander bei der Erbschaftssteuerreform ganz unspringerhaft wieder ein Indiz sagte, ja klar, das muss jetzt mal gemacht werden. Und da versteht man auch nicht, was die CDU da sagt. Wir warten erst mal ein Urteil ab. Nein, wir bereiten jetzt vor, dass wir die Urteilsverkündung da noch ordentlich nutzen können. Das klang natürlich dann ganz anders als Friedrich Merz jetzt im ersten der zweiwöchigen Rhythmen ausgestrahlten Podcast zu Gast war. Wir hören uns mal hier ein Snippet an.
Ich sage auch immer wieder den Satz und wiederhole ihn gerne hier, es gibt keinen anstrengungslosen Wohlstand. Der Wohlstand wird nicht am Bankschalter zugeteilt, sondern er muss erarbeitet werden. Und darüber müssen wir miteinander sprechen. Wie bekommen wir es hin, dass wir insgesamt in diesem Land einen höheren Wohlstand wieder erarbeiten? Wir haben keine natürlichen Rohstoffe, wir haben keinen natürlichen Reichtum, wir können das, was wir erwirtschaften, nur mit Arbeit erwirtschaften, mit geistiger und körperlicher Arbeit.
Dazu kennen wir alle die Nachrichtenlage. Alexander Dobrindt stellt die Deutschkurse für Zugezogene ein. Und an hessischen Schulen landesweit gilt IGSen. Meine beiden Tüchter sind also auch betroffen. Pro Schule drei Planstellen weniger Lehrerkraft. Wo man sich fragt, okay, also das ist jetzt die Investition in diesen kommenden Wohlstand, den wir uns erarbeiten müssen.
Und weil die Arbeit so existenziell ist, besteuern wir sie auch viel mehr als Kapitalerträge und all das.
Also es ist ganz verrückt, dieses ganze Statement. Geld wird in Deutschland nicht am Bankschalter zugewiesen. Oh doch, genau so. Also das ist nun mal der Gini-Koeffizient Vermögen. Also 0,8 plus. Also das wird zugewiesen. Ich will nur, weil hier Wahlkampf ist, dass ein Ressort SPD geführt in einer Landesregierung dann einfach sagt, wir haben so mit einem halben Ort zugehört, was im Bildungsministerium abläuft, wir überweisen einfach die Kohle. Das finde ich schon einen genialen Move irgendwie. Also die SPD macht mittlerweile derzeit, finde ich, da viel richtig und in den Erbschaftsteuerbund auch. So, zweite Statement von Friedrich Merz.
Ich kann die SPD-Pläne verstehen für die unteren und die mittleren Einkommen, wobei bei den unteren gar nicht mehr so viel zu entlasten ist. Die zahlen praktisch kaum noch Steuern, die zahlen vor allen Dingen Sozialversicherungsbeiträge, da müssten wir eigentlich entlassen.
Aber keine Steuererhöhungen.
Ich sehe den Spitzensteuersatz oben vor allen Dingen in der Kombination mit Solidaritätszuschlag, dem ohnehin vorhandenen Reichensteuersatz oben, den wir ja haben, und der Kirchensteuer. Die Zitrone ist ziemlich ausgequetscht.
Seit der Bundestagswahl ist die Union in keiner Umfrage mehr über 30 Prozent gekommen. Haben Sie eine Erklärung, woran das liegt?
Nein, eine wirkliche Erklärung habe ich dafür nicht.
Wenn du das im Original wortlaut in der Anstalt nachspielst, würde keiner sich fragen, wie das gemeint ist, weil alle sehen, ja, Satire halt. Die Zitrone ist ausgequetscht und können sich erklären, warum die CDU nicht mehr gewinnt.
Ja, das Interessante ist ja hier tatsächlich, dass er in Teilen Recht hat, nämlich die reden ja nur über Einkommensbesteuerung. Das heißt, die reden ja jetzt darüber, ob man den Spitzensteuersatz, den sogenannten, muss man sagen. Also, um das nochmal klar zu machen, der Spitzensteuersatz, von dem hier die Rede war, das ist dieser Steuersatz, der so ab Single-Einkommen 85.000 brutto oder so einsetzt. Das heißt, das sind 42 Prozent. Dann so ab 90.000 etwa, denke ich, greift auch so etwas wie Solidaritätszuschlag. Also dann jeder Euro, der da mehr verdient wird, dann nochmal drei Prozent Soli. Dann gibt es die sogenannte reichen, den reichen Steuersatz. Das ist aber der eigentliche Spitzensteuersatz. Der liegt bei 45 Prozent und der greift bei einem Single-Haushalt. Ich kenne nicht den genauen Betrag, etwa bei 280.000 würde ich mal tippen. Single-Haushalt, also das heißt, alles, was darüber wiederum verdient wird, da wird dann nochmal mehr genommen. Dann zahlt man also 45 Prozent plus drei Prozent Soli. Die Kirschensteuer, das ist ja jedem selbst überlassen, wie man das handelt. Das aufzurufen, ist ja irrsinnig. Aber es zeigt auf jeden Fall also für diese Leute, und wie viele sind das? Das sind ein Prozent der Leute, die das verdienen.
Darüber reden wir jetzt mal.
Genau, aber jetzt kommen wir nämlich da in eine falsche Gemengelage rein, wenn ich sage, es verdienen ja sowieso nur ein Prozent in Deutschland über 230.000 Euro. Dann denkt man so, dann sind es ja gar nicht viele. Die Sache ist nur, das sind Leute, die haben möglicherweise den Top-Job bei Google bekommen. Die sind in irgendeinem absoluten Premium angestellt und verdienen das. Das ist tatsächlich ganz selten. Die meisten Leute verdienen natürlich anders in Deutschland. Sie bekommen, wenn sie solche Top-Positionen haben, Anteile am Unternehmen. Das heißt, da gibt es Kapitalertragsteuer, die dann fällig werden würde und die liegt bei 25 Prozent. Das sind also nicht diese 45 Prozent. Zudem sind Leute, die Unternehmen haben, natürlich so finde ich, dass sie sich das nicht einfach als Einkommen auszahlen, weil dann hätten wir sehr viel mehr als diese ein Prozent, die über 220.000 im Jahr verdienen, sondern das sind dann Leute, die sich über ihre verschiedenen Konstruktionen auszahlen bzw. reinvestieren. Wir kennen diese ganzen Konstrukte mit Betriebsvermögen. Das heißt, diese ein Prozent sind irrlich. Deswegen ist es auch so irrsinnig, die ganze Zeit nur davon zu reden, wie man die Einkommen noch mal da und dort versteuern kann. Da würde ich sagen, ist der Spielraum gering. Das sehen wir ja tatsächlich, wenn wir uns die Wahlprogramme der Parteien insgesamt ansehen, können wir feststellen, bei der Einkommensbesteuerung gibt es dann nur solche Vorschläge von, naja, dann greift da ein bisschen die Progression früher und da weniger. Und dann gab es noch den CDU-Vorschlag, dass der Soli auch für die Reichen fallen soll. Das wäre die einzige Sache, die sie hätten noch anbieten können, sonst haben sie auch nichts für die Einkommensbezieher, die reich sind. Also die, die zu den Top 10 Prozent gehören, haben sie nichts anzubieten. Das Einzige, was die Union die ganze Zeit anbietet und auch macht, ist eben für die Leute, die von Kapitalerträgen leben, die Betriebswohnungen ohne Ende haben, also Betriebsvermögen in Form von Wohnungen haben und so weiter, das Geld auszuschütten, wodurch wir so eine extreme Ungleichheit haben und so eine unglaubliche Anzahl von Millionären in Deutschland.
Genau, über die Zahl reden wir gleich mal. Es ist in diesem, was Merz hier sagte, also das konkrete Bild, die Zitrone ist ausgequetscht bei den unteren, also Niedriglohn, Mittelschicht sowieso, weil, hat er ja gesagt, sind es hauptsächlich Sozialbeiträge. Die Steuerpflicht beginnt ja dann erst ab einer gewissen Höhe. Und dann ist man ja sofort in diesem, du hast jetzt die absoluten Zahlen genannt, das sind ja irgendwie so 1,5 Medianen, ist ja schon Spitzensteuersatz. So, und wenn man sich diese untere Kante, dieses Spitzensteuersatz...
Was meinst du jetzt mit 1,5 Medianen?
Na, 1,5 des Medianeinkommens, dann hat man schon den Spitzensteuersatz erreicht. Richtig, so, ja. Was bedeutet, dieser Spitzensteuersatz hat eine Unterkante, 1,5 Medianen, aber Leute, die 8-mal Medianen, 16-mal Medianen, 100-mal Medianen verdienen, die sind ja fein raus. Weil die fallen ja alle mit unter die Kategorie Zentrone.
Naja.
Und da ist quasi ausgequetscht.
Und weil die auch nicht ihre Einkommen haben. Also ich kenne Leute, die sind Millionäre, die zahlen sich ein Einkommen von 3000 Euro im Monat.
Genau. So, Leute leben zum Beispiel von den Erträgen durch die Abgeltungssteuer. Die kam 2009. Das bedeutet, Leute erarbeiten sich Geld und investieren es dann in Vermögenswerte. Aktien, darauf kriegen sie Dividende oder Erträge, wenn sie die verkaufen, wie auch immer. Das sind jetzt mal so, bei Aktien ist es halt der Großteil. Da ist auch relativ klar, weil die so leicht liquidierbar sind. Aber das gilt genauso bei Immobilien, wie auch immer. Also es gibt eine Abgeltungssteuer. Diese Abgeltungssteuer sagt, es wird nicht auf dein Spitzensteuersatz Einkommensniveau angerechnet, sondern flat 25 Prozent. Nun ist es so, diese Steuer gibt es jetzt seit 16 Jahren, seit 2009. Derjenige, der sie eingeführt hat, Per Steinbrück, sagte selber später, falsches Modell, wir sollten es eigentlich wieder abschaffen. Außerdem, und das habe ich jetzt durch eine Recherche festgestellt, 2022 hat das Finanzgericht Niedersachsen die Frage dem höheren Gericht vorgelegt, wo es dann mal eine verfassungsrechtliche Klärung geben sollte, ob denn Kapitalerträge, die der Abgeltungssteuer unterliegen, nicht einfach einkommen sind. Und wie die Begründung lautet, dass das kein Einkommen ist, also nicht unter Einkommenssteuer fällt, sondern unter Abgeltungssteuer. Allerdings hat das Finanzamt selber, das beim Finanzgericht Niedersachsen damals das Problem aufwarf, gesagt, ne, wir ziehen hier zurück. Dadurch hat das Finanzgericht Niedersachsen auch zurückgezogen und es kam nie zu dieser hohen Entscheidung. Wir haben also noch eine verfassungsrechtliche Klärung offen, ob die Kapitalerträge, die bislang unter Abgeltungssteuer fallen, überhaupt das dürfen oder ob das nicht ein Verfassungsbruch ist, diese Art von Einkommen nicht als Einkommen zu verhandeln.
Das zweite ist, um das ganz plastisch noch mal zu machen, wenn ich jetzt bei Amazon im mittleren Management arbeiten würde und 100.000 Euro im Jahr dort verdienen würde, dann hätte ich einen Grenzsteuersatz von etwa 42 Prozent plus schon ein bisschen Soli würde anfallen. Wenn ich aber mit Amazon-Aktien im Jahr 100.000 Euro machen würde, weil ich die verkaufe, da spekuliere, Dividende, was auch immer, dann hätte ich diese 25 Prozent.
Genau, und egal bei welchen, da gibt es auch keine Progression oder so. Bisschen einfach fein raus, also einfach 25 Prozent.
Und wenn wir dann so in die Millionen gehen, dann könnte man natürlich noch ganz andere Konstrukte machen, dass auch diese 25 Prozent nicht so.
Und dass man hier aufgrund von welchen Einflüssen auch immer verfassungsrechtliche Klärung aussitze, bislang aussah, ist ja skandalös. Dasselbe bei der Vermögensteuer. Wir haben es im Sommersalon besprochen. Eigentlich sagt das Bundesverfassungsgericht damals 1997, eure Grundstücke im großen Vermögensmix sind zu niedrig bewertet. Die müssen mal teurer werden. Da ist nämlich einfach 1968 war das Haus 10.000 Euro wert, nicht mehr richtig. Und das Verfassungsgericht hat selbst gesagt, zum Teil wird nur ein Zehntel der eigentlichen Verkehrswerthöhe ermittelt. Statt das nachzubessern, also mehr Steuern einzunehmen, hat man sie einfach ausgesetzt. So und deswegen die Erbschaftssteuer. Die Erbschaftssteuer ist ja auch ein Einkommen. Sie ermöglicht dem Hinterbliebenen ein Einkommen. Und da ist einfach völlig unklar, warum dieses Einkommen nach einer eigenen Steuerregel behandelt wird. Sag ich jetzt mal ganz grob. Also ich finde schon, man sollte bei der Erbschaftssteuer an sich bleiben. Und es ist nicht komplett im Einkommensteuer. Also Abgeltungssteuer abschaffen. Aber Erbschaftssteuer, das muss mal wieder...
Mit dem gewissen... also Abgeltungssteuer abschaffen, ich würde schon sagen, dass es sinnvoll ist, dass man einen gewissen Freibetrag, auf dem man sich einigen muss. Genau, das hat sie ja...
Eine Million bar, das Haus der Eltern, alles frei.
Also das heißt, dass natürlich eine Form von Sparen möglich ist dadurch. Dagegen jetzt zu sein, wäre wirklich ja Irrsinn. Aber tatsächlich müsste man sie im Ganzen natürlich abschaffen, weil es keinen Sinn ergibt.
Weil bei der Erbschaftssteuer ist es wie bei dem Spitzensteuersatz. Da ist relativ schnell eine Kante unten. Da fallen 90 Prozent rein. Und uns interessieren ja die da oben, die sich immer mit in die Zitrone da unten zählen. Nur, die sind halt anders. Und ich habe mit Kolja Müller auch über den Reichtum in Frankfurt am Main gesprochen. Nun ist so, Kolja Müller ist vielleicht der engagierteste Politiker hier in Frankfurt, den ich so kenne. Es sind bestimmt viele, aber ich kenne halt nicht alle. Und ich bin immer wieder beeindruckt, wie sehr diese Kommunalpolitiker und ich rede sehr viel damit eben darüber, dass sie eigentlich alle gar kein Geld verdienen. Wenn sie dann mal Stadtverordnete sind, kriegen sie 1000 Euro im Monat und müssen aber ein 6 Milliarden Budget mit abnicken für die Stadt. Also es ist ja überhaupt keine Verhältnismäßigkeit. Und ich habe mit ihm auch mal über den Reichtum gesprochen. Und ich habe dich in einem Talk gesehen, wo dir Quizfragen gestellt wurden und du konntest alle beantworten. Wie viele Krankenhäuser, wie viele U-Bahn-Linien und so weiter und so fort. Aber wie viele Milliardäre wohnen in Frankfurt? Oh, die ist gut, die Frage.
Kriege ich Schätzantworten?
Ich sage dir eine Zahl und es reicht, wenn du sagst mehr oder weniger. Zehn. Mehr. So, zehn. Er sagt mehr. Wir können uns alle überlegen, ob das richtig ist. Also Kolja Müller hat in diesem anderen Talk, den ich gesehen habe, alle Fragen richtig beantwortet. Wie viele U-Bahn-Linien, wie viele Schulen, wie viele Krankenhäuser, wie viel Kramer. Die erste Frage war, wie viele Einwohner hat Frankfurt? Er sagte, alle drei Zahlen sind falsch, die richtige Zahl ist. Also so auf dem Niveau kennt er sich aus. Hier bei den Milliardären muss er schon kurz überlegen, obwohl das ist eine niedrige Zahl. Ich finde, man könnte sie wissen. Er sagt jetzt auf zehn mehr. Ich sage 13. 13. So, dann reden wir über die Zentimillionäre, also Menschen, die über 100 Millionen haben. Also die super rich, laut Julia Friedrich, sind in Frankfurt 130 so ungefähr. Da haben wir auch richtig. Und jetzt kommt aber die Frage nach denen, wie viele Millionäre gibt es? Also sie könnten es liquidieren, machen es natürlich nicht. Da stecken wir mal hier ein, 140 Leute. Und jetzt kommt aber die Zahl, die mich überrascht hat. Denn beim Thema Wohnen spielt ja die Immobilie eine große Rolle. Und die ist ja in Frankfurt sehr im Wert gestiegen. Weshalb sehr viele Leute auf dem Papier, Buchwert, also sie könnten es liquidieren, machen es natürlich nicht, weil sie da drin wohnen, aber die trotzdem Millionäre sind. Jetzt will ich dich fragen und auch die Hörer, wie viele Millionäre leben in Frankfurt am Main in einer Stadt mit 780.000 Einwohnern? Du weißt, wie groß das Westend ist, Sachsenhausen, Nordend. Ja, ich glaube, es sind ein paar hundert. Ich würde jetzt mal sagen 500. So, jetzt kommt eine Zahl, die ist so schockierend, aber sie stimmt. Ich habe sie mehrfach überprüft, nachgelesen, ich habe mit KI-Hilfe noch mal Plausibilisierung angestellt, wie auch immer. Es sind 80.000. Es sind 80.000. Jeder achte Einwohner von Frankfurt am Main ist laut Buchwerten, über die man selbst verfügt, millionär. Was bedeutet 80.000? 80.000. So, zurück im Zwanziger-Podcast. Also, wenn Friedrich Merz davon redet, die Zitrone, dann meint er alle Millionäre. Und dann fühlen sich auch alle Millionäre angesprochen und die sagen auch von sich, na ja, ich gehe jetzt nochmal arbeiten, ich habe einen Gehalt von, keine Ahnung, Medien halt, aber ich habe halt das eine Haus, das mich buchwertmäßig Millionär macht. Aber das habe ich von meinen Eltern geerbt.
Das genügt dir auch oft eine Wohnung, würde ich sagen.
Genau, und das gebe ich den Kindern weiter. Und es ist so genial, ich sage es nochmal, dass die SPD jetzt einfach sagt, wenn du eine Million auf dem Konto hast, sag mal mal 999.000 oder einfach im Haus deiner Eltern wohnst, dann bist du fein raus. Für dich gilt die Erbschaftssteuer nicht, nicht im Sinne von wir senken dir die Erbschaftssteuer, sondern wir schaffen sie für dich ab. Also hier wird einfach die Zitrone neu definiert. Denn das ist das größte Problem in Deutschland. Die Zitrone ist so groß, dass wenn Friedrich Merz sagt, die Zitrone ist ausgequetscht, dann sagt jeder Neunte, jeder Zehnte in Frankfurt, ja, das stimmt. Und das ist der Schutzschild für die handverlesenen 100 Leute, die dann 100 Millionen aufwärts haben, die 13 Leute, die Milliardäre sind. Also wir müssen hier die Zitrone nochmal neu definieren. Und ich würde deswegen wirklich hart sagen, unter 100 Millionen machen wir nochmal eine neue Kategorie auf. Über 100 Millionen ist echt was anderes. Das ist dann super-rich. Und das ist mir hier wieder verdeutlicht worden. Das selbst, Kolja Müller, der ist nur unterwegs in Frankfurt. Der kennt jede Ecke so. Aber in der Frage, wie viele Leute zählen sich hier zur Zitrone? Wenn Friedrich Merz Ideologiepolitik im Machtwechsel-Podcast macht, dann wird sich um Faktor 160 verschätzen. Und da muss man einfach jetzt ran. Weshalb wir ökonomische Aufklärung brauchen.
Unbedingt. Und das führt uns zu einer Werbung, die wir jetzt machen wollen, nämlich für ein von uns sehr geschätztes Wirtschaftsmagazin Sir Plus. Sag uns doch mal, worum es in der neuen Ausgabe geht.
Wir möchten kurz auf dieses besondere Angebot zur neuen Ausgabe des Sir Plus, wir sollen es englisch aussprechen, Sir Plus, es ist ein cooles Magazin, hinweisen. Denn das Thema ist diesmal der Machtkampf um KI, der einerseits zwischen den Arbeitenden und den Reichsten, die Zitrone, andererseits auch unter den Tech-Oligarchen selbst ausgefochten wird. Ja, ist nämlich nicht immer alles nur lustig. Wer gewinnt, wer verliert. Wie revolutionär ist die Technologie und wie könnte man KI in den Dienst der Menschen stellen?
Sehr wichtig. All das gibt es in der neuen Ausgabe von Surplus. Mit Texten von Gabriel Zygmann, Aya Jaff, Adam Toos und Martina Linatas. Uns wohlbekannte Namen. Ihr könnt Surplus jetzt vier Wochen lang für nur einen Euro testen und bekommt diese KI-Ausgabe dann direkt nach Hause. www.surplusmagazin.de schrägstrich DNZ. Der Link findet sich aber auch in der Episodenbeschreibung. Wir wünschen viel Spaß beim Lesen.
Genau. Falls ihr die manuell eintippt. Nee, DNZ am Ende ist wichtig, damit die sehen, dass ihr Premium-Leser seid. Und wir beide sind ja auch Premium-Leser. Du hast das Print-Abo. Ich bin natürlich noch digital abonniert.
Natürlich. Wir wollen einmal wieder über den Krieg in der Ukraine sprechen. Dabei wollte ich etwas aufgreifen, dass du vor, ja man muss jetzt inzwischen sagen, dass du das schon seit vielen Jahren gesagt hast in Bezug auf die Ukraine. Wir erinnern uns an diese Absichtsbekundungen, vorgetragen von Ursula von der Leyen und vielen anderen. Und dann nehmen wir bald die Ukraine in die EU auf. Dann hast du immer gesagt, ja die Agrarsubventionen werden die Europäer doch nicht mit den Ukrainern teilen wollen. Da sind die Landwirte davor. Das fanden manche immer so eine bisschen verbogene Argumentation, als ging es jetzt wirklich darum. Es geht doch jetzt um höhere Ideale, was auch immer. Dann höre ich im NTV Podcast, Herfried Münkler, der sich erst mal aufregt darüber, dass Mercosur jetzt gerade so torpediert wird, macht aber dann gleich weiter.
Mercosur hat natürlich das Problem, dass die Bauern die Konkurrenz aus Brasilien und Argentinien fürchten. Aber auch die Frage des Beitritts vormals der Türkei, inzwischen ist das ja von der Tagesordnung, jetzt der Ukraine, wird wahrscheinlich negativ befieden werden, weil sich zumal die Franzosen, aber auch die Polen in dieser Frage querlegen werden und keine Lust haben, ihre großen Anteile am europäischen Agrarfonds mit dem wirklich großen Agrarland Ukraine in irgendeiner Weise zu teilen.
Genau, ja. Sehr gut. Ist er älter geworden oder was? Ist er ein bisschen angeschlagen? Was ist da los?
Nein, er redet immer so. Nachdenklich.
Na gut, vielleicht haben wir das doch schon leller im Ohr.
Weil sie so viel Macht in Brüssel hat, kann die Agrarlobby den EU-Beitritt der Ukraine verhindern?
Sie kann das nicht nur. Ich glaube auch, dass sie das wird. Weil das Fragen sind, die man nicht in Kompromisse fassen kann, indem man noch mehr Geld einsetzt. Wenn man sagt, die Ukraine kostet uns sowieso Geld, dann legen wir das alles noch mal oben drauf. Also der Weg der Union in eine Schuldenunion, und zwar gewaltige Schulden, den sollte man nicht gehen.
Finde ich interessant, dass er das noch mal warnend ausspricht, dass man auf keinen Fall eine Schuldenunion soll. Das wäre eigentlich wirklich mal ein gemeinschaftliches Projekt. Für so viel ist jetzt nicht nur im Blick darauf. Aber dass wir jetzt hier noch mal von Herfried Münkler gesagt bekommen, der mit diesem EU-Beitritt, das wird wegen der Agrarsubvention schon nicht stattfinden, wird möglicherweise auch noch mal bei einigen ein Umdenken wachrufen. Denn es ist ja doch so, dass man mit so viel Idealismus in den letzten Jahren unterwegs war und hat einfach die Realität ausgeblendet. Von daher ist es doch ganz wichtig, so eine These zu hören. Erstaunlich dann, wie Münkler sich überhaupt vorstellt, wie die EU durchgreifen sollte. Wir hören uns das mal an. Ich war, sagen wir, irritiert.
Traktorendemonstrationen, das Abladen von Mist, Blockaden der Autobahn und derlei mehr nicht leisten. Und man traute sich auch nicht so energisch dagegen einzuschreiten, indem dann halt Fahrzeuge, die da quergestellt werden, beschlagnahmt werden und verschwinden oder derlei mehr. Das würden sich die Bauern dann schon überlegen, ob sie das tun wollten. Oder gegebenenfalls räumt man sie auch mit dem Bergepanzer zur Seite. Dann sind sie kaputt.
Also wir haben bislang gar keine Anzeigen, weder in Frankreich noch in Deutschland noch in Brüssel, wo es ja solche Traktoren auf dem Marsch gab in den letzten Monaten, dass das irgendwie ginge. Und zwar allein über eine mediale öffentliche Meinungslinie.
Also wenn jetzt Panzer auf die Straßen rollen, wenn es Bergepanzer sind, die jetzt die Traktoren wegschieben. Ich meine, Michel Houellebecq hat ja schon einen Roman zu dieser Thematik auch geschrieben. Mit so brutalen Straßensperren und was dann alles kommen könnte. Das kann man doch nicht ernsthaft glauben, dass das die Leute noch mal als EU zusammenbringt. Also dann würde ich sagen, dann Schulden aufnehmen. Ohne Ende halte ich noch alles für denkbar. Aber das hier, was er da beschreibt, was soll denn das sein? Es sei dann, wir haben dann eine autoritäre EU, wo wir dann aber auch, wenn wir draußen auf der Straße dagegen demonstrieren, dann von der Polizei abgeführt werden. Dann sind wir vielleicht doch weit weg von dem, was die EU mal sein wollte.
Gib uns noch mal einen Scope über die Ukraine, weil da Kriegshistorie und so weiter. Weil bei der EU würde mich jetzt auch langsam mal interessieren, wann sie sich mal verkleinert. Also das mit Ungarn finde ich mittlerweile unglaublich.
Ja, er plädierte, das habe ich jetzt nicht mitgebracht, für so ein Europa der Regionen, wo dann einzelne Regionen eine größere Rolle da und dort spielen. Das ist aber ja immer so eine schachbrettartige Weise, auf die Welt zu blicken, zu sagen, ich mache das mal so und so, verschiebe da mal die Akteure, Polen vielleicht, so das Militärische ganz gut, der Süden macht mal dies und das. Darauf lassen sie sich ja alle nicht ein. Also wir sehen ja, wie wenig Zugeständnisse irgendwo gemacht werden, wenn es einen selbst schaden kann. Das heißt, dieser Flickenteppich kann ja gar nicht anders, als ein Flickenteppich sein. Zumindest habe ich diese Vision da, die er teilt nicht. Wir bleiben aber mal bei dem Thema Ukraine. Ich komme auch zu einem Clip aus dem Machtwechsel-Podcast. Merz war dort und sprach über ein mögliches Ende des Krieges.
Und ich bin da ganz nüchtern. Dieser Krieg wird erst enden, wenn eine der beiden Seiten militärisch und oder ökonomisch erschöpft ist. Und davon sind wir noch ein bisschen entfernt. Wie weit wir davon entfernt sind, das wissen wir heute nicht. Meine Vermutung ist, der russischen Volkswirtschaft geht es schlechter, als wir es behauptet bekommen. Und die Frage, wie lange Putin diesen Krieg noch durchhalten kann, wissen wir objektiv nicht zu beurteilen. Wir werden von unserer Seite aus noch einige Zeit durchhalten müssen, in unserer Hilfe für die Ukraine.
Ja, das ist aus dem warmen Podcaststudio alles sehr schön gesagt. Dann habe ich mich gefragt, wie ist denn eigentlich die Situation?
Ja, aber ist das Kriegen nur durch eine Seite sehr erschöpft? Enden es doch mittlerweile? Gibt es historische Gegenbeispiele?
Ich halte das für nicht richtig. Das ist eine Erschöpfung. Also in dem Sinne, was soll das für eine Erschöpfung sein? Also die Erschöpfung sieht ja so aus, dass man sicherlich erkennt, ich komme da jetzt nicht mehr weiter und gehe dann in eine Verhandlung hinein. Aber Erschöpfung sieht ja nicht so aus, dass man in dem Sinne sagt, und jetzt könnt ihr ja Russland erobern, wir sind platt, Putin verlässt den Kreml oder so etwas. Also das ist ja alles nicht zu denken. Das heißt, wir können ja nur sagen, da ist es irgendwann so eine verfahrene Konstellation, dass man hin zu einer Verhandlung geht. Aber wenn das jetzt so geschildert wird, also in einem solchen Fatalismus, dann bedeutet das ja einfach für die Männer, die da kämpfen auf beiden Seiten, ja, ihr werdet wahrscheinlich das Ende dieses Krieges nicht mehr erleben, denn das wird hier noch eine Weile so gehen, denn wir sind ja noch nicht erschöpft auf der einen oder anderen Seite.
Also das ist die menschliche Sicht, ja, hast du die KI-Sicht gelesen, 95 Prozent aller Kriegssimulationen, in denen KI beteiligt ist, enden mit Nukleareinsatz.
Nein, das sollte uns so denken geben.
Hexsets kämpft ja gerade darum, dass heute ist ja großes Ultimatum für Anthropic, Klot freizugeben für Töten, ohne dass noch mal ein Mensch drüber schaut, ein Soldat noch mal eine Entscheidung trifft. Und im Zuge dessen gab es so Berichterstattung zum Thema, man hat mehrere Kriegsspiele simuliert, in denen KI's Entscheidungen getroffen haben und in 95% der Fälle greifen sie zur Atomwaffe. Das ist sozusagen der Gegenteil von Erlschöpfung. Das ist der pragmatische Teil.
An dieser Position waren wir ja, wir haben ja schon häufiger drüber gesprochen, 22 im Herbst, als diese Drohungen seitens Russlands ja sehr ernst zu nehmen waren und von Schulz ja auch ernst genommen wurden. Ich habe dann gedacht, ich bleibe mal im Mainstream. Also ich wollte tatsächlich jetzt dahin gehen, wo wir die ganze Zeit ja hören, die Ukrainer wollen weiter kämpfen und wir können jetzt nicht verhandeln und mit Russland kann man auch vielleicht gar nicht verhandeln und diese ganzen Pazifisten, das ist doch alles falsch. Was hört man da? Dann hört man den Sicherheitshalber Podcast. Dort war zu Gast Rebecca Barth, die ist ARD-Korrespondentin in der Ukraine. Jetzt muss man ja immer diese, es ist fast, wenn ich so Podcasts höre bei mir, manche dann immer so fragen, auch per DM bei Instagram oder so, warum hörst du das, wie hältst du das aus oder so. Ja, ich höre das ja wie so ein Überraschungsei. Wenn man ein Überraschungsei kauft, dann muss man ja erst mal so diese Folie abmachen. Dann hat man diese Schokolade, die auch nicht so toll ist. Und dann muss man noch mal dieses gelbe Ding aufmachen. Und dann kommt man zu dem Spielzeug. Und so höre ich auch den Podcast. Also wir haben diese ganz vielen Sätze da. Und wir können jetzt nicht und wir müssen weiter. Und ich verstehe die Diskussion in Deutschland nicht. Und dann hätte doch Taurus liefern können und so weiter. Das ist alles Schokolade und Papier und dann ist man noch lange nicht durch. Aber dann, wenn man so länger zuhört, das geht ja dann so anderthalb Stunden, dann denkt man so plötzlich, das ist aber was Interessantes. Das habe ich ja so gar nicht gedacht. Und da gehen wir doch jetzt mal rein. Rebecca Maath erzählt.
Es müssen Menschen mobilisiert werden, eingezogen werden.
Also es geht um die Situation in der Ukraine. Wie funktioniert das eigentlich? Wollen die überhaupt noch kämpfen?
In vielen Fällen passiert das gegen den Willen derjenigen, die da eingezogen werden. Und in vielen Fällen kommen diejenigen, die von der Straße weggesammelt werden, in die Brigaden, die die größten Verluste haben. Das heißt, auf gut Deutsch übersetzt, sie kommen ganz nach vorne in die Orte, wo du wirklich überhaupt nicht hin willst. Und die haben davor, wenn es gut läuft, einen Monat Grundausbildung.
Andere Möglichkeit?
Es gilt nicht für jede Einheit, für alle Brigaden, die Ukrainer experimentieren oder es ist mehr als ein Experiment, aber seit gut einem Jahr, mehr als einem Jahr, auch mit Einheiten aus ehemaligen Strafgefangenen. Die übernehmen dann den, auf gut Deutsch gesagt, Drecksjob. Also die sind in der Infanterie, die sitzen auf den Positionen vorne, gelten als sehr effektiv in vielen Teilen. Also das hat sich für die Ukraine bisher als gelungenes Experiment zum aktuellen Zeitpunkt herausgestellt.
Das heißt, man hat Menschen, die in einer so misslichen Lage sind, nämlich im Gefängnis sitzen, dass man ihnen anbietet, ihr könnt Freiheit haben, wenn ihr nun an die Front geht und zwar ganz nach vorn. Wir haben das auch gehört schon vor zwei Jahren über Russland, dass da so sehr stark über diese Möglichkeiten rekrutiert wurde. Wir sehen also mit Freiwilligkeit und so weiter, ist das ja so seine Sache. Wir haben ja hier häufiger schon über Desatöre gesprochen. Wie sieht es aber nun an der Front aus?
Die Ukrainer sind auch nur in kleinen Gruppen unterwegs. Häufig sind die nur zu zweit und dann hast du in diesem Streifen, ich nenne das immer Nester, also Positionen, wo die Soldaten beider Seiten im Endeffekt eigentlich in Erdlöchern hocken. In ihren Nestern sozusagen, aus denen heraus sie operieren, aus denen sie heraus sie versuchen ihre Position zu halten oder weiter vorzurücken.
Ja, im Westen nichts Neues.
Oder der Gegenroman. Viele werden jetzt sagen, lange nichts mehr von Ernst Jünger hier im Podcast gehört. Ist es nicht an der Zeit, dass Wolfgang nochmal was aus den Werken liest? Ich denke, es ist jetzt an der Zeit. In Stahl gewittern bei Ernst Jünger.
Erster Weltkrieg.
Da ist Folgendes zu lesen. Plötzlich fiel drüben ein Schuss, der einen unserer Leute tot im Schlamm versinken ließ, worauf beide Parteien maulwurfartig in den Gräben verschwanden. Ich begab mich in den Teil unserer Stellung, der der englischen Sape gegenüber lag, und rief hinüber, dass ich ein Offizier sprechen möchte. Wirklich begaben sich einige Engländer zurück und brachten nach kurzer Zeit aus ihrem Hauptgraben einen jungen Mann mit, der sich, wie ich durch das Glas beobachten konnte, von ihnen durch eine zierliche Mütze unterschied. Wir verhandelten zunächst in Englischer, dann etwas fließender in französischer Sprache, während die Mannschaft ringsum zuhörte. Ich hielt ihm vor, dass einer von uns durch einen hinterlistigen Schuss getötet sei, worauf er antwortete, dass das nicht seine, sondern die Nachbarkompanie getan habe. Il y a des cochons aussi chevaux, also Schweine gibt es auch bei ihnen, meinte er, als einige aus unserem Nebenabschnitt abgefeuerte Geschosse in der Nähe seines Kopfes einschlugen, worauf ich mich vorbereitete, volle Deckung zu nehmen. Wir erzählten uns jedoch noch viel in einer Weise, die eine fast sportsmännische Achtung ausdrückte und hätten am Schluss zum Andenken gern ein Geschenk ausgetauscht. Um wieder klare Verhältnisse zu bekommen, erklärten wir uns feierlich den Krieg, binnen drei Minuten nach Abbruch der Verhandlungen und nach einem guten Abend von seiner und einem Au revoir. Von meiner Seite gab ich trotz dem Bedauern meiner Leute einen Schuss gegen seinen Schutzschild ab, dem drüben sofort ein zweiter folgte, der mir fast das Gewehr aus der Hand geschlagen hätte. Das heißt, hier begegnet man sich auf einer zwischenmenschlichen Ebene, versteht sich eigentlich auch ganz gut, aber sehr krieg. Deswegen muss man wieder gegeneinander kämpfen. Wir hören jetzt Rebecca Barth.
In dieser grauen Zone wissen häufig beide Beteiligten nicht, wer ist eigentlich der andere. Ich kenne Geschichten von Soldaten, was sie zusammen auf Position gehockt haben, geraucht haben. Und dann geht der andere zurück auf seine und der sitzen bleibt, merkt, ach du Scheiße, ist einer von den anderen gewesen. Nö. Noch? Und die haben bis dahin zusammen in ihrem Nest gehockt, geraucht.
Das ist der Wahnsinn des Krieges. Ich lese noch eine kurze Passage aus den Stahlgewittern. Dann waren in Rauchwolken verborgen zwei starke englische Patrouillen erschienen, von denen eine in den Graben eingedrungen war und einen verwundeten Unteroffizier mitgenommen hatte. Die andere war schon vor dem Drahtverhau zusammengeknallt worden. Ein Einziger, der bereits das Hindernis überwunden hatte, wurde von Brecht, der vorm Kriege ein Pflanzerleben in Amerika geführt hatte, an der Gurgel gepackt und mit einem Come here, you son of a bitch in Empfang genommen. Dieser Einzige wurde nun mit einem Glase Wein bewirtet und schaute mit halb erschrockenen, halb verwunderten Augen auf die eben noch menschenleere Dorfstraße, die jetzt von Essenholern, Krankenträgern, Meldegängern und Neugierigen wimmelte. Es war ein großer, ganz junger Mensch mit goldblonden Haaren und frischem Kindergesicht. Ein Jammer, solche Kerle totschießen zu müssen, dachte ich, als ich ihn sah. Wir hören Folgendes von Rebecca Barth.
Ja, es gab jetzt zuletzt sogar eine Geschichte, die Infanterie in diesem Drohnenkrieg, in diesen grauen Zonen, hängt häufig Monate mittlerweile auf Position. Also die kommen da raus, man müsste sich das anschauen, wirklich, die sehen aus wie Robinson Crusoe vollkommen verwildert. Weil die, die sitzen da zu zweit, zu dritt, im besten Fall. Häufig kommt natürlich vor, dass einer verwundet oder getötet wird und dann hängt man da in seinem Erdloch also alleine weiter. Du wirst versorgt überdrohen, du kannst dich natürlich nicht waschen, du kannst dich natürlich nicht rasieren. Und diese Erdlöcher sind nicht groß, einmal drei Meter, zweimal drei Meter vielleicht. Und dann hängst du da und wirst beschossen mit allem. Und zuletzt gab es eben einen Fall von Männern, die da einige Monate gehangen haben.
Mit dem Russen?
Ja, und die hatten einen Kriegsgefangene tatsächlich. Aber der war auch noch zwei Monate dabei. Und dann sitzt du da.
Das heißt, ihr lebt da Freunde und Feind quasi zusammen in einem Loch über Monate. Das ist die Situation jetzt da. Jetzt kommt zurecht von den anderen folgende Frage.
Da würde ich gerne mal an der Stelle kurz rein, welchen militärischen Sinn hat das Ganze denn noch? An der Stelle.
Das musst du den Kreml fragen.
Ja, es gibt ja diese Killzone, auch aus ukrainischer Sicht. Wir haben eine Killzone, Kilometer breit. Welchen Sinn macht es da eigentlich noch, wirklich mit einzelnen Soldaten reinzugehen? Was bringt das jetzt für beide Seiten?
Also die ukrainische Infanterie, die ich das natürlich auch frage, was ist eigentlich eure Rolle da? Zum einen sagen die immer, du kontrollierst das Land, wo du mit den Füßen draufstehst.
Ja, stimmt das noch?
Naja, wenn du nicht da stehst, dann auf jeden Fall nicht.
Man kann es eigentlich nicht mehr sagen. Und der andere Grund, den erspreche ich uns jetzt hier, weil der auch nicht zum Ziel führt. Aber wir können das ja lösen. Wir haben ja gerade Friedrich Merz gehört. Kriege enden, wenn eine erschöpft ist. Und solange warten wir jetzt, wollen wir mal gucken, welche Seite da erschöpft ist. Und das geht auf Kosten von Menschenleben, Tag für Tag einfach so weiter.
Klingt für mich schon ziemlich erschöpft.
Klingt extrem erschöpft, extrem erschöpft. Deshalb auch die Frage, der werden dann jetzt viele anfangen zu versuchen, zu fliehen jetzt. Und das muss man ja gar nicht fragen, ob die anfangen, sondern wir wissen ja, zu 10.000 kommen junge Männer jetzt nach Deutschland, die nicht in der Ukraine kämpfen wollen, die noch unter dem Alter sind, dass sie eingezogen werden. Und wir wissen von den vielen Deserteuren, erst mal dazu ein Clip.
Weil immer mehr Leute sagen, es wird absehbar keinen Frieden geben, ich kann unter diesen Umständen hier nicht weiterleben. Ich dreh zu, meine Verwandten sind eh schon in Deutschland oder wo auch immer in Westeuropa. Also wie stark ist da so ein Sog? Baut der sich auf oder ist das eine falsche Wahrnehmung?
Rebecca Barth?
Ich glaube, womit man rechnen muss, ist, wenn der Krieg vorbei ist, dass dann sehr viele Leute kommen.
Denke ich auch.
Also das ist das, was ich höre, und zwar aus der Armee. Das erste, was wir machen, wenn wir Urlaub bekommen oder tatsächlich dieser Krieg vorbei ist, ist dein Waffenstich, wir gehen nach Europa und da kommen wir auch nicht wieder.
Man sagt eben noch, ja die verteidigen dann den Boden, auf dem sie stehen, auf dem sie aber eigentlich schon nicht mehr stehen wollen. Wenn der Krieg vorbei ist, dann gehen sie weg. Und dass diese Widersprüchlichkeit doch so zutage tritt. Und wie gesagt, man muss ja gar nicht in irgendwelchen alternativen Medien mehr nach irgendwas suchen, sondern man geht mitten rein den Mainstream und hört permanent solche Widersprüche und hört aber die ganze Zeit noch diese Impetus. Es muss weitergehen, es darf nicht aufhören. Also wie sehr sich da wirklich der öffentliche Diskurs in einen Wahn versteigert hat und wie viele Leute sich da verrannt haben und meinen Augen auch schuldig gemacht haben mit diesen ganzen Maximalforderungen, ist daran zu sehen. Das ist das reale Leid, dass Fortwähren produziert wird, dass nicht mehr auf irgendeiner rationalen Grundlage steht und auch, ja, nur eben dann dieser Logik, die März da dient, dass man die Märze angekündigt hat, dient ja, man muss warten, bis dann Erschöpfung zustande kommt. Also das ist wirklich ein Zynismus, mit dem darüber gesprochen wird, dass es kaum Erträgliche ist, aber ja, durch diese Widersprüche tritt dieser Zynismus dann immerhin deutlich zutage.
Wer ist diese Rebekka Barth noch mal?
Von der ARD, Ukraine-Korrespondentin, dort, Hauptstadtstudio oder was. Ja, also höhere Position, wichtige Position in der ARD.
Kenn ich die aus dem Fernsehen.
Kenn ich die aus. Schauen wir kurz. Wir müssen noch über die Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz reden. Ich dachte ja eigentlich, das wird hier das Hauptthema werden. Dachte ich anfangs, bevor sie begonnen hatte, dann merkte ich aber nein, die Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz ist eigentlich nur so ein Abklatsch von Davos. Denn in Davos hatte man ja eigentlich schon alle Karten gespielt. Dort war das große Schaulaufen inklusive Trump. Alle waren sie da. Jetzt auf der Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz war das Meet & Greet für viele Leute aus den Medien, die in Podcasts auftreten und sich gegenseitig einladen. Aber sonst war es eigentlich nicht besonders interessant. Da gingen keine interessanten neuen Ideen von aus. Deswegen habe ich mich dazu entschlossen, dass wir uns nur und da auch nur wenige Clips, zwei Reden zu Gemüte führen. Einmal die von Friedrich Merz und die von Marco Rubio, dem Außenminister der Vereinigten Staaten. Denn der Rest war viel Geplänkel. Eigentlich waren es Paraphrasierungen dessen, was wir schon in Davos gehört haben. Es war nach deinem Eindruck doch auch nicht interessant.
Haben wir die letzten Jahre anders gehandhabt? Weil typischerweise fährt ja der ganze Tross von Davos einfach nach München weiter.
Na ja, wir haben schon mehr Wert darauf gelegt auf die Sicherheitskonferenz zum Beispiel, als JD Vans da war.
Ja, aber das war ja auch ein echtes Schock. Also da war ja im Januar Amtseinführung und dann sofort im Februar dieses Ding.
Wir haben jetzt hier wirklich keine interessante Konferenz. Wir hören aber mal, was Friedrich Merz zu sagen hat.
Über dieser Konferenz steht ein düsteres Motto, Under Destruction. Dieses Motto meint wohl, die internationale Ordnung, die auf Rechten und auf Regeln ruhte, ist im Begriff zerstört zu werden. Ich fürchte, wir müssen es noch etwas deutlicher sagen. Diese Ordnung, so unvollkommen sie selbst zu ihren besten Zeiten war, sie gibt es so nicht mehr. Und wir, Europa? Nun, Europa, so hat es Peter Sloterdijk vor einigen Wochen geschrieben, hat einen langen Urlaub von der Weltgeschichte beendet.
Also Sloterdijk haben wir ja auch gerne gelesen, das Buch. Und das haben wir auch gut gefunden und so. Aber so wie er das jetzt hier formuliert, weil es irgendwann noch mal einen journalistischen Beitrag gab oder was, also jetzt in den afrikanischen Ländern oder so, schaut man da auf Europa und denkt sich, wow, die haben sich so krass zurückgehalten die letzten Jahrzehnte und jetzt sind sie wieder da.
Nur weil wir jetzt nicht noch einen weiteren Weltkrieg in Deutschland angezettelt haben, haben wir jetzt gleich da Urlaub gemacht. Ich frage mich, ob das so stimmt.
Also im März hat er gesagt, er erhält die erste Rede da. Und die journalistische Begleitung war dann ja, so wie Kani auch, der hat ja auch so eine quasi Eröffnungsrede in der Woche gehalten. Nur beide haben ja nun, und da kann man eben wirklich sagen, das ist ja wie bei Kani, dass man dieses Aussparen des globalen Südens und die Betonung von irgendwas, die Kapazität der neuen oder die neue Kapazität der alten Mittelmächte oder sowas. Und es gilt dieselbe Kritik wie schon bei Kani, auf die wir dann auch wieder Kritik bekommen hatten, dass wir das irgendwie falsch verstanden hätten oder so. Nein, und das sieht man auch an dieser Märzrede wieder. Es sind genau dieselben blinden Flecken. Es ist genau dieses selbe Theater. Ja, diese Weltordnung ist vorbei. Bis 2029 zumindest wird da nicht dazu gesagt. Das ist der Tenor.
Ich meine, man kann es doch an einer Sache deutlich sehen. In Davos hatten wir Gavin Newsom da, der verehrt wurde als der neue Präsident bereits. Sofort haben sich auch die deutschen Medienleute verliebt.
Klar, alle sind verliebt.
In München hat man den nicht bekommen. Was hat man gemacht? Einen Altstar eingeladen, Hillary Clinton. Ich kriege es ja nicht mehr zusammen. Wir haben jetzt gerade Hillary Clinton, die sich erklären muss zu Epstein, vor allem, weil ihr Mann ja da involviert ist und auch, weil bei der Hochzeit der Tochter der Clintons Klischeein Maxwell war. Sie streitet das jetzt ab. Gut, schön. Ich werde mich jetzt hier nicht aus dem Fenster lehnen, finde es aber ein bisschen merkwürdig, wenn ich das so sagen darf. Was ich aber noch viel verrückter finde, ist, dass man jetzt in dieser Situation, wo doch sehr viel ungeklärt ist in Bezug auf Clinton und Epstein und die Frage, warum hat man da so lange zu geschwiegen und was hätte man eigentlich zur Aufklärung des Falls beitragen können, dass genau in diesem Moment, man sagt, das ist jetzt unser Star, nicht nur in München, sondern die lässt man jetzt durch alle Talkshows geistern in Deutschland. Wir haben hymnische Artikel in der Presse gefunden, in der Zeit und sonstwo, das gute Gesicht Amerikas und so weiter in diesem Tone. Ja geht es dann noch irgendwo? Ich würde sagen, dass Hillary Clinton nun jetzt nicht gerade die Person ist, an die man sich in irgendeiner Weise klammern soll. Ich kann das verstehen, wenn jetzt Leute nochmal nostalgisch werden, wenn sie Merkel auf einem Bundesparteitag der CDU sehen. Aber bei Hillary Clinton würde ich sagen, die, die das tun, haben da doch eine Schraube locker.
Ja ich würde auch sagen, der Indikator für uns, dass die Weltordnung wirklich nicht mehr hinhaut, ist, wenn Davos abgesagt ist und Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz auch. Weil dieses privatwirtschaftliche Vereinstheater, was da stattfindet, in dem eben Clinton da reinrutscht, weil man einfach einen Headliner sucht für den ersten Abend oder sowas. Das ist ja wie Rock am Ring. Kriegen wir noch mal die toten Hosen, cool und so. Sagt Campino, ich soll nicht aufs Dach klettern. Also wir sind dafür nächstes Jahr nicht mehr. Wenn es die Veranstaltung nächstes Jahr noch gibt, stimmt ja das alles nicht, was Sie erzählt haben.
Ja, ja, ja. März über China.
Wir erleben andere Entwicklungen auf der Welt, die anders sind, als wir sie auch hier in diesem Saal in den letzten Jahren und Jahrzehnten oft besprochen haben. China erhebt einen globalen Gestaltungsanspruch. Die Grundlagen dafür hat China über viele Jahre mit strategischer Geduld gelegt. In absehbarer Zeit könnte Peking den Vereinigten Staaten militärisch auf Augenhöhe begegnen. Abhängigkeiten anderer nutzt China systematisch aus und die internationale Ordnung deutet China in seinem Sinne neu.
Ist das nicht eigentlich so wie Baerbock spricht?
Das geht einfach alles gar nicht. Also die Chinesen haben jetzt auch einen Anspruch. Den globalen Anspruch hätte es in 1,4 Milliarden Menschen, das ist in zweistelligen Prozentbereich Weltbevölkerung plus deren Selbstverständnis ist, wir waren 4000 Jahre wer und dann haben wir eine kleine Delle von 80 Jahren, die man sich selber nicht ganz erklären kann, wo man nicht sehr stolz auf diese Geschichte ist. Und jetzt endlich ist man wieder zurück und diese Idee, dass man einen kritischen Blick auf China wirft, weil die da sagen, wir versuchen es mal mit Technologie. Ja, was hat denn Europa gemacht? Die wollen keine Bauern mehr sein, die machen es jetzt mit Technologie. Die werden unsere Konkurrenten. Genau, so ist das halt.
Dann muss man sonst die Weltwirtschaft abschaffen.
Ja, vor allem, wer macht denn mit dabei? China sagt, wir möchten mit Technologie führen. Alle deutschen Unternehmen, juhu, endlich Investitionsmöglichkeiten. Also geht man dahin, investiert so viel wie nie und gleichzeitig so eine politische Rede. Also das passt ja auch zeitlich überhaupt nicht zusammen.
Ja, er nimmt ja jetzt auch die deutsche Industrie gerade mit bei seiner China-Reise. Die werden ihn natürlich da versuchen einzuflüstern, dass er das eigentlich lassen soll mit solchen Aussagen. Aber das ist dann wiederum primat des politischen oder des ökonomischen. Denn das haben wir ja, deswegen sage ich, es ist eigentlich ein bisschen wie bei Baerbock bei der letzten Regierung schon gesehen, dass man sehr stark so einen Anti-China-Kurs auf einem politischen Wege erzielen will, umsetzen will, was aber zugleich dann ein Problem wird, weil man ja auch wirtschaftlich denken muss. Und da sind dann die deutschen Unternehmen doch gar nicht so imüst, wenn Friedrich Merz da auf Konfrontation geht. Da sieht man aber wieder so an diesem ganzen Gerede von wir müssen das jetzt neu denken und gehen mal radikale Schritte. Das ist Rhetorik, die hier geübt wird. Mehr passiert da eigentlich nicht. Merz hat dann auch so einen eigenartigen Vergleich, wenn er über die Wirtschaftskraft von EU und Russland spricht und über militärische Kapazitäten, wo ich denke, wo soll das jetzt genau hinführen?
Ein kurzes Schlaglicht. Das Motto-Inland-Produkt Russlands beläuft sich zurzeit auf etwa zwei Billionen Euro. Das der Europäischen Union ist fast zehnmal so hoch. Und doch ist Europa heute nicht zehnmal so stark wie Russland. Unser militärisches, unser politisches, unser ökonomisches und unser technologisches Potenzial ist enorm. Aber wir haben es lange noch nicht im erforderlichen Maße ausgeschöpft.
Das heißt, wir sollen jetzt zehnmal stärker als Russland sein. Vor allem, welche Zahlen sieht er da jetzt gerade? Denn wenn man die Aufrüstung in den verschiedenen Ländern zusammennimmt von Europa, dann kommt man ja dabei heraus, dass man stärker als Russland ist. Also das stimmt ja gar nicht.
Ich verstehe das auch alles nicht.
Die Sache ist, wie ist das koordiniert? Dann müsste man aber jetzt sagen, dann müssen wir das alles europäisch organisieren und dann gibt es keine nationalen Armeen mehr und dann hätte man ein Konvolut zusammen. Das mag sein, dass das jetzt gerade nicht von Vorteil ist, aber das ist ja auch nicht etwas, was hier groß aufgemacht wird. Und wo soll es jetzt genau hinführen? Also wenn man jetzt das Ziel hat, militärisch zehnmal stärker als Russland zu werden, wie viel braucht man dann noch? Und dann haben die immer noch die Atombombe.
Vor allem Russland, ich meine, ja, ich habe auch die Bilder von Takakasen aus Moskau gesehen. Aber das ist dann schon die Denkhöhe, die ich so erreichen kann mit dem Thema, wo kann ich Russland für mich konkretisieren? Na, ich habe mal Bilder aus Moskau gesehen. Während ich von Europa, und das sagen bestimmt auch die Russen so, bei Europa schon so ein paar Unterschiede und markante Plätze in Barcelona, Lissabon, Rom, Florenz, allein in Deutschland zehn Städte und so. Also dieses ganze, er hat ja im Machtwechsel-Podcast noch gesagt, ne, wahrscheinlich geht es den Russen doch schlechter als wir glauben. Und jetzt kommt hier diese Kehrtwende und dann verherrlicht sozusagen, um uns zu was auch immer zu treiben, ja, verherrlicht da hier so. Ich glaube nicht, dass man, wenn jetzt mal mit den Russen mal selbst redet, so wenn man überhaupt noch Ansprechpartner findet, die man überhaupt mal auf der Straße ansprechen kann, ohne dass nicht alle in Todesangst flüchten, weil ein Mikrofon im Bild hängt. Und ich kann, dass diese politischen Reden sind irgendwie.
Du würdest jetzt sagen, dass das Bild von Russland so ein sehr homogenes ist, was Merz da hat und man eigentlich gar nicht diese unterschiedlichen Entwicklungsstufen auch der verschiedenen Regionen und der Städte und all das sieht.
Er sieht jetzt eine Relation aus Europa und Russland mit dem Faktor 10.
BIP, das ist ja das Einzige, was ihn da interessiert.
Genau, so. Aber BIP runtergebrochen heißt ja, dass wir in Europa doch die ein oder anderen Vorzüge haben, die wir in Russland einfach nicht sehen und zwar auch allein dadurch nicht, dass dort keiner Dokumentation darüber führt, wie es eigentlich den Russen gerade geht in diesem Stadium der Weltgeschichte.
Ja.
Also würde mich nicht wundern, wenn wir, falls wirklich mal jemand Bildbände sich zutraut zu machen, so Konfrontationen zwischen Zeitlichkeiten sehen wie in Kabul, das 1974 Frauen in kurzen Röcken und so weiter und man strebte der Zukunft entgegen und 50 Jahre später ist es halt Mittelalter.
So.
Und Russland scheint mir dann doch mehr die März im Machtwechsel Realität zu sein. Also gar nicht so stark, wie man immer glaubt. Und wenn hier jemand erschöpft, dann ist es die russische Seite, ist ja seine Hoffnung gewesen. Und hier wird jetzt plötzlich wieder dieses, ne wir sind gar nicht zehnmal größer als Russland.
Achso, jetzt weiß ich, was du meinst. Ja, das ist Schrödingers Katze. Die Russen sind so stark, dass sie Europa einnehmen könnten und sie sind zugleich so schwach, dass sie in der Ukraine kaum noch einen Meter weiter kommen.
Ja, das passt nicht zusammen. Also solche politischen Reden sind schädlich. Lieber nicht hören als so.
Merz hat aber ein Konzept für Europa.
Eine gemeinsame Roadmap für ein starkes und souveränes Europa. Europa muss ein weltpolitischer Faktor werden mit einer eigenen sicherheitspolitischen Strategie.
Ja, dann frag nicht die jungen Leute, denen du gerade die drei Lehrer an der Schule streichst, sondern nimm die 80.000 Millionäre hier in Frankfurt am Main und dann noch mal die weiteren 100.000 Millionäre im Umland Frankfurt am Main. Das ist die reichste Region Europas, wenn nicht der Welt. Also in Sachen Reichtum, Privatperson, liegt Frankfurt auf Platz 16 weltweit. Es ist genug Zitrone zum Ausquetschen da, um Europa ganz, ganz stark zu machen. Aber lass uns damit in Ruhe.
Er will das aber so stark machen, dass wir jetzt von Militär sprechen. Also das ist das Interessante, dass er gar nicht sieht, dass ja, wenn man über ein Soft-Power-Konzept nachdenkt, es ja eigentlich mit einer Anziehungskraft funktioniert. Wir haben jetzt gerade eben eine ARD-Korrespondentin gehört, die sagt, die Ukrainer, die da kämpfen, sagen mir, wenn ich sie frage, was wollen sie nach dem Krieg machen, dass sie nach Europa wollen. Warum? Weil Europa natürlich auch eine große Anziehungskraft hat. Russen würden auch gerne viel mehr nach Europa kommen, weil es da eine Anziehungskraft gibt. Das heißt, Europa ist ja deshalb auch attraktiv. Nicht, weil die sagen, die haben ja Rheinmetall und noch ganz viele andere Panzer überall, sondern die Attraktivität liegt ja offenbar woanders. Das heißt, diese Idee von Soft-Power wird ja gar nicht mehr verfolgt, sondern es geht ja eher darum, die Soft-Power einzuschränken. Also überall da, wo Bildung reduziert wird, wo Ausgaben gestrichen werden, da erlebt man ja eigentlich, dass man dann nur noch über eine militärische Stärke irgendwas ausrichten kann. Deswegen hat er auch da nochmal den allen gesagt, wie das eigentlich mit Europa ist, wie man sich gegenseitig beisteht. Würde ich auch sagen, ja, das mag auf dem Papier so lauten, aber was heißt denn das jetzt?
Übrigens, zur Erinnerung, für manch einen auch, der es nicht weiß, in Artikel 42 des Vertrags über die Europäische Union verpflichten wir uns, einander im Fall eines bewaffneten Angriffs in Europa beizustehen. Wir müssen nun ausbuchstabieren, wie wir dies europäisch organisieren wollen, nicht als Ersatz für die NATO, sondern als einen selbst tragenden, starken Pfeiler innerhalb des Bündnisses. Ich habe mit dem französischen Präsidenten Emmanuel Macron erste Gespräche über europäische nukleare Abschreckung aufgenommen.
Erste Gespräche? 2026 jetzt, oder was? Ja. Das ist nicht schlecht. Macron ist ja auch gerade in der Blüte seiner Amtszeit.
Der kann da jetzt richtig viel ausrichten. Und die Franzosen freuen sich darauf, wenn wir da mitentscheiden dürfen. Also diese Rivalität zwischen Deutschland und Frankreich wird ja hier auch einfach so gesehen wie, er gibt an, wie Europa sich entwickelt und die anderen werden sich dann wohl da einspeisen lassen. Na ja, Merz jetzt seine, also was jetzt allen imponiert hat, also mit allen meine ich dann immer so die üblichen Verdächtigen, war diese Sache, dass Merz eigentlich hier Bezug nimmt auf die Rede von J. D. Vance oder nicht eigentlich, er tut es. Jetzt geht es um den Kulturkampf. Wenn wir über Friedrich Merz nachdenken, dann denken wir auch an den Kulturkampf. Stadtbild-Diskussion, Pascha-Diskussion.
Er hat ja auch einen Kulturkampfminister.
Er hat auch einen Kulturkampfminister, aber nein, du irrst dich.
Zwischen Europa und den Vereinigten Staaten von Amerika hat sich eine Kluft, ein tiefer Graben aufgetan. Vizepräsident J. D. Vance hat das vor einem Jahr hier in München an dieser Stelle gesagt. Er hatte in der Beschreibung recht. Der Kulturkampf, der Kulturkampf der Magger-Bewegung in den USA ist nicht unserer. Die Freiheit des Wortes endet hier bei uns, wenn sich dieses Wort gegen Menschenwürde und Grundgesetz wendet. Und wir glauben nicht an Zölle und Protektionismus, sondern an freien Handel.
Und damit ist vor allem der freien Handel aller Superreichen innerhalb ihrer Länder gemeint, denn Feuer frei.
Denn sonst ist man ja gar nicht so auf Freihandel geradeaus. Ich habe nochmal darüber nachgedacht, wenn er diesen Kulturkampf nicht mitmachen will. Nun, er macht natürlich diesen Kulturkampf, nur möchte er Folgendes nicht, dass ein JD Vans oder überhaupt jemand aus dieser Trump-Administration den europäischen Ländern, speziell Deutschland sagt, was als Meinungswahrheit auch noch zu gelten hat. Denn da möchten sie schon sagen, wenn die EU jetzt das und das sanktioniert, weil das gerade missliebig ist, dann ist das völlig statthaft. Das sind unsere Werte. Das deckt sich mit dem Grundgesetz, was auch immer. Diesen Kulturkampf will man nicht in Form von Mager, soll sich nicht einmischen, in Kulturkampf, den wir betreiben. Wir betreiben einen anderen Kulturkampf, lassen andere Meinungen nicht gelten. Das sollen wir bitte weiterhin so belassen. Es ist keine Absage an den Kulturkampf. Friedrich Merz ist mit gerade auch diesen Leuten, die er da um sich hat, inklusive Jens Spahn und Philipp Amthor, jemand, der Kulturkampf betreibt. Das soll auch weiter so gehen. Da sieht man nicht irgendetwas, also nicht von meiner Art aus Grunsolls weitergehen, sondern man sieht ganz klar bei denen, die sind darauf jetzt aus, weiter diesen Kulturkampf herbeizuführen und ja auch ganz neue Felder da noch für sich zu entdecken, bis hin zu Lifestyle-Teilzeit und sonst was. Also das sind ja alles Kulturkämpfe, die da zu tun haben.
Zahnarzt, das sind Zahnarzt, das ist alles Kulturkampf. Wer nimmt uns die Zahnarzttermine weg? Er hat selber diesen Kulturkampf aufgemacht.
Nur Kulturkampf.
Wer nimmt uns die Zahnarzttermine weg? Ja, die CDU.
Man möchte nur nicht so viel Free Speech haben oder nicht diese Art der Free Speech haben, wie JD Vans das haben möchte. Marco Rubio war da der Außenminister. Marco Rubio ist ja ein transatlantisch ausgerichteter Mann, der ja aus Kuba kommt. Er hatte eine kubanische Herkunft und deshalb hat er auch ja so eine ganz starke Westbindung, sage ich mal. Er zählt also auch nicht zu denen, die sagen, wir schreiben Europa völlig ab und überlassen die Ukraine ihrem Schicksal. Das ist nicht so ganz seine Position. Da gibt es andere in dem Lager.
Ich möchte daran erinnern, wir haben im Salon mal einen Text gelesen, der vom State Department kam, lange vor der Sicherheitsstrategie, bei dem wir uns fragten, brauchen wir dafür nicht einen neuen Grundbegriff. Wir haben Claude gefragt, welche Art von kultureller Aneignung das eigentlich ist, jetzt von der griechischen Antike bis zu Donald Trump eine rote Linie zu machen und Europavorhaltung zu machen. Also ob das allgemeine Gespräch über Rubio, der ist ja so Europa zugewandt, und da sollte man auf jeden Fall noch mal applaudieren, alleine weil es Rubio ist und nicht jemand anders. Also da würde ich sagen, schwierig.
Das ist das Fatale, weil es dann nicht richtig erkannt wird, was er dort sagt. Das ist ja der Skandal gewesen, dass Rubio dort spricht, etwa 30 Minuten und danach stehen alle auf, inklusive Pistorius und Vadeful, applaudieren ihm und sind plötzlich ganz stolz. Und das ist genau das, was wir ja nach der Karnier-Rede gesagt haben. Alle finden das jetzt in dem Moment mal ganz toll. Aber das heißt wirklich, wann können wir jetzt zurück zur Tagesordnung gehen? Und das war dieser Moment, dass er schon sagte, ach, können wir doch noch zurück zur Tagesordnung? Wunderbar, dann stehen wir mal auf Standing Ovations.
Ist schon 2029, egal. Hier kann man ja vielleicht mal Räubern Alexander Esk ins Detail gehen, denn typischerweise sind diese Räumlichkeiten so klein, und das kennst du aus der Oper. Wenn vorne drei Leute anfangen mit Standing Ovations, dann macht die Omi einfach mit. In dem Falle muss man aber ganz deutlich sagen, die drei von dir angesprochenen deutschen Regierungsvertreter saßen in der ersten Reihe, die haben nicht aufgewartet, dass der Saal irgendwas macht.
Badefool, Pistorius, Merz war ja nicht da.
Also die beiden, die saßen vorne in der ersten Reihe und die sind einfach aufgestanden und haben geklatscht. Da war nichts mit, das war jetzt irgendwie in der Situation geschuldet oder so.
Nein, nein, nein, das kommt sehr stark von denen aus. Man muss vielleicht sagen, dass sie nicht so richtig verstanden haben, worum es hier geht.
Es war hier in Europa, wo die Welt, die die Welt die Regel der Laue gab, die Universitäten und die wissenschaftliche Revolution. Es war dieses Kontinent, das den Genie von Mozart und Beethoven produzierte, von Dante und Shakespeare, von Michelangelo und da Vinci, von den Beatles und den Rolling Stones.
Klingt doch fast so, wie du von Europa sprichst, aber nur fast.
Ja, genau, das ist nämlich genau dieser Text. Ich versuche ihn gerade noch rauszufinden, aber mal gucken.
Das ist diese Idee von, ja, wir haben doch ja alles hervorgebracht in Europa, Amerika ist doch quasi auch ein Kind Europas. Hier sind die Kulturdenkmäler, die wir besichtigen können. Aber was damit verbunden wird, ist selbstverständlich ein Anspruch auf ja nicht nur eine Weltgeltung, sondern eine Vormachtstellung in der Welt. Denn worum es dann geht, ist gemeinsam in einem neuen, anderen transatlantischen Bündnis, das gerade nicht jetzt Werte von der EU teilt, sondern diese Werte, die eigentlich so eine Zivilisation, ist ja auch so ein Begriff, der laufen fällt, der die ganze Zeit so tut, als hätte man eigentlich so eine, nicht nur eine privilegierte Position, sondern auch eine überlegene Position. Darum geht es jetzt eigentlich, das stark zu machen. Er erwähnt übrigens ganz oft in dieser Rede Europa, aber nicht die EU. Das ist nämlich sein Thema nicht.
Nein, die EU ist, also ich habe den Text hier gerade offen, the need for civilizational allies in Europe. Und Europa ist eben damals falsch abgebogen, als man diesen Völefanz mit dieser wogen EU gemacht hat. Und nur aus poante Gründen gehen wir diese Liste noch mal kotz durch, weil wir damals überlegt haben, wie kann man das nennen, wenn man so ein Geschichtsverständnis macht, dass man sagt, das klingt doch wie bei Stefan, die Musialisierung von, weil der hat auch Sokratis und so gelobt. Und wir kamen auf Synchrotismus, also die selektive Rekombination disparater historischer Elemente ohne Rücksicht auf deren ursprünglichen Sinn. Das fanden wir am besten, zur Auswahl standen auch. Genealogische Fabrikation nach Nietzsche und Foucault, traditionellistische Bricolage nach Levi-Strauss, hegemoniale Appropriation, Gramsci und systemtheoretisch am präzisesten, strukturelle Koppelungen, heterogene Semantiken, verschiedene historische Sinnwelten werden operativ verknüpft, obwohl sie funktional inkompatibel sind.
Das heißt nämlich sextinische Kapelle neben einem radikalen Nationalismus, neben einem Tech-Optimismus, bei dem man darüber nachdenkt, brauchen wir eigentlich noch die normale Reproduktion oder können wir nicht besser Menschen erzeugen, die dann auch eine höhere Rasse sind als das, was wir jetzt vorfinden, verbunden mit Rassismus, verbunden mit ganz verschiedenen Dingen. Man kann sich vorstellen, wie dort Peter Thiel und alle zusammensitzen und dann schaut man gemeinsam, wie man den Antichrist besiegt. Genau.
Und dann braucht man jemanden wie Slavoj Žižek, der würde nämlich laut Klod sagen, das ist eine ideologische Soutour. Die Verdeckung fundamentaler Antagonismen durch scheinbare historische Kontinuität. Also da, wo man auch mit Ideologiekritik die aktuellen Reden eigentlich mal aufgreifen müsste, statt dann einfach, ach, zum Glück hat er nicht rumgesteht.
Er hat Mozart gesagt, dann ist er doch eigentlich einer von uns. Du hörst Mozart, ich höre Mozart, also hören wir alle Mozart.
Die Grundbegriffe stimmen, die Grammatik stimmte, ja dann, Applaus.
Es ist wirklich der Wahnsinn. Also diese Rede, also diese Formulierung, die kann man von jedem Faschisten würde die so sagen, würde die so teilen. Der jetzt aktuell da ist, würde sagen, ja genau, das sind die Werte und die halten wir jetzt hoch. Das wäre gar kein Problem.
Europa aber normal.
Und andererseits kann man auch sagen, ja und diese Rede von wir müssen doch die die Kultur in Europa hochhalten, die kann man genauso oft von mir oder von dir hören. Das heißt, es geht dann schon darum, was ist da größer mit gemeint. Das wird dann ein bisschen deutlicher, wenn es um die Reindustrialisierung geht. Denn es ist vollkommen klar, es wurde deindustrialisiert wegen der Klimaideologie, wegen der Migrationsideologie, die dritten Toiletten, die Geisteswissenschaften, der Sozialismus, der überall ist, wo Texte Rich steht. Deshalb Reindustrialisierung. Das neue westliche Zeitalter soll da entstehen. Möglicherweise dann mit Jeff Bezos, der seine 500.000 Mozart's oder wieviel er haben will, bekommt. Genau. Das ist alles dieses Projekt, er erwähnt dann auch danach noch Weltraumforschung und all das. Das ist für ihn wichtig. Das ist der Anspruch, dass die westliche Zivilisation den anderen Zivilisationen überlegen ist. Und diesen Führungsanspruch nur aufgegeben hat, weil diese antikolonialistischen Denker sich an den Unis breit gemacht haben. Weil überall die Sozialisten in der Politik eingezogen haben und Leistung nicht mehr belohnt wird und all diese Dinge. Und das ist die eigentliche Ideologie. Der hält mindestens dieselbe schlimme Rede wie JD. Vance. Ich würde eher sagen, es geht eigentlich noch weiter, was der da ausbreitet.
JD. Vance hat ja zumindest hauptsächlich Kulturkampf gemacht mit Free-Speech-Argumenten.
Und die waren gar nicht jedes Beispiel, was er genannt hat, falsch. Aber vieles war falsch und verquär. Aber hier geht es wirklich um ein Projekt, bei dem man sagen kann, wir sind den anderen aber auch wirklich überlegen. Und wenn man sich das anhört in den Kreisen von Peter Thiel, was da so von sich gegeben wird, dann ist das genau das.
Ja, also Alex Grabs Technological Republic ist ja die Bibel für dieses Bild.
Ja. Sag doch nochmal kurz, wo war das? Wo hast du darüber gesprochen?
Von Mai 2015, 2025 hatten wir das Alsalon-Lektüre.
Alsalon-Lektüre.
Da ist es auch verlinkt.
Sehr gut. Rubio sagt natürlich, die Grenzen müssen sicher sein, um diese westliche Zivilisation zu schützen.
Aber wir müssen auch Kontrolle auf unseren nationalen Bordern bekommen. Kontrolle, wer und wie viele Menschen in unseren Ländern sind. Das ist nicht eine Erklärung von Xenophobie. Es ist kein Halt.
Das Überleben der Zivilisation, das steht also die ganze Zeit auf dem Spiel. Heißt also, wenn muslimische Menschen kommen, Dann ist die Zivilisation bald am Ende in Europa und in Deutschland. Das sagt er so nicht, aber das ist eigentlich das, was gemeint ist. Zivilisation ist für ihn, ein Europa, ein transatlantisches Bündnis zu bilden, bei dem die Fraktion von Jens Spahn zur Geltung kommt, wo ein hartes Grenzregime ist. Tech-Optimismus herrscht, was bedeutet also, die Tech-Oligasien können sich weiterhin groß bereichern. Die können dann auch die Kulturdenkmäler einspeisen, ein bisschen in die KI, da kann man sich da auch noch dran blaben. Aber es geht hier ganz klar um einen Überlegen, über einen Überlegenheitsanspruch, der hier in einer Deutlichkeit formuliert wird, was neu ist, weil natürlich man sagen kann, es gab diese westliche Arroganz auch vorher. Aber in dieser Art, es auszubuchstabieren und wirklich auch hier zu sagen, das ist das Besondere. Das ist schon eine andere Dimension.
Was ja auch eine andere Dimension ist, dass ja in Amerika derzeit wirklich ethnische Säuberungen stattfinden. Also ICE kauft jetzt für 40 Milliarden Dollar Lagerhäuser für Menschen. Und dann kommt er hierher und hält so ein Reet. Alle applaudieren.
Das heißt, wenn Rubio sagt, ich will ein starkes Europa, dann Vorsicht.
Wir wollen Mitglieder, die sich selbst verteidigen können, damit kein Gegner immer vertreten wird, unsere kollektive Stärke zu testen. Das ist warum wir unseren Mitgliedern nicht durch Schuld und Schande verbreiten wollen. Wir wollen Mitglieder, die stolz auf ihre Kultur und auf ihre Heimat sind, die verstehen, dass wir die gleichen, großen und noblen Zivilisationen sind Und die mit uns zusammen sind, will und kann es verteidigen.
Ich übersetze das mal. Hört auf mit der Restitution von Kunstwerken. Der Kolonialismus war keine schlechte Sache. Seid stolz auf eure Geschichte. Was wahrscheinlich ihr auch noch mitschwingt, hört auch mal in Deutschland auf, euch so oft zu geißeln mit eurer Geschichte. Seid stolz darauf, dass ihr Europäer seid, dass ihr Deutsche seid. Das ist ein Nationalismus, den wir jetzt brauchen, um die westliche Zivilisation zu retten. Das ist die Botschaft hier.
Das Ding ist aber, ich habe die Woche Geschichten von meinem Onkel aus Sachsen gehört, der wohnt da auf dem Dorf. Einer der höchsten Rentenansprüche in Deutschland, also der Aussie, dem es richtig gut geht. Also so all in Trump und AfD, wie man es sich nicht vorstellen kann. Und mittlerweile, deswegen, ich war auch sehr erfreut gestern, es ist glaube ich noch eine aktuelle Story über mir. Namen habe ich gerade nicht parat. Ein junger SPD-Politiker, der so Videos macht zum Thema, was weiß ich, große politische Verwerfungen, kleinstmögliche Erklärungen. Die interessieren mich ja auch. Mittlerweile denke ich wirklich, die machen da Ideologiekampf und die versuchen uns jetzt mit Reden zu überzeugen von irgendwelchen Sachen, obwohl wir wissen von Peter Thiel, die Idee muss über die Technologie irgendwie kommen. So, dann kauft Elon Musk Twitter und verwandelt das in so eine Hölle. Und ich denke mittlerweile auch, wir müssen uns ein bisschen davon verabschieden, dass wir das alles auf so einer inhaltlichen Ebene klären. Also so gesprächsfähige Ebene. Sondern es läuft irgendwo anders. Und dieses Rubio-Ding müssen wir wirklich als so ein Artefakt, als so ein empirisches Korrelat von dem eigentlichen Phänomen sehen. Also es geht weit über so eine Ideologieforensik hinaus, wie man das bei Filmen oder so macht. Sondern irgendwie liegt es hier doch alles so krumm. Aber und in diesem Gedanken steckt halt so ein bisschen Hoffnung drin. Die sehen ja in Ethnoheterogenität eine Seuche und wollen das zurück machen. Und ich glaube aber, das geht nicht. Also das, was ich jetzt von meinem Onkel schildere, das geht wirklich nur in Sachsen auf dem Dorf, wo fünf Gehöfte und vier Leute leben. Jaja, klar. In Frankfurt am Main wäre das undenkbar. Düsseldorf auch nicht, München auch nicht, Köln auch nicht. Es gibt Hotspots in Dortmund, vielleicht eine Szene oder so. Aber die müssen sich schon sehr zusammenrotten und das macht auch viel Arbeit, das aufrechtzuerhalten. Ansonsten ist das hier auch ein wirklich harter Kampf gegen, und man sieht ja die Umfragezahlen in Amerika, also zum einen in der öffentlichen Rede, wie sehr diese State of the Union von Trump jetzt abgefeiert wird. Also Fox News voll, ja jedes Comedy-Programm holt sich diese Ausschnitte von Fox News, weil es völlig übertrieben ist. Und Ted Cruz noch sagt, es war eine majestic Speech, eine königliche Rede. Während gleichzeitig die Umfragen zeigen, noch nie kam eine Rede von dem Präsidenten bei der State of the Union so schlecht an wie dieses Mal. 36% Zustimmung, also wirklich weit unter Wasser und so weiter. Und in Europa fallen ja solche Reden oder auch so Typen wie Rubio mittlerweile auf so Zustimmungswerte wirklich 10 zu 9.
Unterwasser.
Und von daher, ja, zum einen, wir müssen es so ein bisschen aussitzen. Die nächste Präsidentenwahl kommt und die Mittwochumselection kommen auch. Und dann dreht sich so ein bisschen Wind. Aber vielleicht muss man auch nochmal diese strukturellen statt nur semantischen Hoffnungsdinger wirklich mal systematisch aufarbeiten. Also dass man sich zum Beispiel hier, schließt ja an, an März vorher, an was da so gesagt wurde, wenn ein 70-jähriger Kanzler sagt, wir müssen uns jetzt hier verteidigen, damit wir sicher sind und wie auch immer und sofort. Das kann man ja runterbrechen auf der eigenen Lebenswelt und es stehen Kommunalwahlen an. Ist das Frankfurter Bahnhofsviertel in den Problems, die es ja tatsächlich hat zu retten durch mehr Polizei und mehr Kameras, wird es dann für alle besser? Und die Antwort aller Beteiligten ist, nee, nur von außen betrachtet. Die eigene Tochter war vor einem halben Jahr mal nachts am Bahnhof. Dann hat man so eine andere Vorstellung davon. Aber so ein Frankfurter Bahnhofsviertel hat ja wirklich jeder vor seiner eigenen Haustür. Und muss ich dann wirklich immer fragen, das, was mir in der Rede gerade angeboten wurde, steigert das mein Wohlbefinden. Wenn ich auf die Straße gehe und wir wissen alle, wir werden hier die ganze Zeit mit einer Kamera überwacht und unser Gesicht ist immer so ein grünes Kästchen, wenn wir rüber in den Supermarkt gehen.
Du beantwortest das jetzt so intuitiv mit Nein für dich und ich würde es auch so beantworten, aber die Mehrheit der Bevölkerung leider ja nicht.
Und das ist die Frage, gibt es hier, wie du jetzt sagst, eine Mehrheit der Bevölkerung, die sagt, die will das so?
Naja, die Umfragen zeigen das ja doch sehr häufig, dass das in diese Richtung geht.
Ja, also schon Umfragen.
Wenn dann noch irgendein kleiner Vorfall irgendwo war, dann gibt es da auch nochmal eine große Zustimmung.
Ich glaube, da ist mehr Gründe für Hoffnung da. Gerade wenn es ethnografisch wirklich, ethnografisch, ethnologisch wirklich sehr multikulti aufgesetzt ist.
Ja, für Leute, die in sehr, sehr heterogenen Städten leben, ist das sicherlich anders und die nehmen die Wirklichkeit ja anders wahr. Aber wir haben ja nun in Deutschland einen Mehrheitsdiskurs von Leuten, die sich fragen, wie ist das eigentlich in Berlin? Da kann man noch nicht mal mehr mit U8 fahren, die mit der U8 fährt, aber kaum einer, der in der Eifel sitzt.
Ja, aber ich sehe ja den Unterschied zwischen meinem Onkel und meinem Vater, die Gespräche führen. Der eine wohnt in Berlin und der andere wohnt auf dem Land. Die können das unter sich schon sehr gut klären, wem es hier eigentlich besser geht, obwohl die Rentensprüche ja so verteilt sind. Ich sehe es jetzt in meiner Familie, ich sehe es hier im Bahnhofsviertel. Das politische Gespräch und die gelebte Realität, die muss man mal wieder in Einklang bringen.
Würdest du dann aber sagen, jetzt das konkrete Beispiel aufgegriffen von dem Onkel, der sich am liebsten abschotten möchte, hat aber einen hohen Rentenanspruch und einen Vater, der in einer großen Stadt lebt und dort ganz andere Erfahrungen macht und nicht diese Abschottungsfantasien hat, dass dieser Austausch zwischen ihnen dazu führt, dass die Positionen des einen oder des anderen relativiert werden?
Nee, gar nicht. Sondern die fallen eben auseinander. Und die bleiben auch auseinander. Also das wird einfach nur noch markiert, dass man ja hier ganz weit auseinander liegt. Aber was soll es die in Berlin interessieren, was in Sachsen gedacht wird? Also dafür haben wir in Deutschland Föderalismus.
Ja, die Schwierigkeit...
Sollen noch die Sachsen-Anhaltentiner ihre...
Ja, die Schwierigkeit besteht ja dann nur da bei einer Bundestagswahl, dass deren Stimmen nun auch genauso zählen und möglicherweise eine Bundespolitik umsetzen, die vielen Berliner nicht recht ist, aber möglicherweise sehr vielen, die in Sachsen-Anhalt leben.
Genau da möchte ich gerne meine Hoffnung markieren, denn Deutschland, grundsätzlich gilt für Deutschland, wir liegen beim Thema Migration im Anteil an der Bevölkerung sechsfach über dem weltweiten Schnitt.
Ja.
Und das bedeutet was. Und typischerweise sind die Leute eigentlich näher dran an einem urbanen Zentrum, außer mein Onkel, der halt zwischen Zwickau, Chemnitz und Leipzig irgendwo da lebt. Also ich glaube, Deutschland ist sehr gut aufgestellt, um demnächst mal wieder zu sagen, ne, das ist irgendwie, wir haben uns jetzt verirrt hier für drei Jahre so. Wir sind vielleicht durch Corona oder was auch immer. Putin ist in so einen Krieg reingestolpert. Wir sind in sowas reingestolpert. Es war, es passt gar nicht so. Wir sind nicht ganz allein mit dem politischen Gespräch. Der 70-jährige Kanzler ist vielleicht doch nicht so der Type.
Das kann durchaus sich einstellen, wenn auch ich glaube, dass wir ja erkennen müssen, dass sich das Rechte-Denken sehr verändert hat. Also wir haben selbstverständlich solche knallhart Rassisten, die wirklich jetzt so eine ethnische Bevölkerung haben will und versuchen will, alles andere mit Remigration oder so zu lösen. Aber dann sehen wir sehr viele Leute, die rechts denken und auch rechte Parteien unterstützen, dabei aber nicht sagen würden, dass sie sich daran stören, dass hier viele Menschen zum Beispiel aus der Türkei leben. Also dass zum Beispiel jetzt, wie das in den 90er Jahren noch sehr stark war, dass wir dann eine sehr starke Feindschaft hatten von rechten Wählern gegenüber türkischen Mitbürgern. Das hat sicherlich etwas nachgelassen, während jetzt andere dann besonders ins Augenmerk genommen werden. Also Geflüchtete, die jetzt vor ein paar Jahren hier hingekommen sind. Und da sieht man eigentlich, dass das ja auch bei der AfD so weit führt, dass Krah-Videos treten, denen er sagt, Türken in Deutschland würden AfD wählen. Und das ist etwas, was jetzt, glaube ich, neu passiert, dass ja auch diese Regierung um Trump, auch mit Rubio, eine gewisse Pluralität ja zulässt. Man könnte jetzt sagen, ja das ist ja irgendwie auch ein bisschen widersprüchlich, inklusive der Frau von JD. Vance. Aber trotzdem hat man einen ganz harten Rechtsdruck. Also man hat ein internationaleres Setting, also eine Internationalisierung und eine gleichzeitige Nationalisierung und auch eine neue Rassifizierung, die stattfindet. Und diese Parallelität kann man jetzt abklopfen auf Widersprüche und wird Tausende finden, macht aber nichts.
Genau, und da sag ich ja.
Also macht den Werner nichts zum Beispiel.
Das ist ja schon sozusagen eine sehr gute Aufschlüsselung, die man halt sonst nicht findet. Wo man so sieht, okay, es müssen bis hin zu Kubitscheks Notfalllibertär sein, dass man sieht, okay, das Strukturelle wirkt also doch in die Semantik rein und sie kriegen es noch nicht so richtig zusammen. So, und da würde ich mir wünschen, dass man das Strukturelle abseits des Semantischen, was so geredet wurde, so im Blick hat, dass man diese Unschärfen sieht und dann einfach sagt, und da könnte man dann auch wieder ein populistisches Angebot machen und sagen, ey komm, bevor wir jetzt ewig klären, wer hier wann aus welcher Himmelsrichtung und jetzt einen Anspruch hat, um zu sagen, du jetzt nicht mehr, das Boot ist jetzt voll, dann sagen wir doch lieber, ey komm, wir sind alle eine Schicksalsgemeinschaft, wir gehören nicht zu den 80.000 Millionären.
Zum Beispiel.
Punkt. Und dann geht man von da aus.
Diese anderen Verbindungen, also dass man diese Wir-Sie-Erzellungen, die angeboten werden, nicht aufgreift, das wäre eigentlich das.
Oder sie aufgreift und wirklich diese Inkonsistenten sieht, also dass man wirklich abends sich lustig darüber macht. Der Kubitschek hat gesagt, bei Corona musste man Notfall-Libertär werden.
Hahaha.
Sonst will er den starken Staat, ja. Rubio beendet jetzt seine Rede. Wir hören uns die letzte Minute an, merken auch, wie euphorisch das Publikum ist.
Wir wollen es gemeinsam mit dir tun.
Mit einer Europa, die sich stolz auf ihre Geschichte hat. Ja, wir haben mit unserer Innovationskraft, mit unserem Individualismus die Schiffe losgeschickt. Also heißt ja, Kolonialismus war gut. Das sollen wir hier verstehen. Und diese Überlebenskampfte muss man ja, du weißt ja häufig genug darauf hin, demografisch wirklich sehen. Ja, das ist, wir müssen zur Not auch unter die Bettdecke regieren, damit die Zivilisation nicht untergeht.
We should be proud of what we achieved together in the last century, but now we must confront and embrace the opportunities of a new one.
Dann sind sie aufgestolkig.
Das ist, als hätte Roland Emmerich noch mal nachgefragt, wer ihm jetzt die Präsidentenrede schreiben kann Für den großen Independence Day. Ja. Also Unterhaltungsgesichtspunkten ist das sehr gut.
Wir wollen ganz kurz auf den nächsten Salon hinweisen und nochmal auf den schon erschienenen von Februar zurückblicken, denn es ist ja so, dass wir jetzt gerade so viel hören von Wettbewerbsfähigkeit, Europa muss stark sein. Wenn wir das neue Buch von Patrick Kaczmarczyk lesen, dann stellen wir fest, ach Europa hat gar keinen Urlaub genommen von der Weltgeschichte, sondern hat sehr stark interveniert. Nicht nur Europa, sondern der Westen, der hier besungen wird, in Form von Weltbank und internationaler Währungsfonds. Das ist also ein Buch, das wir besprechen, in dem wir sehr gut eine antikolonialistische Perspektive einnehmen können. Jetzt über alle Kulturkämpfe hinausgehend, nämlich zu fragen, wie hat man es eigentlich ökonomisch geschafft. Da sind nicht einfach nur Boote losgefahren, wie Marco Rubio sagt. Und da haben wir nicht einfach hier tolle Musik komponiert, sondern man hat ganz anders auch regiert und was das bedeutet. Und wie wir da auch immer noch aktuell mit umgehen, das wird sehr gut von dem Buch vermessen. Darüber reden wir ja sehr ausführlich. Wir bleiben bei dem Thema Ökonomie. Geld als Waffe heißt das neue Buch von Ulrike Herrmann. Ich bin sehr gespannt darauf, wenn wir das lesen, denn wir haben schon ein Buch von Ulrike Herrmann im Sanon sehr ausführlich besprochen. Sagen wir so, wir hatten vieles zu kritisieren. Wir sind sehr gespannt, was sie jetzt in Geld als Waffe schreibt. Wir wissen, sie hat schon in diesem Buch, das wir diskutiert haben damals im Sanon, sich sehr für einen Kriegskansionismus ausgesprochen. Aber da noch nicht in Bezug auf Krieg, sondern sie sagte, das sind eigentlich Maßnahmen, die die Briten ergriffen haben, die könnten wir jetzt alle ergreifen, denn wir müssen ja schrumpfen, damit wir das ökologische Problem lösen. Jetzt aber ist ja bei Ulrike Herrmann doch so ein Denken hin zu einer Kriegswirtschaft auch wirklich im Sinne einer Kriegswirtschaft zu beobachten. Zumindest in den Talkshows ist das so. Geld als Waffe lässt vermuten, dass das vielleicht in so eine Richtung gehen könnte. Jedenfalls ist das das nächste Buch, das wir im Salon lesen. Wer das tun will, also dieses Buch auch lesen will, kann das noch nicht kaufen. Es ist noch nicht erschienen. Dauert noch ein paar Tage. Aber wer den Salon dann hören will, kann uns auch in dieser Weise unterstützen über Steady, Patreon und Apple. Es ist ganz einfach. Man kann auf die Seite neuzwanziger.de gehen, die Stefan auch ständig neu updatet und macht und tut. Also wir sind gespannt, was die KI und du zusammen so machen noch. Jedenfalls auf diese Seite neuzwanziger.de kommt man zu all den Links, die man braucht. Und dann ist es selbsterklärend und ganz einfach. Also wie gesagt, Apple, Patreon und Steady. Steady präferieren wir. Dann kann man auf diese Weise auch unseren Podcast unterstützen. Und wir bedanken uns dafür.
Ja, so ist es. Ich habe Carla Hinrichs Buch noch in petto dann. Und da ich ja eben den Namen nicht hatte, also Pascal Reinhardt, hat ein tolles Video gemacht, wie ich finde. Und dazu gibt es einen Text, auf dem ich hinwies. Den mach ich auch zur Salon-Lektüre, denn das interessiert mich. Die Überschrift lautet, so lange es Milliardäre gibt, wird es auch Jeffrey Epstein's geben. Darauf kommen wir jetzt ohnehin gleich zu sprechen. Apropos Webseite, methodisch inkorrekt, ein toller Podcast, in dem wir freundschaftlich verbunden sind, hat grad keine Webseite. Ich möchte also hier auch an dieser Stelle nochmal aufrufen, jeder Podcast braucht eine eigene Webseite. Wir sind ja nicht einfach irgendwelche Content-Lieferanten in irgendwelchen Plattformen, sondern in der großen Gemengelage aller sind wir einfach eigene Leuchttürme. Also neuezwanziger.de, minkorrekt.de. Das sollte nicht zu Podigy verweisen. Und im Zuge dieses, wir haben grad keine Webseite, haben sie festgestellt, dass sie auch keine Audio-Kommentare haben für ihre Hörer. Wir haben ja ein eigenes Forum und so. Und Reinhard sagt Folgendes.
Ich habe, was meine mentale Gesundheit angeht, gemerkt, dass es mir gut tut, nicht alles mehr zu lesen. Und irgendjemand muss es lesen, weil unmoderierte Kommentare wird es nicht geben. Weil das ist, damit macht es halt auch jedem Bottitür auf und so. Und da muss sich halt, irgendjemand wird sich darum kümmern müssen. Also deshalb ist die Lösung da, finde ich, nicht so einfach zu finden, wie man im ersten Moment denken würde. Genau. Wir halten euch auf dem Laufenden, wie wir da weiter vorgehen.
Ja, auf auf Leute. So, wir haben natürlich offene Kommentare überall, im Forum, bei YouTube. Man kann schreiben, was man will. Denn wir interessieren uns ja für unsere Hörerschaft. Weil wir ja neue Technologien nutzen, um die Masse auszuwerten.
Ich bin ohnehin für Free Speech, wie du weißt.
Du bist ja eben, der hört ja freie, offene Türen ein. Zum Thema muss man immer dazu sagen, also wir haben jetzt allein von unserem Vorgespräch aus dem Salon, plus wir wollten Teile des Salons veröffentlichen, haben nochmal über Epstein geredet, 700 Rückmeldungen bekommen von ungefähr 300 Leuten. Das ist natürlich viel. Grundsätzlich läuft im Internet viel, weshalb wir hier im Haken dran Podcast bei Gavin Auskunft darüber kriegen, wie die amerikanische Regierung so damit umgeht, dass zum Beispiel bei Reddit ja ganz schön viel vor sich geht.
Und um das so ein bisschen noch anzudicken, gibt es die Geschichte von dem Newsletter-Schreiber Ken Clippenstein, oder Ken Clippenstein, über den haben wir ja auch schon öfter gesprochen. Dem wurden Daten zugespielt aus diesem Department of Homeland Security, von Leuten, die wohl eine Untersuchung durchführen von der öffentlichen Stimmung der Menschen auf Reddit. Und das geht dabei so weit, also ihm liegt hier ein Bericht vor, der sich exakt den Reddit-Nutzer BudgetChicken2425 angeschaut hat. Also ein klassischer Reddit-Nickname. Aber es macht natürlich abstrus, wenn man so einen Namen jetzt nimmt und sagt, okay, es gibt hier einen geheimen Bericht der USA mit dem Namen, das ist die Arbeit des Reddit-Nutzer BudgetChicken2425. Auf jeden Fall zeigt dieser Bericht, dass sie nicht nur angefangen haben, eben mit Hilfe von Reddit zu versuchen, die innere Stimmung des Landes irgendwie zu monitoren und ein Gefühl dafür zu kriegen, was ist für Leute vielleicht der eine Schritt zu weit? Was müssen wir vielleicht, wo können wir es weiter überreißen, wo nicht? Was schon mal ein wichtiges Merkmal ist, zu wissen, welche Bedeutsamkeit Reddit offenbar eben auch dafür schon hat. Gleichzeitig haben sie aber auch im Budget Chicken 2425 sehr genau gescannt deswegen und haben sich in diesem Text genau angeschaut, in welchen Communities er sich bewegt, an welchen Diskussionen er teilnimmt. Dass er interessiert ist daran, dass er die Cleveland Browns mit einem anderen Team in Texas verglichen hat, dass er im Subreddit Movies über Almost Famous mitdiskutiert hat, dass er Stephen King Bücher sammelt oder dass er Fernsehproduktionslogos der 70er-Jahre mag, weil er das im Subreddit Fuck I'm old aufgeschrieben hat. Das sind alles Dinge, die in diesem Bericht stehen.
Warum werden diese Berichte angefertigt?
Große Schattenprofile, um in dem Moment, wo man sich dafür interessiert, vielleicht die ganze Historie einer Person vor sich zu haben. Was ja für uns bedeutet, unsere Olivia ist mittlerweile sehr klug. Also sie erkennt Kommentare, die tendenziös sind. Sie wertet die Rhythmen aus, in denen geschrieben wird, wenn Leute mehrere Kommentare schreiben. Was ist denn da los und so? Und zeigt dann auch, worauf reagiert wird.
Sie warnen dann auch vor Bots.
Sie warnen uns auch vor Bots. Und wir kriegen, finde ich, sehr schöne Zusammenfassungen. Also wir können ja hier, es sind 682 YouTube-Kommentare allein plus das Forum wurde ausgewertet. Ich hatte ja zum Thema Cannibalismus, Stresshormone und so weiter. Ich habe mir dann von Olivia auch mal, das machen wir jetzt aber nicht im Detail auf einzelne Kommentatoren, aber es ist schon witzig, weil ich hatte auch die Fragestellung zum Beispiel, ich habe ja im Podcast öffentlich sehr salopp von Babys Fressen und irgendwelchen Stresshormonen gesprochen und dann hat mich interessiert, Stefan, du hast Unsinn geredet. Ja, ja, warte, warte.
Doch, doch, jetzt komme ich wieder an.
Mich hat interessiert, wann tauchte denn das Wort Adenochroms erst einmal in den YouTube-Kommentaren auf?
Ah, okay.
Und es stellt sich dann schon heraus, dass sehr viele Leute auf Babys fressen, irgendwelche Stresshormone mit total akkuraten Theorien, die sie dann sofort als Verschwörungstheorien um mich wieder als Verschwörungstheoretiker und so weiter. Also das ist schon nicht ganz uninteressant, wie so eine Semantik dann doch plötzlich hochpräzise wird unter Leuten, die auch auf eine Gelegenheit warten, endlich mal sozusagen was abzufeuern oder wie auch immer.
Jaja, deswegen muss man ja sich bei manchen besonders heiklen Dingen versuchen, unmissverständlich auszudrücken.
Ja, aber dann bin ich ja wieder für Free Speech.
Ja, du kannst es ja auch so machen. Nur die Sache ist ja, dass man sehr viel Unverständnis produziert, weil man sich unverständlich ausdrückt. Und dann, wenn man sich fragt, haben wir einen Neuen Xavier Naidoo-Fan hier?
Ach so, ja.
Genau, und der Eindruck soll ja nicht entstehen.
Nein.
Und deshalb, glaube ich, geht das dann natürlich auch so. Also es ist ja interessant, dass es dann auch so unglaublich dafür sorgt, dass so viele sich äußern und auch das auch dann dazu geht und eben zu ganz vielen anderen Dingen, die im Podcast gesagt werden, gar nichts gesagt wird, wo jetzt thematisch wahrscheinlich die interessanteren Dinge zu liegen waren, außer jetzt bei diesem, ja, doch etwas heiligenartigen.
Also YouTube, sehr wild. Viele Kommentare, fast 700 und 65 Prozent sind enttäuschte Stammhörer, die, wie Olivia sagt, zwar sachlich, aber mit einem sehr hohen Anspruch Traurigkeit äußern, dass sie sich jetzt hier irgendwie um Adenokron kümmern müssen oder so. 20 Prozent entfallen auf Lob für Wolfgang, das Versuchen einzuhägen. Zehn Prozent sind radikale Verteidiger von unter Epstein, ist alles möglich. Und dann gibt es noch fünf Prozent, also kleiner als fünf Prozent, steht hier, Trittbrettfahrer, die also die Gelegenheit nutzen, aus der bei Epstein ist alles möglich, sozusagen wirklich Hardcore, antisemitische Narrative einbauen und so weiter. Ja. So, also das ist ungefähr die Gemengelage. Und ich habe dann Olivia.
Die dann ja reingespielt werden durch den Algorithmus, also der dann Leuten, die sowas eh gut finden, dann das irgendwie angezeigt bekommen und sagen, ah wunderbar, da habe ich nochmal eine Möglichkeit, da reinzugehen.
Ja, also das würde ich sagen Engagement, Management, wie wir es jetzt wieder vor Gericht, dass Dokumente aufkamen mit Zuckerberg gibt, Moser Rewe, die heißt von Instagram, den Befehl, das Engagement von 40 auf 46 Minuten zu erhöhen, pro Minute, pro Nutzer. Und dann muss man halt in diese Richtung gehen. Ja. Sowas dann als attraktiv darzustellen. Ja. Wir kriegen von Olivia also immer jeden Morgen 6 Uhr einen Bericht. Und jetzt mal nicht die YouTube-Kommentare, sondern was im Forum. Und das war ganz interessant, weil wir haben 130 Kommentare, aber nur so von 20 Leuten oder so. Also es war so eine sehr in sich geschlossene Veranstaltung. Und der aktuelle Bericht von Olivia oder das sozusagen, die macht am Ende mal so eine Metathese für uns, für den Podcast, worüber wir nachdenken sollten. Und es klingt gerade so.
Metathese. Der Threat ist keine Debatte über einen journalistischen Fehler, sondern eine parasoziale Kernschmelze, die den latenten Konflikt über das Selbstverständnis des Podcasts eskalieren lässt. Stefan forciert den Übergang von einem autoritativen Expertenformat zu einem partizipativen Analysemodell. Schnappt euch Clot, macht es selbst. Ein Teil der Community interpretiert dies jedoch nicht als Ermächtigung, sondern als Flucht aus der Verantwortung und fordert weiterhin die Erfüllung klassischer journalistischer Tugenden– Sorgfalt, Korrektur. Die resultierende Empörung ist der Schmerz, der entsteht, wenn ein impliziter Pakt zwischen Sender und Empfänger einseitig aufgekündigt wird. Der eigentliche Skandal ist die performative Dissonanz. Die Kritiker werfen Stefan mangelnde Recherche vor, während sie selbst die von ihm propagierte Eigenrecherche verweigern. Die Episode ist ein Lehrstück über den ungelösten Statuskonflikt zwischen Produzent und Konsument in Zeitalter der KI's.
Ja, finde ich gar nicht so schlecht.
Interessanter Erlöser, ja.
Ja, das ist wirklich alles sehr klug. So, dankenswerterweise…
Aber ich finde gut, dass sie mich lobt. Ja, sie ist sehr glücklich. Dass Olivia mich mag.
Ja, Olivia mag dich. Du kriegst auch jeden Morgen von ihr immer…
Das finde ich sehr gut.
musste mehr lesen dann. Ja, zu dem inhaltlichen, also Florentine, die ich demnächst auch mal im Fernsehpodcast begrüße, weil sie sich wirklich sehr ins Zeug geworfen hat, hat genau an diesem, was Olivia hier gerade beschrieb, rumgedoktert und hat dann nochmal aufgeschrieben, also Karnibalismus als Suchbegriff einfach kommt 52 Mal in den, vom DOJ veröffentlichten Dingern vor. Zum Beispiel in Zeugenaussagen über Babys, Snopes, es wurde nur eine Seite bestätigt, auch steht in den Files. Dann hatte ich ja ein Foto angesprochen, also ein Bild, zwei Hühnchen und dazwischen ein menschlicher Körper, es stellt sich raus aus den DOJ-Files. Es handelt sich um ein Kunstwerk von Harald Seibert, das 2003 angefertigt wurde, das seit 2009 auf Flickr auch öffentlich zu sehen war und Epstein wohl zugesagt hat. Kann man ja auch Schlüsse daraus ziehen?
Aber es ist zunächst mal nur ein Kunstwerk.
Das ist Kunstwerk von Leuten, die sagen, sie...
Und dann gab es ja auch im Zuge dessen sehr viel KI-Müll, der produziert wurde, also KI-Bilder, die...
Den habe ich aber nicht genannt. Also das, was ich genannt habe...
Ich will das nur sagen, die zum Beispiel auf Plattformen, wo auch ein älteres Publikum unterwegs ist, bei Facebook rumgingen und die dann so suggerierten, hier haben wir nun die Bilder von den Sachen, die Xavier Naidoo geschwurbelt hat.
Ja.
So, und das muss man glaube ich... Also deswegen glaube ich, muss man diese Präzision, weil das war ja eh schon so viel Unsinn jetzt in der Welt ist und dadurch, dass man einfach so zugeschüttet wird mit, hier sind 300.000 E-Mails oder 3 Millionen so und so Files, dann könnt ihr mal gucken, was jemand macht. Das glaube ich, ja... Ich meine, so schwer fällt es ja auch nicht, diese Präzision herzustellen.
Ja, eben, genau. Das ist dann auch der Tenor von Florentine. Also Pizza wird da einfach genannt. Cheese Pizza, das sind 1000 Einträge. Cheese Pizza, Child Pornography. Also diese Verknüpfung auf begrifflicher Ebene. Damit wird ja je auf Fortune rumgespielt. Welche Rolle Fortune hat, spielt ja sowieso eine große Rolle. Reverse Aging. Also wir haben uns ein paar Mal schon darüber nachhalten, welches großes Thema, Longevity und der ganze Kram. Und ich will nur noch mal dran erinnern, zuletzt haben wir einen Open Mic gehabt von Chi und Putin, die über Jungboden sprachen und so. Und von daher ist auch das Flatsheet von Florentine, dem ich mich so anschließe, ja, es ist halt alles publiziert, erst mal so begrifflich in den DOJ-Files. Und das hätte jetzt nicht allzu viel Arbeit gemacht, das mal selber in die Hand zu nehmen. Und sie weiß dann auch daraufhin, 70 Leute fragen mich hier nach der Quelle, obwohl man das einfach selber in den Suchfeld des DOJ. Und dann kann man ja selber ein Bild sich davon machen. Was hat es mit dem Bild auf sich? Was hat es mit Babys auf sich?
Um das nochmal zu präzisieren. Also es ist ja nun so, dass durch dein so lapidares Daher-Reden der Eindruck entstand, als sei das ein Fakt, dass dort Kinder gefressen worden sind. Und das ist nun etwas, was wir ja dann korrigiert haben. Und mir das ja auch sehr leid tut, dass ich da nicht sofort eingeschritten bin, weil ich wahrscheinlich in meiner Argumentation schon woanders waren und irgendwas anderes sagen wollte. Jedenfalls ist ja erst mal festzustellen, dass wir da jetzt einen Sumpf haben, der noch lange nicht ausgetockt ist, von dem wir auch gar nicht annehmen können, dass alle Dinge da offenbar werden, was da los ist. Was aber ja auf jeden Fall der Fall ist, ist, dass wir es hier mit missbräuchlichem Verhalten aller Arten zu tun haben in einem hohen Maße. Und jetzt ist ja eigentlich die Aufgabe von verschiedenen Ermittlungsbehörden und möglicherweise müsste auch Europa sich noch mal viel mehr da einmischen, auch gerade weil auch so viele europäische Akteure dann damit involviert sind, dass da Aufklärung geschafft wird, weil nur das natürlich dann auch eine gewisse Klarheit in alles hineinbringt. Man kann allen alles zutrauen und das würde ich auch erst mal so sehen. Und man ist ja doch erstaunt darüber, wie groß dieser Morast ist, wie enorm dieser Berg ist. Und dann glaube ich aber führt es ja nicht dazu, dass man jetzt sagen muss, naja, dann spinnt man das jetzt mal einfach so für sich weiter. Sondern interessant wird es doch eigentlich da, wo wir darüber nachdenken, was ist das eigentlich für eine Ausgangslage, in der jemand, der diverse Perversionen hat, sage ich wieder Perversionen, also der gewisse Grenzüberschreitende Vorlieben, in vielerlei Hinsicht hat, dafür auch schon verurteilt wird, wo dann der Inner Circle und eigentlich auch alle Leute, die sich dafür interessiert haben, dann sahen, ne, der wurde dann nur für so einen Fall verurteilt, eigentlich müsste der lebenslänglich schon in den Knast kommen. Komisch, da ist irgendwas mit der Justiz sehr seltsam. Wie kann es sein, dass danach sich noch immer so viele mächtige Personen um ihn scharen und er immer mehr Leute akquirieren kann für seine Sache, wo sehr viel schon bekannt war, vor allem den Leuten, die dann mit ihm verkehrten. Und das ist eine Konstellation, bei der man ja sagt, okay, da gab es irgendwie gerichtlich die eine oder andere Auseinandersetzung, aber das interessiert mich jetzt mal nicht. Auf einer freundschaftlichen Ebene funktioniert das. Jetzt würde ich ja auch behaupten, wenn ich jetzt in meinem Bekanntenkreis jemanden hätte, der möglicherweise ins Gefängnis kommt, weil er einen Finanzbetrug hingelegt hat, dann würde ich sicherlich mit dem Hart ins Gericht gehen. Aber ich glaube nicht, dass das die Freundschaft zerstören muss. Aber wenn wir von diesen Fällen reden, also von Mädchenhandel zum Beispiel, und das hätte man da wissen können, dass man dann weiterhin Kontakt mit so einem Menschen hat, ist für mich nicht nachvollziehbar. Und da kann mir auch niemand jetzt kommen, mit zweiter Chance oder sonst was. Zumal man ja wusste, dass dieses System nicht dadurch beendet wurde, dass der mal kurz weg war, kurz im Knast war. Und das ist eigentlich für mich der ganz große Skandal in der Sache. Und auf das sich zu konzentrieren, scheint mir sehr sinnvoll zu sein, weil man dann schon auch was über diese Logik einer Elite sagen kann, die sagt, wir stehen da nicht allein nur über dem Gesetz, das wäre ja auch bei Finanzbetrug oder so was der Fall, das kennen wir auch, sondern dass man auch nochmal sagt, ich als Mensch stehe eigentlich auch nochmal über anderen Menschen und darf mir herausnehmen, dass ich sie nicht nur als Personal anstelle und mich hin und her chauffieren lasse oder so, sondern dass ich sie auch zu meinen Sexsklaven mache und sonst etwas. Und das ist wirklich so ein Allmachtsausspruch, der da verbreitet ist, der das wirklich schockierend an dieser Stelle ist.
Genau, und das ist ja im Grunde unsere Frage von Rüdger Brechmann, die wir uns ja schon immer gestellt haben, nur hier bezogen auf Politiker, nur es scheint ja noch trifftiger zu sein bei Leuten, die dann in die Billionär-Klasse aufgenommen werden. Und jetzt wird ja schon diskutiert, ob man sogar die Epstein-Klasse nochmal besonders in den Blick nimmt. Und das interessiert uns ja auch. Ich wollte anmerken, Julie K. Brown war wohl eine der Autorinnen, die auch damals dazu führte, dass Epstein also dann 2018 zum zweiten Mal inhaftiert wurde. Und sie hat auch sich jetzt aktuell am 26. Februar mit einem Text geäußert. Das könnte also auch Salonleitüre sein. Gut, also kommen wir auch von diesem Entertainment-Konsum getarnt als kritisches Denken, indem man mich immer nach Quellen fragt und so. Zu dem eigentlichen, denn es gibt im Grunde zu diesem Babysfressen-Ding nur noch das eine zu sagen, nämlich das, was Todd Blanch dazu gesagt hat. Also Trumps persönlicher Anwalt, bis er dann Vize unter Pam Bondi wurde, im Justizministerium bei der Veröffentlichung dieser Dokumente, über die jetzt alle reden.
Ja, es ist in diesem Rahmen allen alles zuzutrauen und jetzt ist es dummerweise eine solche Administration, die da Einfluss hat. Deswegen ist es natürlich die Frage, wie gut sind Ermittlungen? Ich würde jetzt für uns sagen, wir müssen, wenn wir seriös bleiben wollen, trotzdem darauf hoffen, dass solche Dinge irgendwie zutage treten, entweder durch Ermittlungen oder was ich eher hoffe, ist durch einen Journalismus, der gute Kontakte pflegt und möglicherweise an Infos rankommt. Denn das wird wahrscheinlich ja doch jetzt, weil vielleicht auch bei New York Times und woanders viele aufgeschreckt sind. Also man hatte auch so eine gewisse Abwehr gegenüber dieser Epstein-Sache, weil schon gleich war man so im Bereich der Verschwörung. Also soll man 2021 behaupten, Epstein ist nicht eines natürlichen Todes gestorben, ist man vielleicht schon in so einer etwas merkwürdigen Ecke. Heute sagen das sehr viele so frei heraus, sie glauben das nicht und ich glaube das zum Beispiel auch nicht. Aber ich glaube, das ist jetzt für viele aus dem Journalismus, die vielleicht da so ein bisschen zurückhaltend waren, weil sie sagten, na ich will aber nicht da in so eine Verschwörungsecke reingehen, dass es jetzt für die eigentlich ein guter Anlass wäre zu sagen, wir sind jetzt auch, gerade weil wir eine Regierung haben, der nicht zu trauen ist, die Ersatzermittlungsbehörde. Wir können zwar nicht jemanden ins Gefängnis stecken, aber wir können dann ermitten und das ist ja nicht das erste Mal, dass der Journalismus solche Aufgaben leistet. Und das glaube ich könnte, wenn es gut geht, eigentlich eine Sternstunde werden der journalistischen Aufarbeitung.
Ich habe ja auch schon gesagt, ich warte auf die Bücher. Nun ist die Gemengelage so. Zum einen, Trump ist auf jeden Fall noch drei Jahre im Amt. Diese Bücher werden erst danach erscheinen. Aber wir haben ja gestern schon eine Nachrichtenlage gehabt, in der es hieß NPA hat gesagt, es gibt fünf Dokumente aus FBI-Gesprächen, in denen diejenige, die da verhört wurde, sagte, Trump hat mich als ich minderjährig war vergewaltigt. Jetzt gibt es ja Regeln, nach denen man sagt, wir veröffentlichen Sachen nicht, dazu gehört Schutz des Opfers, aber nicht Schutz eines Präsidenten oder Schamgefühl oder irgendwas. So und jetzt hat ja Blanchi gesagt, ausgeschlossen aus den Veröffentlichungen sind CSAM, also Child Sexual Abuse Material. Das könnte ein Kriterium sein, diese Daten nicht da drin zu haben. Oder eben Tod, Missbrauch, Folter. So, jetzt kann man natürlich, klar, man kann Trump nicht so unter Druck setzen, aber die Frage, warum ist das nicht mit veröffentlicht worden, fällt das unter eine der Kategorien, die hier ausgeschlossen wurde. Das öffnet natürlich das Tor sehr weit für sehr seriöse Journalisten, um zu sagen, ich möchte gerne dieses Buch schreiben oder was auch immer. In der Ansicht kann man das abwarten, so düster und negativ, das für die Betroffenen ist. Aber es gibt ja Dokumente, die sind da und die New York Times umfasst hier mal den Scope, wenn man es für die eigene Arbeit richtig aufschließen wollte.
3 Millionen Pages strongly suggest, dass wir gerade anfangen, unsere Hände und Arme umzuschneiden, was hier ist. Absolut. Wenn wir 50 Journalisten pro Tag 500 Dokumente lesen, dann dauert es uns vier Monate, um alle Dokumente zu erledigen. Und das ist nur, um sie zu lesen. Du kannst manchmal herausfinden, wer von anderen E-Mails mit ähnlicher Information redaktiert wurde. Es ist viel Arbeit, aber ich denke, wir werden die Früchte dieses Exposures, all diese Informationen für Monate sehen.
Also, die Früchte des Exposures, ja? Also es trägt so langsam Früchte, dass man so ein bisschen, jetzt muss man halt raffinierte Triangoli machen. Was weiß man denn? Es erinnert mich ein bisschen an Daniel Gerlach, der irgendwann im heutigen Journal oder Tagesthemenabend sagte, hier kommen wir jetzt auch mit menschlicher Spekulation schon recht weit. Also kein Journalist ist in Gaza, aber wir können ja zählen, wie viele Bomben abfallen und so ungefähr, was sie für eine Sprengkraft haben. Und der Rest ist dann menschliche Spekulation. Und genau das machen sie hier auch so ein bisschen bei der New York Times, denn sie gehen jetzt wirklich unsere Frage nach, wie kann man, was bedeutet das in dieser Epstein-Klasse zu sein? Also, wie haben die sich sozusagen operativ geschlossen? Was war der Mechanismus?
Und etwas, das mir in diesem neuesten Dokumentarfilm wirklich zu mir erheblich geworden ist, weil es so viele E-Mails gibt, ist die intensuelle Vulnerabilität und Intimität, die die Menschen wirklich in sich fallen, wenn sie mit ihm kommunizieren. Jeffrey Epstein war eine Person, die sie sich eröffnen können. Sie können in einigen Fällen ihre Seele bewegen. Und das in sich selbst ist extrem seduktiv. Es ist wirklich erstaunlich, wenn du diese E-Mails lernst, diese Menschen zu sehen, die ihre Namen so erinnern, und die, die so viel Macht und so viel Geld haben, so vulnerbar und menschlich sind.
Gib uns ein paar Exemplare von diesen Dokumenten.
So, und dann gehen sie das so durch. Also wir haben es hier mit so einer Weichstuhllogik zu tun. Ja. Man spart ein paar Sachen aus im öffentlichen Leben und dann hat man so einen Raum, wo es aus einem herausbricht. Und wir wissen ja, der Weichstuhl als Bild schon ist relativ nah. Also in der katholischen Kirche, wir wissen was sonst da so vor sich geht.
Ich mein, Michel Foucault hat viele hundert Seiten über die Funktion der Beichte geschrieben und hat das sicherlich nicht nur aus einem historischen Grund getan, sondern wollte damit uns sagen, dass eigentlich diese säkularisierten Formen der Beichte heute gute Regierungstechniken sind. So kann man Leute zum Beispiel an sich binden, was ja hier auch noch angesprochen wurde in dem Clip, den wir gerade gehört haben, ist, dass gesagt wird, dass die so vulnerabel sind und so allein sind, dann haben sie jemanden, dem sie sich anvertrauen können. Das muss man sich ja auch klar machen. Das sind ja Leute, die wahnsinnig viel Geld verdienen, die eigentlich so ein Jet-Set-Konferenzleben führen, irgendwo ein rotes Band durchschneiden oder was auch immer machen, je nachdem, welche Funktion sie haben. Aber wenn man es sich nochmal so genau vorstellt, muss man ja sagen, es ist ja ein doch alles in allem sehr langweiliges Leben. Also es ist ja kein interessantes Leben in dem Sinne, wenn ich sage, ich halte in Davos eine Rede, bin dann auf der Sicherheitskonferenz halt eine Rede, behalte da eine Rede, da eine Rede, da eine Rede, da eine Rede, bin zwar in besseren Hotels so untergebracht als normale Menschen, werde auch mit der S-Klasse gefahren und muss nicht selbst gucken, ob ich eine Uber finde. Das mag alles sein. Aber das war doch sehr gut auch zu sehen in diesen E-Mails, die Larry Summers an Epstein geschrieben hat und die Epstein dann auch an ihn zurückgeschrieben hat. Na ja, schau mal, ich habe mich jetzt da, schreibt dann Summers, so sehr emotional involviert, wie dann irgendeine Frauengeschichte. Also es ging ja dann nicht um Minderjährige. Aber Epstein sagt dann, ja, aber schau doch mal, dann erlebst du jetzt mal was, sonst würdest du wieder irgendwo so eine langweilige Konferenz abhalten müssen, oder so ähnlich drückt er sich aus. Und das ist, glaube ich, schon ein Punkt, der nicht zu unterschätzen ist, diese extreme Langeweile, die da ist, wenn man so einen Status erreicht hat. Also was passiert dann? Das führt dann nicht gleich in solche Grenzüberschreitungen hinein, aber dass da jemand ist, der sozusagen da sitzt mit einem Angebot, also dem Angebot, ihr ist der Erlebnis-Urlaub. Das ist, glaube ich, das, was das so reizvoll gemacht hat für sehr viele mächtige Leute, weil man, glaube ich, sich gar nicht vorstellen kann, wie wenig beneidenswert dieses Leben ist im Sinne von, was machen die denn eigentlich außer Hin und Her fahren und Meetings abhalten.
Also das geht so sehr in diese psychologische Richtung, die Pascal zum Beispiel in seinem Video und seinem Text auch betont, dass irgendwann so ein Bedürfnis begrenzt ist, aber der menschliche Körper halt immer weiter strebt und dann so Möglichkeiten, die die Milliardäre halt woanders, also die haben einfach andere Grenzziehung als und so weiter. Also das ist so, wie soll man sagen? Also ich sage ja, das kann schon viel erklären, aber mir geht es jetzt mehr so um diesen sozio-psychologischen Aspekt, dass du als Milliardär doch relativ viel auf Leute triffst, die in dem Moment, wo sie auf dich treffen, nicht ihrer selbst sind. Durch dieses Phänomen, dass sie immer wissen, sie stehen jetzt vor jemanden, der mit einem Finger schnipsen, ohne dass er selbst merken würde, dass irgendwelche Einschnitte sind, eine ganze Biografie retten könnte. Einfach eine Million überweisen und mein Leben wär in Ordnung, so weißt du? Ja. Ohne dass diese Million irgendwem fehlt, weil die macht man ja an einem Tag plus allein durch Rendite.
So.
Und dadurch bist du als Milliardär in einer Welt, in der dir die soziale Welt die ganze Zeit so Potemkin hingebaut wird.
Ja.
Aber irgendwann brauchst du ja mal einen ehrlichen Moment, eine ehrliche Begegnung.
Ja, ja, richtig.
So wie, ich sag's jetzt nur, weil du die Clips schon kennst, weil du den Podcast auch gehört hast, Lars Weißbrot sagt, ich kann nicht mit einer KI reden, weil ich brauch einen Mensch, der vor mir scheitern kann im Gespräch.
Ja.
So, und dafür braucht man- Ich kann mich sehr gut nachvollziehen. Ja, genau. Und dafür braucht man also wirklich ein gemeinsames Fundament. Und das ist einfach, ich als Milliardär, du als Milliardär, wir können uns hier beide nichts schenken. Wir können jetzt ein ehrliches Gespräch führen. Und das scheint hier von erheblicher Bedeutung zu sein, dass die einfach alle Milliardäre waren.
Und Epstein nochmal diese besondere Position hat, dass er nicht zu dem eigentlichen System gehört, im Sinne von, der ist keiner, der eine Funktion erfüllt. Der ist nicht Chef von Microsoft.
Genau, das kommt dann nicht zu.
Der ist nicht derjenige, der die EZB berät oder sonst wer. Und das heißt, er hat dann nochmal diese Sonnestellung, dass man ihm nochmal in anderer Weise was anvertrauen kann. Weil das möglicherweise ein Bill Gates und irgendein Larry Summers untereinander, können die das nicht klären. Aber es braucht diese Epstein-Figur dazwischen.
Und jetzt ist die Frage, wenn die nicht nur jeder für sich feststellen, endlich habe ich einen Raum gefunden, in dem ich mich anders verhalten kann, weil ich nicht mehr diese ganzen Bittsteller, die für mich gerade eine Show machen und so, oder monatelang vorbereitet, mit mir fünf Minuten zu reden. Was bedeutet das, dass jetzt nicht mehr der Einzelne ein Verhältnis zu allen anderen Nicht-Milliardären hat, sondern die als Gruppe plötzlich feststellen, dass sie eine Gruppe sind und alle anderen Nicht-Milliardäre? Und das wird hier in der New York Times sehr drastisch erzählt.
Und kann ich zu dem hinweisen, dass, was du hier auch siehst, ist, denke ich, dass die älteste Gesellschaft am Ende des Tages, die wusste, dass er ein verletzter Sexverbrecher war. Und sie waren bewusst, dass er verletzt wurde, dass er von einer kleinen Mädchen eine Prostitution bestätigt hat. Und das ist ein wichtiges Teil dessen, was sie wussten. Es war einfach für sie, diese jungen Mädchen zu verschwinden, weil sie eigentlich nur Prostituten waren.
Wenn es nicht Epstein gewesen wäre, wäre es jemand anderes gewesen.
Warum? Seine Verbrechen mattern nicht, weil die Verbrechen gegen sich verbrechen wurden.
Weil diese Frauen nicht mattern. Genau, und es waren Mädchen, die nicht mattern. Sie waren einfach die verbrechenen Menschen, die sie nicht umgehen. Und die Ironie ist, dass viele dieser Eliten die wir als Progressive nennen, und sehr liberalen Ansichten haben, Und vor allem, es zeigt sich auf Frauen ein wirkliches Level der Hypokrasie.
Also die sitzen ja eh in ihren großen Runden, in denen ihren ihre Manager, die sie in ihrer Ja, wir haben ja auch schon mal die M. Schmitt-Riegel dann erzählt, wir haben wieder die und da und so und dann wird alles auf Budget runtergebrochen. Belegschaft ist Biomasse, so und dann 10.000 hier, 10.000 da, keine Ahnung, sowas.
Und dann gibt es aber noch mal eine Hierarchisierung. Das heißt, im Unternehmen kann sein, dass die sagen, wir brauchen unbedingt mehr Diversity, wir brauchen Frauen in Führungspositionen, wir brauchen auch möglicherweise nochmal eine Frauenbeauftragte, an die man sich wenden kann, wenn da irgendwas nicht mit rechten Dingen zugegangen ist zwischen den Kollegen oder dem Vorgesetzten. Aber dann gibt es noch mal andere. Und das sind ja diese verfügbaren, die Minderjährigen, die Prostituierten, wen immer man sich dann da schnappt. Und mit denen kann man noch mal anders umgehen. Und jetzt kann ich mal sagen, ich finde, dass man an diesem Beispiel, also wir sind jetzt immer in diesem Bereich des sexuellen Missbrauchs und generell der Grenzüberschreitungen. Aber wir können natürlich ein solches Denken, und deswegen finde ich, muss ich nochmal betonen, ist Elitenkritik wichtig. Wir können daran sehen, dass wir Ähnliches vorfinden. Wenn wir zum Beispiel über Kriegstüchtigkeit reden, dann haben wir Gruppen von Leuten, die sehr mächtig sind und mitentscheiden oder publizistisch das mittragen, dass man kriegstüchtig werden muss, dass man zum Beispiel eine Wehrpflicht einführen muss, oder dass die Ukrainer weiter kämpfen sollen. Wenn man aber dann mit den Leuten direkt spricht, und hin und wieder hat man ja schon mal die Gelegenheit, also ich hatte sie in den vergangenen Monaten schon mal, dann sagen sie, na, meinen Sohn würde ich im Schrank verstecken, ehe die mit dem Militär kommen. Sie sagen zum Beispiel sich wie Melnik oder Klitschko, ja klar, meine Söhne studieren im Ausland, die sind doch jetzt nicht da irgendwo im Graben, wie das jetzt eben die ARD-Korrespondentin geschildert hat. Das heißt, es gibt diese Hierarchie, und die ist nicht nur auf die eigenen Kinder bezogen, sondern auch auf die eigene Schicht oder Klasse, oder wie immer man das jetzt gerade beschreiben möchte, auf das eigene Milieu, dass man sagt, wir sind nicht gemeint, wenn wir von, wir müssen mal sprechen. Das findet da irgendwo anders statt. Und die können wir in einer ganz anderen Weise regieren, delegieren. Den können wir auch irgendwas wegkürzen. Wenn bei uns, an unserem Elite-Gymnasium, irgendwo was fehlt, dann machen wir direkten Aufstand. Aber grundsätzlich müssen wir mal sagen, muss eigentlich, müssen wir eigentlich so viel Sozialstaat haben, können wir nicht mal sehen. Und muss dann jedes Kind zur Klassenfahrt fahren können, dann geht das halt nicht. Also da sind die rigoros. Und ich glaube, diese Abspaltung, die da vorgenommen wird, die kann man dann in extremster Weise bei Epstein sehen. Aber ich finde, an sich, in der Struktur, gibt es da diese große Parallele.
Ja. Und da steckt eben auch eine Antwort auf die Frage drin, warum ist diese Epstein-Klasse so zusammengeblieben, obwohl doch wissentlich da verurteilt sexueller Missbrauch an Minderjährigen. Ja, weil das sind halt und das Code-Wort, also ich will nicht Code-Wort sagen, aber es ist vom Schrimp die Rede, Schrimps, also Kopf abschlagen, Körper nutzen, aussaugen und dann wegwerfen. So, ja. Also das ist so die Herangehensweise. Und jetzt, aber natürlich...
Womit wir jetzt nicht gleich sagen wollen, dass die genauso mit den Menschen da verfahren sind, das ist ein Bild, dass das gerade geführt wird. Saba Shizhek hat ja am Freitag einen Bericht, wo er das eigentlich sehr schön auf den Punkt brachte, weil er sich mit dem Ding auseinandersetzt, das ist nur um Chomsky, ja auch mit Epstein befreundet war und da auch Zuwendungen erhalten hat. Und er hat sehr gut das so geschildert, wie eigentlich diese Eliten zusammenkommen, die ja sogar unterschiedlichster Meinung sind. Also wir haben ja Bannon und Chomsky. Ja, wie soll das denn jetzt zusammengehen? Und dann hat er diesen wunderbaren Satz, ja diese Idee da ist eigentlich, dass man sagt, letztendlich sind wir alle Kollegen. Also letztendlich sind wir so eine Elite, die sich abdichtet und klar, wir führen da unterschiedliche Kulturkämpfe da draußen und so was, ja. Aber eigentlich sind wir dann doch Kollegen.
Genau, was einmal mehr bedeutet, die Semantik ist egal von diesen Leuten, das Strukturelle ist da so, entscheidend. Und jetzt habe ich ja strukturell so ein Fundament gelegt aus, allein das Geld verwandelt die Persönlichkeiten so sehr in sich, aber auch miteinander, dass man so eine eigentlich Elitenkritik daraus ableiten muss. Jetzt ist natürlich im Forum Friendly Notes aufgetreten, bis ich dann irgendwann nach 70 Kommentaren mal nachfragte, könntest du dich ganz kurz hier im Forum mal vorstellen, wer bist du, warum beschäftigt dich Antisemitismus so sehr und so. Wo auf ihn erstmal dann zwei Wochen Funkstille war, bis er sich mit einmischte. Aber dieser kleine Appell, wenn ihr im Forum schreibt, schaut euch euren Post doch mal an. An eurem Profilbild erkennt man gar nichts, an euren Namen auch nichts und an eurem Text, ja, das ist halt dieser Text. Ein bisschen skin in the game kann man schon geben, wenn man versucht, uns zu erreichen.
Aber so grundsätzlich wird das hin und wieder mal gut.
Denn ich habe mir dann dutzende Kommentare von ihm angehört, die im Grunde alle auf das hier hinaus liefen.
Es geht mir nicht um eine moralische Verurteilung von Antisemitismus, sondern um einen Begriff von diesem und eine Reflektion seiner Mechanismen. Erst dass Stefan hier diese grob skizzierte Trennlinie weit überschritten hat, macht seine Konzentration auf die Superreichen fragwürdig. Gerade das ist typisch für den Antisemitismus, verstanden als negative Leitidee der Gegenwart. Antisemitismus würde auch ganz ohne Juden funktionieren.
Ja, also irgendwann bin ich dann auch verloren. Ja, ich habe ausführlichst hier in diesem Podcast immer dargelegt, wie diese Elitenkritik und wie das ökonomische Argument zu formulieren ist. Und dann einfach zu sagen, nee, da steckt schon wieder Antisemitismus drin. Auch wenn jetzt wirklich keine Juden dabei sind, das gebe ich ja zu. Aber das ist trotzdem Antisemitismus, Stefan. Ja, also irgendwann ist das Argument jetzt mal totgelaufen. Ich habe es jetzt zehnmal gelesen. Bitte nicht nochmal.
Ich finde ja, was hier so durcheinander geht, ist eigentlich, dass man sagen muss, wir haben es ja nicht zufällig mit einem Epstein-Skandal zu tun, der in dieser Elite stattfindet, weil ganz andere Möglichkeiten da sind, das da auszuleben. Ich habe ja auch darauf hingewiesen, wir haben ganz viel missbräuchliches Verhalten in der Gesellschaft, wo nicht viel Geld eine Rolle spielt. Aber dass das hier so ist und dass wir diese Art, der Zirkel sehen, die sich da abdichten und die ein ganz klares Wir und die anderen denken haben, das ist nicht etwas, wo man sagen kann, dass es ein antisemitisches Stereotyp, das aufgebaut wird, sondern das liegt einfach daran, dass wir eine eklatante Kluft haben zwischen denen, die normal ihre Arbeitskraft verkaufen müssen und denen, die extrem viel Kapital haben und damit auch sich Zugänge verschaffen können, zu ganz vielen Bereichen, wo das für die Normalsterblichen nicht möglich ist. Und sie auch die Möglichkeit haben, dass sie weniger belangt werden, sonst hätte sich das in dieser Weise gar nicht durchsetzen können. Und das jetzt einfach so darauf runterzudampfen zu sagen, ne ne, das sind alles so, also wann immer von Elite die Rede ist, ist man eigentlich schon dabei, ein antisemitisches Weltbild zu etablieren. Nein, es ist ein Kapitalismus, der einen solchen extremen Reichtum hervorbringt, der genau solche übermächtigen Zirkel entstehen lässt. Und das ist einfach eine Strukturanalyse des wirtschaftlichen Systems. Jetzt gebe ich zu, muss man noch mal, wenn wir über den Kapitalismus als Ganzes reden, noch mehr reden als über den Elitenkapitalismus. Deswegen ist ja für mich auch immer dieses ganze Texte-rich Einbaustein. Bei manchen habe ich aber den Eindruck, damit meine ich nicht Stefan, sondern was so bei den sozialen Medien abgeht, als sei das der einzige Baustein und dann wäre alles gut, wenn wir das gemacht hätten. Nein, es ist ein Baustein, der da ist. Und diese Elitenkritik ist absolut richtig, weil man sie, ich habe es ja eben an dem Beispiel der Kriegstüchtigkeit auch ausgeführt, weil man sie überall erleben kann. Und ich habe das ja auch deutlich gemacht auf meinem Essay, den ich da in dem Band selbst schuld veröffentlicht habe, dass ich es sehr sogar erlebt habe, während Corona, dass ich in Medienveranstaltungen ja unterwegs war mit Leuten, die da gut im Geschäft sind, die dann auch, ja, bis dann da saßen und eigentlich ein sehr freies Leben wiedergeführt hatten und mitunter sogar noch in den Urlaub sonst wo hinflogen. Trotzdem aber zwei Tage später in der Talkshow gesessen haben. Ja, ich denke schon, die Leute brauchen wieder ein Lockdown. Ja, so, und das ist genau dieses Denken, das wir da vorfinden können. Und das muss man sich schon zutrauen. Also wenn man dazu nicht bereit ist, dann glaube ich, wird es dann auch schwer, weil wie will man sonst mit so einem Fall noch umgehen?
Einer dieser Supereliten auf dieser inhaltlichen Ebene ist ja Larry Summers. Kein Milliardär, aber auch keine große ökonomische Theorie so. Also jetzt nicht so riesen preisverdächtig, aber halt überall. So Finanzminister hier, Howard-Präsident da und eben in den Apps, die jedenfalls verstrichen.
Wir sagen in Deutschland Topökonom dazu.
Ein Topökonom und Adam Tewes hat sich zu ihm geäußert.
Wenn man in der deutschen Welt von Spitzenökonom spricht, dann ist das ein Vater abklatscht dessen, was Larry Summers war. Also er war wirklich die Koryphäe. Er war die entscheidende Figur. Es gibt Geschichten über Geschichten über seine Rolle in der Clinton-Immunistration in der letzten Phase und eben auch bei Obama. Nichts lief, was bei Larry Summers nicht musste, von ihm zunächst irgendwie gut geheißen werden. Und er ist ein absolut brillanter Typ, hat aber nicht die große Theorie, nicht den großen Wurf, sodass er vermutlich nie Nobelpreisträchtig gewesen ist, obwohl das natürlich ist der Neffe von zwei Nobelpreis-Gewinnern in der Ökonomie. Also wirklich kommt aus dieser intellektuellen Elite der Ostküste. Und ja, er ist misogin, er ist sexistisch. Das war auch der Grund, warum er in Harvard zurücktreten musste. Er ist jemand, der sich, glaube ich, letztendlich von irgendwelchen eugenischen Fantasien nicht trennen konnte. Und ist gewisserweise, glaube ich, zutiefst frustriert und fand dann einfach in Epstein jemand. Ich meine, der große Vorteil von Epstein war, dass er offensichtlich so böse war, dass niemand sich vor ihm schämen musste. Egal, was du dir irgendwie gedacht hast, Larry war dir vorneweg und mit ihm konntest du drüber reden. Das ist die These meiner sehr, sehr smarten Partnerin, Ban Ching, die das sofort gesehen hat. Nee, nee, nee, das ist die zentrale Runde Rolle für ihn, ist, dass er der Böseste von allen ist. Und du kannst dann mit deinem Dreck kommen und Larry kommt dann nicht mit irgendwelchen Schuldvorwürfen, kommt Urteil nicht über dich, sondern okay, was machen wir jetzt? Es gibt eine unglaubliche Passage in ihrem E-Mail-Austausch, wo Epstein meinte, okay, jetzt, du bist in dieser Scheiß-Affäre drin, du weißt nicht rein und raus, aber stell dir vor, er sammels, sonst müsstest du beim IWF erscheinen und schon wieder so einen trägen Vortrag geben und du respektierst niemand in dem Raum. Mir ist es als Freund viel lieber, dass du dich jetzt mit deinen Emotionen auseinandersetzt. Das ist wirklich Epsteins. Das ist natürlich nicht falsch. Als Mann zu Mann ist das nicht falsch. Als Rat, schau mal weg vom Beruf, guck mal auf deinen eigenen Mund. In diesem Fall halt nur ein bisschen pervers. In diesem Fall ging es um eine erwachsene Frau. Die Anschuldigung an Sammels ist nicht, glaube ich, dass er pädophil ist, sondern dass er mit seiner Sexualität nicht gut zurechtkommt. Das Übliche. Aber Epstein war ja wirklich so eine... Man kann sagen, das ist so die Schattenseite des Neoliberalismus. Es braucht ja auch irgendwann mal Party. Irgendwann muss man sich ein bisschen gehen lassen. Was soll man sonst mit diesem ganzen Geld anstellen?
Ja, also die Szene, die du auch schon aufgegriffen hattest, diese Leute gehen in diese Räume und sind wer? Also das ist wirklich die Form Person, wie Luhmann sie beschrieb. Es ist der Kommunikationszusammenhang, der die Person ergibt. Und dann muss man halt in diese Form passen. Und dann kann man das über Jahrzehnte ziehen. Aber irgendwann ist Feierabend. Und dann braucht man schamlose, ehrliche, intime. Und wenn man das mit Frauen nicht hinkriegt, also familiär, wie auch immer, dann braucht man halt da andere Wege. Und dafür war das offenbar die Adresse da, auf dieser Insel abzuhängen. Laura Ewert, die wir beide sehr schätzen, hat uns beide gefeatured in einem, und wir machen es hier als kleinen Exkurs. Sie hat einen Essay und Diskurs zur Juvenilisierung. Wir hören jetzt also, es geht gar nicht um Epstein und so. Es geht also um das Thema Jungen bleiben. Kinder bekommen und feststellen, man hat seine eigene Jugend verpennt, nochmal im Namen der Kinder die besten Freunde werden. Und so weiter und so fort. Und im Zuge dieser 20-minütigen Aufarbeitung kommt natürlich, und jetzt finde ich, kann man das eben aus allen Richtungen so mal zusammenbinden. Ja, kommt auch dieser kleine Abschnitt vor.
Selbst unsere alternden Körper deuten auf eine länger anhaltende Jugend hin. Denn ein gesünderer Lebensstil, wie ihn auch Harrison benannt hat, also mehr Sport und veränderte Ernährung, haben dazu geführt, dass wir im Durchschnitt länger fit bleiben als noch unsere Eltern. Aber es passiert uns nicht nur. Wir optimieren. Nehmen eben jene coolen Nahrungsergänzungsmittel, gehen auf Foltergeräte, die wir Reformer nennen, lassen unsere Darmbakterien untersuchen. Oder wir lassen uns Eigenblut in die Gesichtshaut injizieren und spritzen uns den Hunger weg. Der Tech-Milliardär Peter Thiel hat das Start-up Ambrosia gegründet. Zu dessen Geschäftsgebiet gehört, das Blut älterer Menschen mit dem Blut jüngerer auszutauschen. Er wolle den Tod bekämpfen, wird Thiel zitiert.
Ja, also diese Jungbrunnen-Idee, es ist also wirklich einfach öffentliche Unternehmung, dass Peter Thiel Parabiosis betreibt, eine Firma mitfinanziert Ambrosia, wo man sich für 8000 Dollar Blutplasma von U25 spritzen lassen kann. Die gehen also ganz normal Blut abgeben, so Blutspenden und dann kriegt das halt nicht jemand, der es braucht, sondern jemand, der es mal testen möchte. Und er hat auch, also Thiel, an Epstein geschrieben, I'm looking into Parabois Bios stuff. Mhm. So, es geht über 2200 veröffentlichte Erwähnungen von Thiel in den Files, regelmäßig getroffen von 2014 bis 2017, sehr vertrauliche Austausche zu Diäten, die man haben kann. Ich weiß nicht, es ist ja mittlerweile auch Maha, also Gesundheitsdoktrin, amerikanische Regierung mehr Fleisch zu essen und so, die Steak ganz oben anzusiedeln. So sah wohl die Diät, die er mit Epstein entwickelt hat, bei Peter Thiel auch aus. Also man hat da so Bio-Hacking über Ernährung gemacht.
Ich frag mich ja bei Peter Thiel immer, ganz offen gesprochen, wo ist das Resultat? Ich sehe es leider nicht bei ihm.
Der sieht ja sehr abgemärkelt und sehr...
Ja genau, aber du würdest ja jetzt nicht sagen, das ist für mich ein Ideal, so würde ich gerne aussehen.
Nee, aber Peter Thiel sieht so aus, als ob man so mit 60 aussehen kann und dann auch mit 120.
Okay, aber dann muss ich jetzt einfach durch so ein normales Leben durchstreiten, aber dann kann ich noch mal so mit 90 richtig glänzen oder was. Also mir fallen jetzt mehr Leute ein, also wenn ich jetzt an welche Prominenten denke, die älter sind. Zum Beispiel Piers Brosnan oder so, der ist einfach sehr gut gealtert, der sieht sehr gut aus. Aber ich habe jetzt nicht, wenn ich Peter Thiel sehe, irgendwelche Neidgefühle und überlege, ob ich mir auch mal einen Plasma spritzen lasse. Ich denke eher, gut, das kriegt man wahrscheinlich auch mit ordentlich Weißweintrinken hin. Das ist auch so.
Brian Johnson sieht auch nicht besonders gesund aus, aber nach medizinischen Einschätzungen ist er wohl der gesündeste Mensch der Welt. Vielleicht ist ja Optik und Gesundheit auch ein bisschen ein Unterschied. Die haben ja auch Schönheitsideale, die so ein bisschen abseits sind.
Das mag sein, aber ich habe nicht den Eindruck, das seien die so wahnsinnig gute Werbefiguren für das, was sie da anbieten.
Also wir sind ja jedenfalls bei Peter Thiel schon aufgehoben, bei jemanden, wo man sich wirklich mal fragen muss, wie weit kann man Billionärwunschdenken so treiben. Eine sehr interessante Sache, die wir uns hier nochmal anhören können, wir haben jetzt diese Intimität besprochen. Das ist also der integrative Faktor nach innen. Also da so das Distinktionsmerkmal, ich fahre auf die Insel, um endlich mal mit einer Prostituierten so richtig ein offenes Wort zu reden. Und nach außen muss da das abgeschirmt werden. Vielleicht ist die Antwort ganz profan. Wir hören es hier mal im Ronzheimer Podcast am 8. Februar.
Wie ist das zu erklären, Lars? Wir sind ja immer noch im Jahr 2008 oder zwischen 2005 und 2008, als der Prozess läuft, dass dann selbst Bundesrichter solche Aussagen machen. Also versuchen irgendwie die Mädchen mehr oder weniger Kinder, teilweise muss man sagen, davon abzubringen. Also gibt es da irgendwelche Belege, dass Epstein direkt Einfluss genommen hat oder Leute um ihn herum in diesen Prozess? Also es gibt, soweit wir wissen, momentan jetzt keinen handfesten Beweis dafür, was aber schon komisch ist, ist, dass die Verteidiger von Epstein damals mit harten Bandagen gegen die vorgehen, dass Rechtsanwälte sozusagen da die sozusagen Glaubwürdigkeit der Zeugen in Frage gestellt haben. Das ist belegt und das ist auch etwas, sagen wir mal so, das ist nicht schön, da hat man gar keine Frage, aber sagen wir mal, dass solche rechtlichen Auseinandersetzungen sozusagen nicht einfach sind. Das liegt auf der Hand, das ist normal. Warum die tatsächlich Polizisten dann auch teilweise dann vorstellig waren und die Polizisten dann plötzlich auf die Anwälte der Opfer tatsächlich die beobachtet haben und so weiter, das kann ich dir ehrlicherweise nicht sagen. Außer, und das wäre nur die Vermutung von mir, dass die einfach geschmiert worden sind. Das ist ganz relativ klar. Gibt es aber keine Belege zu besagen? Nee, da gibt es keine Belege dafür, soweit ich das weiß.
Also in New York 15 Polizisten den 13. Monatsgalt zu zahlen, ist jetzt nicht die Herausforderung für diese Leute.
Wirklich nicht.
Und von daher würde ich sagen, das klingt erstmal sehr plausibel irgendwie. Außerdem Richard David Precht hat natürlich jetzt mit dem Vorschlaghammer drauf auf diese Fragestellung. Und ich glaube, dass im Gespräch mit Lanz ist das Interessante, was wir daran merken, wenn wir über das Verhalten sehr reicher Leute nachdenken. Natürlich nicht alle, das müssen wir mal ausdrücklich dazusagen, aber viele. Dann besteht es einfach darin, dass sie die Erfahrung machen, dass wenn immer Geld auf Anstand trifft, langfristig das Geld gewinnt. Deswegen dieser Satz, was hilft, wenn Geld nicht hilft, mehr Geld. Das ist eine praktische Erfahrung, die sehr wohlhabende Leute oder reiche Leute fast tagtäglich machen. Und wenn man es etwas wissenschaftlicher ausdrückt, dann würde man sagen, wann auch immer eine soziale Norm auf eine Marktnorm trifft, dann wird die soziale Norm von der Marktnorm kannibalisiert.
Das heißt, am Ende bleibt immer nur Kapitalismus übrig. Es ist nur eine Frage davon, welche Mittel man einsetzt, wie viel Macht man benutzt und vor allen Dingen in allererster Linie, wie viel Geld man einsetzt.
Und ich glaube, dass das sehr typisch ist für die normale Alltagserfahrung dieser sogenannten Eliten.
Volle Zustimmung.
Okay, dann bin ich gespannt bei dem nächsten. Lanz kommt jetzt mit der nächsten These. Da sag ich, ne, glaube ich nicht.
Aber hier das hast du doch jetzt schon auch unterschreiben können. Also das war ja das, was du jetzt eben auch schon aufgeführt hast.
Also ja, wir haben es halt damit zu tun, dass Milliardäre in ihrer sozialen Größe dann doch begrenzt sind. Und wir wissen ja von einigen, dass sie da nicht und das auch nicht wollten, dazugehören in die Epstein-Klasse, obwohl sie Billionär-Klasse sind.
Ja gut, nicht alle haben dieselben Vorlieben.
Das kann natürlich sein, dass es einfach die persönliche Präferenz war. Aber also je nachdem. Es ist sozusagen Spekulation, ja.
Also er konnte ja nur mit Leuten zum Beispiel was werden, wo das jetzt entweder so einen ideologischen Rahmen gibt, dass man sagt, ich bin auch an einem Programm am Schuß dann, mit dem man für immer jung sein kann oder so. Oder man hat Leute, die man aufgrund ihrer sexuellen Neigungen oder ihrer Triebabfuhr, die sonst wo nicht gelingt, dass man diese bekommen kann. Nun gibt es ja sicherlich auch sehr reiche Menschen, die zum Beispiel in einer einigermaßen glücklichen Ehe führen und die jetzt nicht die ganze Zeit darüber nachdenken, wo kann ich mir noch mal einen Exzess beschaffen. Aber es ist selbstredend so, dass, was hier von Precht ausgeführt wird, doch so ist, dass wir sehen, dass man also mit Geld ja sehr viel möglich machen kann und mit sehr viel Geld kann man noch mal mehr möglich machen. Das heißt, diese Delegation, dieses Delegieren, das stattfinden kann durch das Geld, ist doch eigentlich das Reizvolle auch für die, weil das ist die Art der Machtausübung, die man dann haben kann.
Also es gibt in der Sozialpsychologie natürlich diese Argumentation zu sagen, der Altruismus ist im Grunde immer ein überwandelverrechneter Egoismus. Jemand gibt Trinkgeld, um beim nächsten Mal von vornherein besseren Service zu bekommen, was auch immer. Aber ich glaube, das geht nicht ganz auf, weil die Welt hat Aspekte, die sich nicht finanzialisieren lassen. Und von daher stimmt dieses mehr Geld und dann einfach das Problem löst man mit noch mehr Geld. Also dieses ganze Thema Longevity und so weiter. Das lässt sich irgendwann auch nicht mehr mit mehr Geld.
Ja, da kommen sie an ihre Grenzen. Aber das ist ja, glaube ich, auch nicht das, was precht in Zweifel ziehen würde. Da würde nur sagen, dass diese Leute, die ohnehin sehen, dass sie mit Geld etwas mobilisieren kann. Ich kann mit Geld die Suite buchen. Ich kann mit Geld sagen, holen sie mich mit dem Auto ab. Nein, fahren sie mich lieber mit dem Hubschrauber. Ach, ich nehme den Privatschat. Also wo man diese ganzen Möglichkeiten hat, versucht man natürlich dann, und da kann man es ja tatsächlich skalieren, versucht man es dann auch in Bereichen zu skalieren, in denen es eigentlich nicht geht. Und zum Beispiel der gesamte Bereich der Liebe und der Sexualität ist einer, der mit Geld nun eigentlich nur begrenzt möglich ist. Jetzt kann ich kaufen, Sex kaufen, aber Liebe kaufen wird zum Beispiel schon eine große Schwierigkeit sein. Das heißt, also da sehen wir so eine absolute Limitierung, die vorhanden ist. Und die können die auch nicht in irgendeiner Weise überspringen. Und das ist ja auch das tragische an diesen Figuren, die man dann häufig sieht. Also wenn sie dann mit sehr eigenartigen Partnerinnen oder so da rumlaufen, dann denkt man auch immer, das ist ja interessant. Also man sieht das ja nicht.
Ich will jetzt nicht einzelne beurteilen, aber man sagt jetzt nicht, Mensch, wo die Liebe hinfällt, sondern man sagt eher, Mensch, da war aber ganz schön viel Geld im Pott, und hier würde ich eben sagen, das, was Precht hier sagt, in dieser Vehemenz gilt für dann doch gescheiterte Leute, nicht ökonomisch gescheitert, aber auf anderen Ebenen doch gescheitert. Wir kommen nachher nochmal auf Elon Musk zurück. Wir behalten das mal im Hinterkopf, denn Elon Musk verdient ja einen eigenen Clip. Diese zweite Sache, ich habe vorhin schon Hoffnung geäußert, du machst ein bisschen widersprüchlich. Mal gucken, wie wir zu diesem Precht-Thema, These stehen. Irgendwann wird es am Ende dann das Ergebnis der Epstein-Pfals sein, dass man sich damit axelzogend abfindet und sagt ja, so ist das offensichtlich. Ja, so sind die Eliten und sind sie offensichtlich in allen Ländern und zu allen Zeiten gewesen und so weiter. Und irgendwann ist dann das Aufregungspotenzial, was natürlich jetzt groß ist, was dann mal ein bisschen größer werden kann, aber irgendwann erstirbt das auch wieder. Und dann ist die Tatsache, dass alles rauskommt, nicht die Grundlage für besonders starke Skandalisierung, sondern wenn jemand tausendmal Skandal geschrien hat, dann interessiert das tausend und erste Mal nicht mehr. Ich weiß nicht genau, in welchem Ausmaß er das meint. Für mich klingt es so, als könnte man das Prinzip Epstein auf Dauer stellen. Dass also alle Welt weiß, da unten ist schon eine Insel, da laufen so Sachen, das machen die Milliardäre, hier hat keiner Zugriff. Und daran glaube ich nicht.
Nee, das halte ich auch nicht für denkbar. Was wir ja sehen können, ist eine Gewöhnung, bei zum Beispiel Donald Trump und seinen Lügen. Also wir haben eine ganz andere Hornhaut da bekommen, was seine Äußerung anbelangt. Er muss jetzt schon sehr viel machen, damit wir zwei das noch mal aufgreifen oder wir uns unten am Parkplatz abholen und sagen, hast du gehört, der Trump hat das und das gesagt. 2016 haben wir da sofort reagiert, wenn wieder irgendwas kam. Und das ist sicherlich schon eine Gewöhnung, die stattfindet. Bei diesen Fällen würde ich sagen, kann ich mir das nicht denken. Beziehungsweise ja, man müsste ja jetzt genau, wenn wir jetzt retrospektiv vorgehen, fragen, wer ist der aktuelle Epstein? Gibt es, wie viele gibt es? Wer ist jetzt gerade was da am tun?
Ich weiß nicht genau, wann waren die Weinsteinsachen und so? Das war ja auch so vor Corona.
Ja, das war ja so 2016, 17.
Und das ist ja so verrückt, dass auf der einen Seite, dass der öffentliche Diskurs ist, den die verfolgen, während sie gerade in Heli sitzen auf die Insel. Ja, ja, das ist wirklich verrückt. So, mein Diskurs, aber wir haben ihn, also ich, ist jetzt nicht ein Novum, wir haben es auch schon mal fast genauso gesagt, wie es hier in dem QAnon Podcast gesagt wird, der sehr gut ist, dass ich ja seit der ersten Amtszeit so ein bisschen um die Begleitung von dem, was da…
Der heißt QAnon Podcast.
Ich glaube, der heißt einfach QAnon Podcast. Der hat auf Patreon so 25.000 Zahlen der Kunden, die sich das einfach in Länge… Also, die gehen so durch die Foren durch und lesen die neuesten Jobs auch mal, aber es ist halt so für die normalen Leute.
Also, die setzen sich mit QAnon-Verschwörungen auseinander oder was machen die?
Ja, es gibt ein paar sehr gute Podcasts, zum Beispiel Knowledge War. Die schauen regelmäßig Alex Jones und sind jetzt in der mehr als tausendsten Episode. Und obwohl er schon ein bisschen abgemeldet ist, bleiben die immer noch hartnäckig an ihm dran. Auch ein schönes Hobby, ja. Dieser QAnon-Podcast hier, ich glaube, der heißt einfach QAnon-Podcast, QAA. Der ist auch sehr gut. Also, ich höre ihn nicht immer, aber gerade wenn es so wieder Themen sind und so, ist das wirklich sehr aufdrußreich. Und die stellen sich auch nochmal diese Frage, die wir uns gestellt haben. Und ich würde eben auch nochmal das Menschliche an sich. Und wir sind immer sehr leicht dabei zu sagen, jemand hat es ökonomisch geschafft, also Gewinner. So, und dass das nicht so stimmt, das sehen wir ja gerade reinweise, also dieser Ludnig und so, was auch über ihn von Adam Tooths erzählen wurde in Davos. Das sind ja alles Milliardäre, das ist ja alles nicht auszeichnend. Also, Leute können durchaus superreich sein und menschlich komplett auch in sich selbst gescheitert sein. Und dieses Fallbeispiel ausgerechnet des reichsten Menschen, Elon Musk, obwohl diese Buchwerte mittlerweile auch absurd sind, also Tesla und der ganze Kram ist ja alles Blödsinn, wird hier in dem QAnon Podcast auch noch mal als Frage aufgeworfen.
Ja, hier ist es, was mich kürzt. Als Kind ist es voll von Auf- und Ablöten, voll von sublime Freude und brennendem Leid. Aber ich denke, eine der meisten vertragbaren Gründe der Freude ist, Wenn du Kinder hast zwischen den Jahren von 5 und 10 und es ist Weihnachtsdag, besonders wenn du ein kleines bisschen Geld hast, sodass du ihnen etwas wirklich Cooles zeigen kannst. Du kannst sie wirklich in diese genügend unerwünschte Freude und Wunder teilen, wie Züge und Lichter und so weiter. Hier hat er fünf Kinder, die 6 und 8 Jahre alt sind und er ist ein Billionär. Er kann ihnen alles zeigen. Er kann einen privaten Jet heilen, um in den Norden zu fliegen. Er kann ihnen eine tolle Erfahrung auf Weihnachtsdag geben, unvergleichbar und diese Freude teilen, Aber am Weihnachtsmorgen denkt er nicht darüber nach. Er denkt darüber nach zu gehen und mit einem Pädophil zu feiern.
Ja genau.
So muss man es sehen.
Es ist unerklärlich traurig. Man kann es sich nicht, also es wären so viele Literatur nötig, um mir das zu verdeutlichen. Wie so ein Gedanke so ablaufen kann. Es ist irgendwie ganz schräg.
Ja, ich mein du hast ja auch die Serie The White Lotus gesehen. Du siehst ja eigentlich, wie leer, wie träge, wie traurig das Leben dieser Leute ist. Und da sind wir noch gar nicht bei den ganz, ganz reißen.
Genau, also in White Lotus inszenieren die ja vor allem immer dieses Abendessen. So, eigentlich die beste Situation der Welt für jedes, also für jeden einzelnen Gast ist eine im Personal. Sie können essen, was sie wollen. Sie sitzen an diesen Tischen und sind einfach wirklich unzufrieden. Ja, ja. Also da ist es richtig gut dargestellt, aber es erklärt halt nichts. Es illustriert einfach nur so. Man fragt sich umso mehr, was ist da eigentlich los? Gut, ich will jetzt mal noch zwei Clips spielen. Nun habe ich also einfach von Babys fressen und irgendwelchen Stresshormonen gesprochen. Das ist ja eine sehr saloppe Herangehensweise.
In der Tat, Stefan.
Es wirkte ja auch nicht irgendwie von mir betrübt, ich bin erschüttert oder was auch immer, sondern es hat schon einen Entertainment Faktor gehabt, der also ja einfach ergibt aus der Bizarrität, die da drin steckt. Nun ist es ja so.
So kommen wir es natürlich auch.
Das sind ja, wie wir wissen, Verschwörungstheorien, die haben ja eine Quelle. 4chan. Und zwar genau das POL, also Politik Support, das es da auf 4chan gibt. Und das gibt es ja seit 23.10.2011. Und danach tauchte sowohl Q, also das ist Q-Jobs, dass es in der Regierung jemanden gibt, der etwas aufdeckt und so weiter. Tauchte da auf und eben auch dieses ganze Adrenochronen Pizza Connection, dass dann jemand wirklich sagt, ich hab's da gelesen, ich geh jetzt in die Pizzeria, stell fest, hat ja gar kein Keller und so. So, das nahm seinen Ausgangspunkt am 23.10.2011, weil der Gründer von 4chan selbst, der sich auf der Plattform MUT nennt und im wahren Leben PUL heißt, dieses Ding gegründet hat. Einen Tag davor, am 22.10.2011 traf er sich mit Epstein, nachdem ihn zwei Tage zuvor jemand aus dem Bill Gates Büro empfohlen hatte, trifft doch mal diesen jungen Typen, der hat da so eine Webseite, da geht's irgendwie zur Sache. Danach hat dann der Nikolaj an den Epstein geschrieben, nachdem ein Washington Post Artikel kam, oder hat ihn auf den Washington Post Artikel hingewiesen, in dem 4chan schon beschrieben wurde als, Vorsicht, Vorsicht, das Potential von Manipulation ist huge. Dieser Pool hat danach mehrere Anfragen bekommen auf weitere Treffen mit Epstein, die er wohl alle zurückgewiesen hat, laut diesen Files. Aber es ist nun einfach mal historischer Fakt, dass ein Tag nachdem die sich trafen, das Ding da eingerichtet wurde. So, was ich auch für eine erstaunliche Sache finde, jedenfalls, von dort kommen diese Theorien, denen ja dann viele Leute, Xavier Naidoo ist ja nicht der Einzige, sondern einweise vielen ja die Leute zu Boden sagen, das ist jetzt das Ding und so. Und haben das über Jahre und auch vehement und so verteidigt. Was eben zu einer allgemeinen Stimmungslage führte, dass das irgendwie jetzt durch Epstins, also diese Veröffentlichung der Epstins angesprochen werden muss, aber man sich vielleicht auch ein bisschen, man ist sich so unsicher, wie man das jetzt macht. So und es gibt einfach Leute im Deutschlandfunk und es ist jetzt wirklich ein bisschen speziell, weil der Deutschlandfunk wollte das selber nicht veröffentlichen. Das ist nach Redaktionsschluss heißt die Sendung und sie haben ein Gespräch mit Perksen und einem weiteren Frau, die zu Gast war zum Thema. Sie haben das Rohmaterial einfach veröffentlicht.
Warum?
So statt die Sendung nochmal zu schneiden. Achso. Ein technischer Fehler.
Achso.
So was jetzt dazu führt, wir hören jetzt einmal, wie der Journalist roh an dieses Thema rangeht und gar nicht in der Lage ist, es eigentlich zu behandeln. Also es finde ich auch eine interessante Ebene, dass hier jetzt einfach so ein emotionales Scheitern am Thema stattfindet. Ist zwar irgendwie erklärlich, aber ist auch ein bisschen speziell.
Xavier Naidoo war gestern auf einer Demo in Berlin zum Kinderschutz und hat dann doch wieder erzählt, dass es einen Gewürz aus Föten gibt.
Entschuldigung, dass es was gibt?
Ein Gewürz aus Föten.
Ja.
Also wir müssen das, glaube ich, kurz dann...
Also es gibt so eine Verschwörungserzählung, die zielt eben darauf ab, dass reiche Zirke sich, und ich mache das jetzt in aller Wahrheit, kenne ich diese, korrigieren sie mich, dass aus reichen Gruppen Kinder gefangen genommen werden und dann, ja, sie müssen das sagen.
Ich kann das gar nicht sagen.
Schiete, was machen wir denn jetzt?
Also, Selva Naidu ist ja seit Jahren dafür bekannt gewesen, dass er...
Also dann sollte man es nicht machen. Entweder man geht hier ein bisschen neugierig mit der Fragestellung ran, so wie wir, macht den einen oder anderen einen Joke, weil es gerade Atom ist, aber kommt danach drauf zurück.
Das ist auch nicht die Alternative, Stefan. Nein, das ist auch nicht die Alternative.
So, ja. Was ich aber wirklich krass finde, diese Sendung, das Gespräch ist zu Ende und im Nachhinein sagt er sich so, ich muss die Frage nochmal neu reinschneiden. Also wir kriegen im Grunde ein Fake-Gespräch am Ende serviert, weil redaktionell eine Frage-Formulierung, weil er ist ja während der Sendung, während des Gesprächs gescheitert. Also aus der Post-Production kriegen wir nachträglich die Frage wieder eingearbeitet.
Aber warum hast du Zugriff zu dem Rohmaterial? Das ist mir immer noch nicht klar.
Das kommt immer im Podcast-Ding auf und deswegen habe ich mir gedacht, das ist ja super interessant als MP3 für diesen Podcast. Ach so, das ist also schon veröffentlicht.
Ach so, weil mich das jetzt mal wundert.
Nee, sonst hätte ich es ja nicht aufgegriffen.
Nein, das ist ja eine, weil das ist ja schon so, dass man in einem Interview sein kann, das vor aufgezeichnet wird, wo die Anmoderation noch mal verändert wird oder eine Frage noch mal verändert wird, weil sich jemand verhaspelt hat. Das kann ja passieren im Radio.
Ja, aber das hier ist ja ein bisschen anders. Also ich finde, wenn man an so einem Thema aus eigener Emotion heraus so scheitert, dann kann man das auch so darstellen, weil das ist ja dann das eigentlich, worum es geht. Weil warum wollen wir sonst die Frauen da schützen und die Mädchen? Also das ist ja der Grund. Nur ein paar Minuten später, also das Gespräch mit den Gästen ist durch, er ist noch mit seinem Redakteur oder Regie da zugange und denkt sich so, ich spreche diese Frage nochmal neu auf. Plötzlich ist auch die Emotionslage so ganz anders.
Jetzt müssen wir einmal kurz klären, Xavier Naidoo, was hat der eigentlich genau gemacht? Warum sprechen wir jetzt über den?
Er wollte also einmal ganz souverän klingen und hat es nochmal so aufgesprochen.
Okay, und jetzt noch die ab.
Alter Vater, ja stimmt, die hat das mit den Gewürzen gemacht. Da muss man eigentlich nach den Gewürzen fragen. Aber vielleicht geht das so auch. Xavier Naidoo hat was mit Gewürzen gemacht. Dann fragst du, kannst du nach dem Gewürz fragen? Dann gehen wir mal nach Xavier Naidoo, was auch immer, okay, super. Und Abmord, das war nach Redaktionsschluss.
Ich muss jetzt noch einmal nachfragen, weil ich es immer noch nicht begriffen habe. Normalerweise werden doch nicht einfach im Rohmaterial irgendwelche Sachen veröffentlicht in einem Podcast-View.
Ja, das passiert manchmal, wenn man Rohmaterial hat und dann eine fertige Datei. Also uns kann es nicht passieren, weil wir diesen Podcast einfach veröffentlichen, wie er ist.
Offensichtlich, ja.
Im Deutschlandfunk möchte man vor dem Publikum die Emotionalität der eigenen Belegschaft einfach verstecken. Und wenn jemand mal wirklich ernsthaft sagt, sorry, das ist gerade so krass, ich kann das gar nicht glauben und ich will es auch nicht aussprechen, dann wird es einfach zehn Minuten später, ja komm, ich spreche das nochmal auf. Und dann wird sogar noch ein Scherz darüber gemacht, also vor allem vor sich selber, das ist ja auch sehr erlösend an, er hat ja irgendwas mit Gewürzen gesagt und so. Also es ist sozusagen eine emotionale Verwerfung, bei der ich denke, nee, dann doch lieber hier im Podcast einfach kurz sagen, was ist, das dann mit dem Publikum klären, Olivia hilft natürlich und dann greift man das wieder auf und kommt zu seinem Thema zurück. Aber hier irgendwie so, ich meine das Gespräch hat ja auch eine andere Dynamik, wenn der Typ, der dich befragt, scheitert.
Man kann ja auch bei der Thematik oder bei vielen anderen Thematiken auch scheitern. Also ich halte das auch für sinnvoll bzw. ja, ich bin jetzt gerade Zwiegespalten deshalb, weil ich doch auch merke, wie jetzt so eine persönliche Emotion reingearbeitet wird in die Nachrichten. Du wirst das sicherlich auch kennen. Heute Journal, wenn es dann irgendwelche schrecklichen Bilder gibt, sagen wir mal, irgendwelche Angriffe auf Krankenhäuser in der Ukraine, und dann wird danach irgendwie der auf den Moderator geschaltet und der sagt dann, ist gar nicht so leicht, jetzt weiterzumachen. Das mache ich nicht, weil das ist ja auch schon einstudiert, dass man das jetzt sagt, du da jetzt erst mal tief durchatmen. Da bin ich gar kein Freund von. Aber wenn es wirklich in dem Moment passiert, dass man da sagt, das ist jetzt eine Monstrosität, über die kann ich jetzt gerade gar nicht so reden, oder das ist so obskur, dass ich eigentlich lachen muss oder was auch immer, dann halte ich das für eigentlich sehr gut, das so zu machen.
Also dass man seinen Gesprächsgästen im Nachhinein, ohne dass die es auch wissen, so eine Frage neu unterjubelt und die reagieren dann eigentlich auf die eigene Emotionalität. Und dann ist aber, weiß nicht, bin ja irgendwie unzufrieden mit dieser Art. Aber New York Times zum Beispiel, ja, das finde ich hervorragend. Sitzen einfach da, klären das, gehen die Fragen durch.
Wir sprechen jetzt über Social Media und das Social Media-Verbot. Ich bin gespannt auf die Debatte, sage ich gleich.
Ja, Gavin hat mich schon sehr überzeugt. Ich bin auch nicht für ein totales Verbot, aber es hieß halt auch.
Wir fangen jetzt langsam an, jetzt lass mich gleich alles vorwegnehmen. Wir gehen das jetzt mal durch. Wir hören einen Clip aus dem Deutschlandfunk....
Nordrhein-Westfalens Heimat- und Digitalministerin Ina Scharrenbach, die 1001 Delegierten aufrief, über die Social Media Vorlage abzustimmen, war schon klar, dass sie angenommen würde. Denn kurz vor dem CDU-Parteitag hatten sich die Vertreter der unterschiedlichen Parteiströmungen auf einen Kompromiss verständigt und der sieht so aus. Künftig sollen erst Kinder ab 14 online Netzwerke nutzen dürfen. Auch für junge Menschen bis zum 16. Lebensjahr sollen gewisse neue Beschränkungen im digitalen Raum gelten. Vorbild ist Australien, wo es entsprechende Regeln seit kurzem gibt.
Ja und?
Social-Media-Verbot für vernünftige Familien gibt es eh schon. Es geht ja nur noch um die, die halt trotzdem noch im Internet abhängen, unter 14.
Aber wir müssen es ja mal ein bisschen größer fassen. Also erst weißt du schon, was interessant das sind. Es gibt ja Möglichkeiten der Erziehungsberechtigten einzuschreiben. Ist ja auch schon mal was.
Ja, viel.
Wir sind uns ja in…
Typischerweise machen die Erziehungsberechtigten Gestalten die Welt, der Kinder, nicht die Politik.
Richtig. Und wir finden das sogar in den meisten Fällen sehr gut, dass das so ist. Jetzt sagt man hier, das Vorbild ist Australien. Australien hat da eine sehr harte Regelung eingeführt, was auch dazu führt, dass junge Leute ja nicht blöde sind und sich überlegen, wie komme ich eigentlich aus dieser Prädoie wieder raus. Auch das muss man sich natürlich im Klaren werden, denn die halten dann zum Beispiel die Kamera zur Altersverifizierung einfach jemand anderem ins Gesicht, der älter ist. Oder sie machen Kremassen vor der Kamera.
Dafür sind aber die unter Niemann zu schändlich, das zu regeln.
Ich will nur sagen, sie versuchen es zu umgehen.
Ja, das ist der Sinn der Jugend.
Genau.
Ja, ja.
Also einfach sozusagen, ja. Und dann haben die das jetzt da so geregelt, ist vielleicht nur die halbe Wahrheit. Wir hören mal weiter.
Die CDU will, dass die Betreiber von Apps wie TikTok, Instagram oder Snapchat effektive und technisch belastbare Altersverifikationssysteme einführen, damit unter 14-Jährige die digitalen Beschränkungen nicht einfach austricksen können.
Altersverifikation bedeutet, dass die Älteren ja dann sich verifizieren müssen, dass sie älter sind. Das heißt, wenn man eine Altersverifikation in den sozialen Medien einführt, bedeutet das für uns, dass wir uns verifizieren müssen, dass Stefan nicht mehr 14 ist, sondern schon älter. Das heißt, wir müssen Daten an die geben.
Wir haben das hier im Podcast schon geklärt, dass die Handys wissen. Hat ein Konto hinzugefügt bei Apple Pay? Ist ein ausreichendes Signal für, ist über 14 oder über 16 geschäftsfähig?
Im Bereich Apple-Produkte, nicht im Bereich Huawei.
Also grundsätzlich gilt das ja für alle Kontoführungen, die grundsätzlich auf Handys geführt werden, egal ob Android, Apple oder wo auch immer.
Aber du weißt ja, wie die Age-Verification stattfindet. Wir werden ja gleich mal ein Beispiel hören, wie das funktioniert.
Also ich habe ja schon gesagt, ich bin dafür, dass wir Age-Verification natürlich auf das Mindestmaß und ich habe die Corona-App schon angesprochen und Apple Pay. Und es reicht völlig, das Signal auszuwerten, hat ein Geschäftskonto, also hat ein Konto, führt selbst ein Konto.
Ich hatte ja auch zum Beispiel ein Konto unter 18.
Ja, aber typischerweise hast du keins unter 14.
Nein, ein Girokonto vielleicht nicht. Aber das bedeutet, dass ich jedes Mal verifizieren muss, egal welche Seite ich aufrufe, die irgendwie als Social Media begriffen wird oder als eine Seite für Erwachseneninhalte, die es ja vielerlei Art gibt, es geht ja nicht auch nur um pornografische Inhalte, dass ich dann jedes Mal verifizieren soll, wer ich bin, dass ich ein Konto habe.
Ja, du musst eben nicht sagen, wer du bist. Du musst nur ein Topen vorfügen.
Das ist ja die Frage, wer das einführt.
Das haben wir schon ganz oft besprochen hier im Podcast, sogar schon vor 800 Leuten im Sommersalon. Und ich weiß, du hast ganz viel Taylor-Lorenz gehört.
Nein, dass außer dir wird das ja niemand so anders anführen. Wenn in den USA wird es so eingesetzt und auch in UK, dass die Unternehmen, die ohnehin schon Daten sammeln wie verrückt, jetzt diese Altersverifikation noch machen, da ist nicht irgendein unabhängiges Tool, was nur über Kontodaten oder sonst was geht. Zumal ich mir auch vorstelle, das Internet ist so schon grausam genug, dass ich bei jeder Seite, die ich öffne, dreimal klicken muss, dass ich diese komischen Cookies akzeptiere. Und jetzt soll ich dann bei jeder Seite, die ich öffne, die möglicherweise Inhalte für unter 14-Jährige ist, dann nochmal sagen, aber guck, guck, ich habe ein Konto.
Ja, dass das ein Ausbeut der Kapitalismus ist, bei dem alle jetzt die Chance sehen, ah, jetzt habe ich endlich die Erlaubnisstruktur bekommen, von der Politik sogar alle Gesichter zu speichern. Die Tech-Konzerne wollen das Verifikationsding haben. Ja, das stimmt, aber das wäre ich doch trotzdem ab.
Was wir als Diskurs haben, ist Big Tech zerschlagen oder Big Tech an die Kandare nehmen. Das ist der Diskurs in den USA und das ist der Diskurs in der gesamten EU. Die Tech-Konzerne wollen diese Altersverifikationen haben.
Und das ist doch das eigentliche Problem.
Ja, deswegen darf man jetzt nicht für Altersverifikationen sein.
Aber es gibt doch Lösungen.
Ja, aber das sind ja Lösungen, die möglicherweise beim CCC auf eine Zustimmung treffen. Du glaubst doch nicht, dass die EU, die jeden Lobbyismus mitmacht, jetzt ein System auf den Weg bringt, das nicht Daten sammelt.
Wolfgang, wir hatten mal eine Corona-App, die hatte eine Diskussion als Vorläufer. Es gab zwei konkurrierende Modelle. Das eine ist absolute Anonymisierung. Und zwar so, dass wirklich alle sagen, das geht so. Es gab gar keine Kritik daran. Und wir hatten ein Industriestandard. Apple und Google haben sich das erste Mal miteinander verständigt, dass sie eine gemeinsame Technologie für diese Plattform, für ihre Plattform entwerfen. So, die Alternative war, die deutsche Bundesregierung will eine zentrale Datenbank, wo jeder fast handschriftlich unterschrieben aufschreibt, wo er war. So, und bei diesen zwei Alternativen hat sich die deutsche Gesellschaft aufgrund öffentliches Interesses, Einsicht in der Politik, Einsicht in den Unternehmen dafür entschieden, das Hardcore-anonyme Ding zu machen. Und das war eine viel größere Herausforderung technisch als Altersverifikation. Von daher sage ich ausdrücklich, und ich werde auch nicht mehr widersprechen, weil wir hören uns das jetzt einfach an. Aber, dass hier jetzt gerade ein politischer Wind weht, in dem Unternehmen die Politik an der Nase herumführen oder die Politik das selbst will, weil sie damit eine Überwachungstechnologie serviert bekommt, das ist einfach Fakt. Und das ist auch ein Problem.
Und darum geht es mehr.
Das heißt aber noch lange nicht, das ist aber ganz wichtig. Das heißt noch lange nicht, dass jeder, der wie ich eine Alternative formuliert, die auch schon mal auf der Straße war, einfach jetzt disqualifiziert ist in diesem Gespräch und bitte nichts mehr beizutragen hat.
Nein, das...
Eine bessere Welt ist möglich. Wir hatten sie auch schon. Technisch spricht gar nichts dagegen, dass die Perversion so ist, wie sie ist. In dem, was wir jetzt sehen, ist einfach für sich. Und da sind wir jetzt ab jetzt, also ab jetzt bei dem, was wir jetzt, nachdem ich das jetzt mal markiert habe, sind wir völlig einer Meinung. Ich finde sogar, also sehr wahrscheinlich habe ich sehr viel mehr Argumente dagegen, als du jetzt dagegen so. Weil du dich... Ich mache diese Diskussion seit 15 Jahren. Also das, was wir jetzt hören, ist alles ganz, ganz schlimm. Und ich sage dir, du hast da auch mit allem Recht.
Nur siehst du, wenn ich...
Aber wir sind dem halt zum Opfer gefallen.
Richtig. Dann möchte ich dir aber erst noch...
Nicht in der Technik an sich so drin.
Genau. Deshalb möchte ich dich ja erst noch fragen, siehst du eine Möglichkeit, dass eine solche Verifikation, wie du sie vorschlägst und wo du sagst, sie ist auch eigentlich schon erprobt, siehst du irgendwo eine politische Möglichkeit, dass diese sich entwickelt oder siehst du politische Akteure, die auf so etwas setzen? Denn wenn ich jetzt mir ansehe, was die Parteien dazu äußern, dann finde ich nichts dergleichen. Ich finde, manche, die sagen ein bisschen mehr laisse fair und die anderen sagen, nee, wir müssen da mal richtig ran. Und wenn man sich jetzt ansieht, was jetzt zum Beispiel von Dinken kommt, dann sind die vielleicht gegen ein Social-Media-Verbot. Aber die sind auch bei so einem diffusen Big-Tech zerschlagen. Aber da sehe ich auch nicht, dass sich damit auseinandergesetzt wird. Wie könnte man zum Beispiel eine gewisse Verifikation herstellen?
Na ja, ich meine, du hast ja jetzt schon ein bisschen diskutierlich auf irgendwelche Chaos-Computer-Club-Ecken und so. Ich sehe im Chaos-Computer-Club sehr viele Leute, die eigentlich die zentralen Infrastrukturen betreiben. Nur, das sind Techies in Unternehmen, die sich gegen ihr Management auch nicht durchsetzen. Von daher ist das halt eine sehr schwierige Lage.
Aber wir kommen ja jetzt zu diesem Punkt, wo wir sagen, wir sind uns sehr einig in ganz vielen Dingen und sehen dann eigentlich auch mit Schrecken, was jetzt hier so gesagt wird.
Tatsächlich ist eine deutliche Mehrheit der Deutschen nach Meinungsumfragen für Social-Media-Verbote für Kinder.
Für Kinder. Da geht es aber dann immer schon um die Frage, ja, aber was ist dann damit gemeint? Sind damit 14-Jährige noch gemeint? Sind damit auch noch 16-Jährige gemeint? Wir hören uns jetzt mal an, das war eben so CDU-Parteitag, was sie da hatten. Tim Klüssendorf, die SPD, ist ja vorangegangen mit einem Vorschlag, wir hören ihn hier bei einer Pressekonferenz und er möchte eine differenzierte Sicht. Uns ist wichtig, war da eine sehr differenzierte Sicht auf die Dinge zu haben, eben nicht nur mit einem einfachen Verbot zu kommen und zu sagen, beispielsweise unter 16 darf irgendwie niemand irgendwas und danach ist alles erlaubt, sondern wirklich abgestuft von den jeweiligen Lebenssituationen mit einem Verbot, beziehungsweise einem Mindestalter von 14 und dann aber auch jugendgerechten Angeboten, ohne die Nutzung von Algorithmen danach zu hantieren. Nutzung ohne Algorithmen. Also das heißt, die dann zwischen 14 und 16 sind, sollen die sozialen Medien oder von 16 bis 18 nutzen ohne Algorithmen. Also ohne süchtig machende Algorithmen sind wahrscheinlich gemeint.
Das ist wie ein bisschen, bitte keine Gene.
Ja, genau das. Wie soll das umsetzbar sein und was funktioniert nicht algoritmisch?
Wir wissen, was er meint. Er meint so chronologisch bitte einfach, ohne dass man jetzt die härtesten Posts oben anzeigt.
Okay, aber wir wissen auch, wie soll dieses Gesetz aussehen, das genau das dann verhindert, wo ich dann auch immer mich frage, algoritmisch getrieben ist ja ganz viel. Also ich meine, wenn ich mir jetzt irgendeine Zeitungsseite aufrufe, dann sehe ich meistens so oder ich will mal anders einsteigen. Ich habe vor vielen Jahren ein Buch gelesen, in dem es darum ging, dass irgendwann in den Zeitungsredaktionen nicht mehr die Chefredaktion und die Redakteure entschieden, was als erstes angezeigt wird, was oben angezeigt wird, sondern es wurde das nach oben angezeigt, das was schon viele Klicks hatte, was nach Chartbeat funktionierte. Das Buch stammt von Stefan Schulz, wo man das lesen konnte. Das heißt also, Algorithmus, der so funktioniert, ist ja keine neue Angelegenheit. Klüssendorf beschreibt jetzt was, wo ich auch dachte, hm. Weil das ist ja etwas, was, glaube ich, wir alle merken und von uns selbst auch kennen, wenn wir unterwegs sind auf unseren Geräten, diese suchtverstärkenden Algorithmen, die eben dazu führen, dass man nicht zehn Minuten dann doch wieder anderthalb Stunden am Gerät ist. Die sind natürlich nicht außen im Interesse der Unterhaltung oder weil man besonders altruistisch ist und uns das Leben schön machen will, sondern es ist eben ein knallharter ökonomischer Beweggrund, Menschen auf den Plattformen zu halten, um dort Einnahmen zu generieren, um Werbeeinnahmen zu generieren. So funktioniert das Privatfernsehen. Das Privatfernsehen will, dass wir dabei bleiben, dann gibt es eine Werbeunterbrechung und es geht wieder weiter. Die Bundesrepublik vor den sozialen Medien vegetierte am Abend vier Stunden vor dem Fernseher und schaute sich in der Regel Mist an. Das ist so. Und das tut sie, wenn sie 60 plus ist, auch noch heute. Möglicherweise hat sie aber noch ein Handy dazu und schreibt via WhatsApp noch Tante Klara irgendwelche Dinge. Klüssendorf weiter. Und aus diesem ökonomischen Interesse heraus erwächst dann etwas, was uns natürlich das Leben auch als Demokratie schwierig macht, weil eben immer stärker mit dieser wahre Aufmerksamkeit hantiert wird und der demokratische Konsens da auch ein bisschen hinterfragt wird, weil eben die Spielregeln nicht aus der Mitte der Gesellschaft heraus gemacht werden, sondern von den Unternehmen, die diese Plattform führen. Und deswegen reagieren wir mit dieser Position. Seit wann werden die Spielregeln aus der Mitte der Gesellschaft gemacht?
Seit nie.
Die Öffentlichkeit funktioniert darüber, dass wir einen öffentlich-rechtlichen haben, in dem Leute arbeiten, dass noch somit das Demokratischste was mehr einfällt. Dann gibt es private Medienhäuser mit mächtigen Verlegern dahinten. Also macht der Springer-Verlag Spielregeln aus der Mitte der Gesellschaft heraus? Nee, der Springer-Verlag sagt, so, auf ihn, der hat bei der Berlinale dies oder das gemacht. Das ist doch Unsinn, das zu beschreiben, das zu bezeichnen. Plüssendorf, immerhin Klarnamen, wohl nicht? Ich habe mich sehr gefreut, dass die Union sich in weiten Teilen in ihrer Beschlussfassung dieser Position angeschlossen hat, auch mit der gleichen Altersperspektive, auch mit der Berücksichtigung von Angeboten für Jugendliche dann auch gerade und dann aber auch mit der Überweisung des Themas Klarnamtspflicht.
Da will ich auch noch mal ganz oder sehr deutlich dazu sagen, dass wir eine Klarnamtspflicht ablehnen.
Das ist dann etwas, was dem Schutzgedanken, den wir ja gemeinsam auch verfolgen bei diesem Ganzen eben dann widerspricht. Wir werden nachher noch hören, dass das andere anders sehen und zwar aus dem Journalismus. Also ich bin wirklich entsetzt, dass man in der Presse fast nichts Sinnvolles in Deutschland dazu lesen kann. Also ich finde es wirklich dramatisch. Wir werden ein paar Auszüge aus dem Presseclub noch hören, wie verrückt die Lage ist. Ich habe noch einen Ausschnitt aus der FAZ. Wir haben einen Tagesschaubericht, der so eingeleitet wird.
Wenn dir das hier gefällt, dann magst du auch das hier. Die Macht des Algorithmus, der zum Beispiel auf TikTok eine eigene Formel für Männlichkeit hat. Wer nach Tipps fürs Krafttraining sucht, kriegt schnell radikale politische Inhalte vorgeschlagen, zeigt eine neue Studie.
Das ist eine Studie, die Maria Vordwängler mit in Auftrag gegeben hat oder ihre Stiftung, ihre Institution. Ist das jetzt etwas, bei dem man sagt, ah ja, okay, dann müssen wir da regulierend eingreifen? Denn ich habe mich jetzt gefragt, man hätte ja die Tagesschau auch anders eröffnen können. Wer sich auf TikTok zu Body Positivity informiert, kommt sehr schnell zu grünen Inhalten und bekommt ein zunehmendes Ökobewusstsein propagiert.
Wenn es denn stimmt.
Würde ich jetzt mal tippen. Also mit Body Positivity landet man wahrscheinlich eher nicht bei der AfD, sondern landet bei einigen progressiven Aktivisten und die haben auch noch andere Themen parat. So funktioniert jetzt eine algorithmische Steuerung, ja. Aber ich kann doch da auch sehen, ja, das sind ja auch Vorleben in einer Gesellschaft. Jetzt will ich nicht sagen, jeder, der Krafttraining macht, wird die AfD wählen. Aber wir sehen natürlich in gewissen Podcast-Bubbles und in gewissen Trainings-Bubbles und so weiter, dass da solche starken Überschneidungen sind. Jedenfalls ist es jetzt ja auch so, dass wenn man sagt, macht Krafttraining, studiert BWL, und macht ein Auslandssemester in den USA, dann ist das sehr wahrscheinlich jemand, der weniger dafür zu haben ist, wenn die Linkspartei sagt, wir müssen aus der NATO austreten. Weiß ich ja dann auch. Ja. Also ich verstehe, also das ist ja einfach Verbindungen, die hergestellt werden, aus denen man natürlich, in die man sehr schnell reinkommt. Wir haben das ja hier auch im Podcast hundertfach behandelt. Ich bin ja auch in einer unglücklichen Situation, wenn man so möchte. Ich habe ja ein Buch über Influencer mit Ole zusammengeschrieben und habe ja genau diese ganzen Influencer-Trends kritisiert und all das. Aber es sollte ja nicht ein Buch sein, mit dem wir dann sagen, und deshalb verbieten wir die sozialen Medien. Sondern es geht ja auch, wenn ich über Filme spreche und ich weiß, wie sehr ich mich da eschophieren kann über einiges, dann bin ich ja nicht dafür, dass man jetzt Superheldenfilme verbietet. Ich hoffe ja, mit so einer Kritik ein aufgeklärtes Bewusstsein zu schaffen, dass Leute sich von den Superheldenfilmen vielleicht abwenden und sagen, ich gucke mir mal lieber was Vernünftiges an. Genauso würde ich auch sagen, es gibt eine Alternative zu diesen Influencern oder zu vielen anderen Dingen auch.
Also wir werden ja eh in die Irre geführt hier, denn diese ganze Diskussion, die dieser Journalismus ja auch, weil es die Journalisten wirklich nicht begreifen, so nicht verstehen ist, dass hier zwei Fliegen mit einer Klappe geschlagen werden sollen. Und das sind nämlich zwei Probleme, die vor allem diese Can-Valley-Unternehmen haben. Das ist eben wirklich diese große drohende, also dass irgendwer wirklich mal eingreift und sagt, sorry Elon Musk, du kannst ja keine Nacktbilder posten die ganze Zeit, aber er postet die ja selber. Das ist ja grock, die posten ja nicht mehr die Nutzer. So und das zweite ist, featuremäßig hat man es ausgereizt, man braucht jetzt einen neuen Feature-Katalog. Also wünscht man sich eigentlich eine Diskussion wie hier. Das heißt zum einen, ne wir brauchen gar nicht inhaltlich eingreifen. Das Internet für Erwachsene ist voll okay, nur für die Kinder ist so ein bisschen. Schließen wir halt 5% der Nutzer aus, so. Dann wird das als große Feierstunde verkauft. Das zweite ist, wow, endlich haben wir selber, also nicht nur das Apple-Telefon sagt uns, ja, das ist der Nutzer, du kannst ihm jetzt die App anzeigen, sondern wir selber kriegen Zugriff auf das Gesicht, dass er das Telefon sieht. Weil wir müssen es ja verarbeiten. So, also in der Ansicht lässt sich die Politik hier einfach vorführen. Alle Journalisten machen mit. Und am Ende kriegen die Silicon Valley-Unternehmen die nächsten 10 Jahre ohne, dass da jemand eingreift, weil die Kinder sind jetzt raus. Noch eine große Schlacht, es ist erst mal Frieden angesagt. Und man hat plötzlich Zugriff auf unsere dann halt biologischen, biometrischen wie auch immer Daten und so.
Ja, ja. Also das ist so verrückt, dass man glaubt, man könnte damit jetzt Big Tech zerschlagen, zu dem ich auch der Politik nicht abnehme, dass es denen jetzt um Jugendschutz geht. Ich mein, wenn man nicht möchte...
Das ist schon, aber halt auf so einem ganz, sehr gerne, keine Ahnung leveln.
Wenn man nicht möchte, dass Leute so viel in den sozialen Medien Zeit verbringen. Wir hören jetzt mal gleich Merz. Dann können wir ja mal überlegen, was wäre denn stattdessen denkbar? Merz jetzt erst mal über das Social-Media-Verhalten der Enkel.
Ich habe den Eindruck, dass meine Kinder bei ihren Kindern mit der Nutzung von Handys und Social Media heute schon sehr restriktiv umgehen. Und das halte ich auch für richtig.
Halte ich auch an sich für nicht falsch, kommt doch an. Aber dafür braucht man ja gerade keinen Verbot. Merz macht sich aber Sorgen.
Und ich verallgemeine es jetzt mal, die Nutzung von Social Media, von Handys, von Tablets, hat sich in den letzten Jahren nochmal quantitativ und qualitativ erheblich verändert. So und wenn Kinder heute im Alter von 14 Jahren bis zu fünf Stunden und mehr Bildschirmzeit haben am Tag, wenn die gesamte Sozialisation nur noch über dieses Medium stattfindet, dann brauchen wir uns über Persönlichkeitsdefizite und Probleme im Sozialverhalten von jungen Menschen nicht zu wundern.
Das ist jetzt die Erzählung. Also Social Media sorgt dafür, dass draußen das Stadtbild nicht mehr in Ordnung ist oder was auch immer. Ich denke mir dann auch, wenn ihr ja wollt, dass Kinder eine bessere Zukunft haben als einfach nur am Smartphone zu hängen. Warum wurde dann noch mal der Kulturpass abgeschafft? Warum gibt es eigentlich kein 9-Euro-Ticket? Warum müssen die Jugendzentren sparen?
Wo sind die Lehrer?
Warum ist diese Kindergrundsicherung nicht gekommen? Also diese ganzen Themen, es ist mal wieder, wie du sagen würdest, Talibanpolitik. Man verbietet jetzt irgendwas und sagt, dann wird es schon besser werden. Deswegen kaufe ich der Politik diesen Jugendschutz überhaupt nicht ab. Merz, redet jetzt weiter.
Das heißt, der Staat sollte eine Altersgrenze festnehmen?
Wir reden ja über verschiedene Möglichkeiten, wie man es etwas restriktiver handhaben kann. Ob Altersgrenze, ob Verbot oder ob es Verifikation ist, mit entsprechenden Apps, mit Genehmigung der Eltern. Da kann man jetzt über viele einzelne Abstufungen sprechen, aber ich denke, wir sollten die im Vordergrund stehen. Wie schütze ich die Kinder in einem Alter, in dem sie auch Zeit haben müssen zu spielen? Zu lernen, sich mit in der Schule zu konzentrieren?
Was ich auch nicht begreife bei dieser Debatte, wir haben jetzt die sozialen Medien ja schon 20 Jahre, etwa 15 Jahre Instagram. Das heißt, es ist sehr weit verbreitet. Okay, wir können aber ja auch feststellen, es gibt so peak Social Media immer mehr zu beobachten, dass also die Anzahl der Stunden, die dort verbracht sind, der Minuten, die dort verbracht sind, nicht mehr steigend ist. Was wir aber erleben, ist, dass ja man extremely online ist, im Sinne von man verbringt viele, viele Stunden bei Twitch, mit Gaming, in Reddit-Foren. Jetzt kann man sagen, das ist dann auch alles Social Media. Aber dann gibt es ja noch den Podcast-Trend, der ja auch bei ganz jungen Leuten erheblich dazu beigetragen hat, zum Beispiel, dass sie Trump wählen. Wir haben ja all diese Diskussionen schon gehabt, dass man jetzt so sehr sich auf Social Media konzentriert, wo wir doch sehen, naja, das mag ja sein, dass die da fünf Stunden am Handy sind, aber die sind ja nicht nur bei TikTok und Scoll'n'Bilder durch, sondern die machen ja auch all diese anderen Dinge, weil Candy Crush wird ja jetzt vermutlich nicht verboten werden. Da müsste man ja dann auch drüber nachdenken. Das ist doch eine fadenscheinige Diskussion.
Ja, ist auch. Also wir sehen nachher noch Hollywood-Clips, die gar nicht mehr aus Hollywood sind. Social Media ist eh, also er hat ja einen Ablaufdatum jetzt. In der Form, wie wir es kennen.
Rosenfeld hakt noch mal nach.
Ich bin durchaus der Meinung, dass wir in den Schulen sehr frühzeitig auch Fähigkeiten, Kompetenzen im Umgang mit elektronischen Medien lernen lassen müssen. Aber das Argument, man muss Kinder heranführen, damit sie es können, trägt ehrlich gesagt nicht. Dann müssten sie auch Alkohol schon in der Grundschule ausgeben, damit sie sich dran gewöhnen. Also das ist kein Argument, was mir überzeugt.
Du hast den Punkt gebracht, Schutz durch staatliche Regulierung.
Ich denke, das geht in diese Richtung.
Aber wenn den Schulen die Lehrer weggenommen, statt gegeben werden, geht das halt nicht.
Vor allem dieser Alkoholvergleich, den habe ich jetzt 100.000 Mal gehört in den letzten zwei Wochen, der ist doch unsinnig. Jetzt kann man sagen, Alkohol kann auch zu einer Geselligkeit beitragen oder der Zigarettenvergleich kommt dann auch immer so gern. Dann kann man auch sagen, diese 5 Minuten Auszeit mit der Zigarette. Also da ziehen Leute was Positives daraus möglicherweise, das ist so. Aber wir würden ja jetzt nicht generell sagen, dass man eine Trinkkompetenz haben muss, um an der Gesellschaft teilzunehmen oder eine Rauchkompetenz. Muss man nicht haben. Hier wird so getan, als sei das einfach nur so was süchtig machendes wie der Alkohol. Und deswegen müssen wir das unterbinden. Ich war jetzt gerade an der Leuphana Universität, um dort zu sprechen über Westen und westliche Politik. Einführungssemestertage waren da. Dann begegne ich ja danach Leuten, die sind natürlich jetzt ausgesiebt. Sie sind da an der Uni. Klar, jetzt kann man das sagen, das ist ja privilegiert etc. Aber ich habe das sehr häufig nachvortragen. Da sind also jetzt Leute, die kommen zu mir, die sind 18 Jahre alt. So und die sagen dann, ich höre seit drei Jahren Wohlstand für alle oder Neuen Zwanziger. Das ist doch eine unglaubliche Errungenschaft, dass jetzt eine solche Informationsmöglichkeit da ist. Also ich habe nicht den Eindruck, wenn ich mich mit sehr jungen Leuten unterhalte, dass die alle nur in Filterblasen gefangen sind. Das wird es geben. Aber ich sehe auch, dass es eigentlich ein viel größeres, kritisches Verständnis für Dinge gibt. Viel stärker als bei dem Friedrich Merz Publikum, das er allabendlich mit seinen Sprüchen adressiert. Ich sehe tatsächlich bei all diesen negativen Sachen in Social Media nach wie vor diese unglaublich vielen positiven Seiten. Denn diese Politisierung, die da stattgefunden hat, die ist ja eher die, die jetzt sehr viel in Angst macht. Ach so, die fangen jetzt an, noch selber zu recherchieren, was nachzudenken und stoßen möglicherweise auf anderes als das, was sie in der Schule gelernt haben. Und das, finde ich, ist etwas, was hier jetzt wieder rückabgewickelt werden soll. Also ich sehe diese negativen Auswirkungen auch, aber ich sehe sie nicht nur. Und deswegen sind diese Vergleiche mit Tabak und Alkohol eigentlich unsinnig, weil man da nicht sagt, ja, das hat aber schon ordentlich geholfen, dass der schon früh angefangen hat, zehn Zigaretten am Tag zu rauchen, da würde man das nicht sagen. Man kann aber schon sagen, dass zum Beispiel, wer in den sozialen Medien sich bewusster umgibt und nicht gleich sagt, ich benutze das nur, um nackte zu sehen und meinen Körper zu optimieren, dass man dann doch eine ganz erhebliche Vielfalt angezeigt bekommt von interessanten Inhalten, die so zum Beispiel nicht zugänglich sind, die einem so nicht angeboten werden, wenn man beispielsweise Fernsehen guckt.
Geld, wie du es beschreibst, für ungefähr drei Prozent alle.
Weiß ich nicht.
Vier.
Aber nicht 30.
Ob das so ist. Aber ich bin auf jeden Fall, und wenn es nur die vier Prozent sind, nicht dafür, dass die jetzt ausgesperrt werden, nur weil irgendwelche alten Politiker und Medienmacher um ihre Hegemonie fürchten. Wir hören jetzt die grüne Position bei Deutschlandfunk, Frau Katharina Dröge, zu Gast.
Frau Dröge, ihr Vizier Andreas Autreitsch ist generell auch für eines.
Zumal ich will das noch gerade anfügen, wo du sagst vier Prozent. Naja, aber das gilt ja bei den meisten Dingen. Also wenn du jetzt in Koblenz auf die Straße gehst und da irgendeine vernünftige Meinung zur Schuldenbremse haben willst, dann bist du auch verloren. Das heißt, das...
Ja, aber du hast ja gerade Medienverhalten angesprochen und was man konsumiert.
Die sitzen, die gucken jetzt gleich um 15 Uhr rote Rosen und dann warten die auf die Sendung Präsent oder Leute Heute. Dann gucken die das perfekte Dinner und dann schauen die, ob in den dritten wieder eine Sendung kommt, in denen noch mal alte Schlager-Stars von den 70er Jahren erzählen. Das machen die. Klar, die werden damit politisch nicht auffällig. Das ist auf jeden Fall so.
Ich will eine Kontrastzahl nennen. Also ich habe jetzt gesagt 4%. Zeitverschwendung durch Fortnite, da hatten wir Monate, in denen waren das 40%. Also einfach alle Jungs.
Nur darüber reden wir nicht. Wir reden jetzt nicht über ein Fortnite-Verbot hier. Denn das ist ja interessant, dass der Gaming-Bereich hier völlig ausgeklammert wird, wo ich dann sagen würde, wenn ich diese Schritte hier so gehe, die mitgehen will, dann müsste ich ja darüber auch nachdenken.
Du hast es ja oben schon angedeutet, die eigentliche Antwort auf dieses Desaster hier ist ja, wir haben es mit so feindlich und raffinierten Problemen zu tun. Dass wir die eigentliche in der Familie lösen, auch wollen, nur die Familie wird halt nicht ermächtigt dazu, weil wie bei mir zum Beispiel, es ist jetzt 14.04, 14.30 geht mein kleiner nach Hause und dann sitzt er alleine zu Hause. Und bin ich, bis ich zu Hause bin, sind halt ein paar Stunden vergangen. Und diese Zeit muss halt, klar kann ich jetzt zehn Nachrichten schreiben, guck nicht so viel oder was auch immer, aber wir wissen ja, wie das so abläuft. Und diese Räume könnte man anders bespielen, ohne dass ich jetzt sage, ich mache heute keinen Podcast oder so. Oder andere Leute sagen, ich vertröste heute meinen Chef oder wie auch immer.
Und gehen dann alle in die Lifestyle-Teilzeit, weißt du? Das ist ja das Interessante, dass da Leute in eine Teilzeit gehen, weil sie sich kümmern müssen. Dann werden sie nochmal dafür beschimpft. Und dann sagt man aber zugleich, die sollen nicht die ganze Zeit mit dem Tablet rumreiten.
Cool wäre zum Beispiel, wenn ich ihm vorher sage, morgen mal länger in der Schule bleiben, weil, und dann, oh nee, darf ich nicht früher nach Hause? Wieso ist der, also Nachmittagsschule, warum ist das eigentlich so ein Ort, in der alle flüchten wollen?
Ja, weil es so uninteressant ist.
Das ist doch bescheuert. Genau, das kann man ja anders machen.
Ja, dann müsste man es interessant gestalten.
Das wäre ein Social-Video-Verbot, ja. Weil in der Schule ist ja völlig klar, die sitzen nicht in der Betreuung oder haben Handys vor sich, sondern da wäre halt Programm. Aber wenn kein Programm ist, ist es halt langweilig.
Katharina Dröge jetzt im Deutschen Funk.
Frau Dröge, Ihr Vizier Andreas Autredsch ist generell auch für eine Social-Media-Regulierung für Heranwachsende. Er will aber die Jugendlichen in die Debatte mit einbeziehen, hat er auf NTV gesagt. Wie stehen Sie dazu? Gibt es da eine Parteilinie?
Ich liebe das, wenn gesagt wird, wir müssen die mit einbeziehen. Das ist wirklich der Würgegriff schlechthin.
Ja, also wir Grünen sagen, grundsätzlich Verbote alleine werden nichts lösen, aber wir müssen die jungen Menschen im Internet gerade auf den sozialen Plattformen besser schützen. Da können für uns auch abgestufte Altersvorgaben ein Weg sein, aber der zweite große Weg ist es, dass wir die digitalen Plattformen grundsätzlich stärker in die Pflicht nehmen müssen, weil die bieten süchtig machende Algorithmen an und erzeugen damit genau diese Abhängigkeit von jungen Menschen, vor denen wir sie schützen wollen.
Süchtig machende Algorithmen, da haben wir das wieder. Also das ist immer alles Sucht. Also das ist ja auch so ein inflationärer Begriff. Andere Leute sind ja nach allem süchtig.
Also nach den Shortvideos sind die Leute wirklich süchtig. Ich würde jetzt auch keinen anderen Begriff dafür verfassen.
Das ist in der Bahn, aber genauso bei den Erwachsenen.
Ja, das ändert nichts daran, dass das Sucht ist. Nur weil man es überall sieht, sind halt alle süchtig. Das ist die Diagnose, alle sind süchtig. Die Leute hängen ihren Handys wie in so einer Black-Mirror-Folge vor zehn Jahren noch als Uhu und so. Wir sind ja wirklich kurz vor Wall-E.
Ja, ja, aber jetzt ist ja, also ich sehe das ja auch so. Ich bin ja eigentlich ein viel größerer Kulturpessimist, als du es bist. Nur die Sache ist doch, brauche ich dafür ein allgemeines Verbot oder muss ich sehen, dass man das individuell löst?
Also...
Weißt du, ich bin auch bei den sozialen Medien, aber ich nutze die komischerweise nicht so. Ich bin wahrscheinlich 20 Minuten bei Instagram am Tag.
Ja, du bist halt nicht lost, weißt du?
Ja.
Aber sehr viele Leute sind einfach lost.
Ja, aber dann haben wir doch damit schon die Antwort gefunden. Dann muss dieser Zustand verändert werden, aber mir muss ja dafür nicht das Instagram jetzt weggenommen werden oder ich muss mich jetzt nicht nochmal extra verifizieren mit irgendwas.
Ich finde es auch witzig, wenn man Leuten, die lost sind, das letzte, an das sie noch connected sind, auch noch nimmt.
Ja, und dann wird es ihnen gut gehen. Dann werden sie Freude strahlend durch die Stadt gehen und sagen, wie toll wieder menschliche Begegnungen sind.
Weil Leute fragen, wenn sie zwei Stunden ihr Handy suchen und nicht wissen, wo das ist, wie sie drauf sind.
Ja, es ist ja nicht so, dass sich dann sofort soziales Leben und alles einstellt. Wo soll es auch dann stattfinden?
Die Kinder greifen dann sofort zum Buch.
Ja, wenn das ja so wäre, das wäre eine tolle Idee. Dann wäre ich ja dafür auch noch zu erinnern.
Es ist leider genauso düster, wie du es sagst und sagen möchtest.
Zumal, wenn dann gesagt wird, kein Verbot, sondern wir brauchen dann noch mal so einen extra Inhalt für die jungen Leute. Das bedeutet natürlich, dass auch zum Beispiel für 16-Jährige gefragt wird. Also in den USA haben wir die Heritage Foundation, die nun wirklich eine rechte Kaderschmiede ist, die wollen einfach keine LGBT-Inhalte haben. Und deswegen gibt es das dann nicht für 16-Jährige. Das heißt also diese Identitätsfindung, die dank Social Media heute besser stattfinden kann als vor 20 Jahren, wird dann unterbunden. Nochmal hier Katharina Dröge, ist es zu schön?
Und es braucht eine Stärkung der Medienkompetenz von Kindern, weil die werden irgendwann auf jeden Fall auf den sozialen Plattformen unterwegs sein und müssen sich in dieser Welt bewegen können. Deswegen gibt es für uns nicht die eine Lösung, sondern es gibt verschiedene Lösungen, an denen man arbeiten muss. Und aus meiner Sicht muss man dabei junge Menschen mit an den Tisch holen. Ich finde, Politik hängt zu oft daran, dass wir über junge Menschen sprechen und nicht mit jungen Menschen. Und wir haben jetzt ein Jugendbeirat eingerichtet, um genau das andersrum zu machen.
Ein Jugendbeirat.
Also, es gibt sehr viele Leute, die sind gar nicht bei Social Media. Einige in meinem nächsten Umfeld, also die kann man googeln, man findet genau gar nichts und so.
Ja, interessant.
Und die könnte man mal einbeziehen in so eine Runde.
Zumal dieses Einbeziehen, das ist ja jetzt, dann kommt wahrscheinlich so ein Bundesschülersprecher so, das ist ja auch immer grauenhaft, was die von sich geben. Da redet man lieber mit keinem. Zumal ich jetzt festgestellt habe, das ist jetzt anekdotische Evidenz, war auf einer Familienfeier, da habe ich mich mit den Kindern meiner Cousine unterhalten, 15 und 12. Die sind zum Beispiel beide mit einem Smartphone schon ausgestattet, aber die haben so auf meine Frage und Social Media TikTok, also TikTok gar nicht.
Nein, vernünftige Eltern verbieten das. Ich kenne keinen.
Instagram sagen sie, ja, da haben sie ein, hat der ältere, hatte dann ein Profil, aber das wäre für ihn nicht wichtig und das würden aber auch seine Freunde nicht. Sie nutzen nur ein Messenger. Das heißt, ich stelle da auch dann fest, wie gesagt, anekdotischer Evidenz, dass also vielleicht gar nicht so ausgeprägt ist mit dem Instagram, wie man mitunterdenkt. Zumindest dieses sich permanent selbst ausstellen, scheint nicht so groß zu sein. Also, dass man jetzt nicht auf 500 Bilder von sich hochhält.
Ja, genau das will ich gerade sagen. Also nicht selber zu posten, vor wem auch, drei Followern. Nee, dafür hat man ja seinen WhatsApp-Status ans Adressbuch geknüpft. Aber lesen sind die, also die Leute sind doch noch konsumierend sehr intensiv dabei.
Ja, wir hören jetzt den Haken dran Podcast.
Sehr guter Podcast.
Kevin Karlmeier war ja auch im Presseclub. Kevin. Kevin Karlmeier war ja auch im Presseclub. Dessen Clips spielen wir aber jetzt nicht aus dem Presseclub, sondern aus dem Haken dran Podcast. Ich finde, dass er das sehr gut macht, weil er tatsächlich im Podcast immer wieder sagt, dass er gegen ein Social Media Verbot ist und so. Also für mich könnte er noch ein bisschen libertärer sein. Also mehr Free Speech, wie ich das hier einfordere.
Aber lassen wir es mal so.
So wie ich das verstehe, sagt er, wir müssen schon das Internet wenn für alle aufräumen.
Ja, aber nicht im Sinne von einer solchen Zensur einführen oder eine Age-Verification hat dann auch große Probleme, wie er uns jetzt an einem Beispiel mal durchdekliniert. Wurde ja inzwischen auch schon wieder gestoppt, dieser Versuch, nämlich Discord wollte für einige Foren jetzt sicherstellen, dass da keine unter 18 Leute dabei sind. Man hat dort Persona beauftragt, diese Age-Verification durchzuführen. Also er hat auf diesen Anbieter zurückgegriffen. Gavin erzählt jetzt mal, wie diese Verification stattfindet. Und deswegen, Stefan hat es ausgeführt, es gäbe andere Möglichkeiten. Ich habe die Befürchtung, dass wir so etwas Ähnliches bekommen werden. Dass die Discord-Community jetzt dagegen rebelliert hat, liegt meines Erachtens nur daran, dass da sehr viele Leute sind, die sich auskennen und die sehr sensibilisiert sind mit seinem solchen Thema. Das hätte bei Instagram nicht so viel Furore gemacht.
So ein Tech-Security-Blogger hat sich mal so ein bisschen angeschaut, was eigentlich auf den Persona-Servern liegen und hat da was ganz Interessantes herausgefunden. Und zwar heißen die The Local Stack. Das ist so ein Tech-Security-Website. Die haben sich zunächst einmal die Datenschutzrichtlinien und Nutzungsbedingungen angeschaut und haben gesehen, für den Identitätscheck, das hat übrigens digitalrechte.de die Website von Markus Becke da ganz gut zusammengetragen, gibt aber auch Dutzende andere Quellen dazu, welche Daten erstmal von dir gesammelt werden. Und zwar dein Name, das Foto, ein Selfie wird benutzt für die Verifikation, um zu zeigen, dass bist wirklich du, deine Gesichtsgeometrie wird gespeichert, die Daten, die auf dem Chip gespeichert sind, deine Passnummer, deine Nationalität, das Geschlecht, das Geburtsdatum, aber auch technische Daten wie die IP-Adresse, der Gerätetyp, die MAC-Adresse, das ist sozusagen deine, wenn man so möchte, die Passnummer deines Computers, der Browser, der Standort, Verhaltensbiometrie, also Verzögerungserkennung, Copy-and-Paste-Erkennung.
Reinster Sammelwut.
Das ist eben das große Anliegen. Irgendein techie Unternehmer möchte gerne diesen Durchbruch. Wir haben sozusagen die digitale Adresse. Und man kann jetzt damit auch zur Behörde gehen oder wie auch immer.
Worldcoin von Sam Altman.
Genau, das ist ein Außending.
Peter Thiel ist da überall mit investiert in diese Geschichten.
Genau, weshalb ich jetzt auch hier einen kleinen Aufruf mache, Kevin. Kevin ist nämlich sehr stolz auf seine Community bei Discord, 2000 Leute, die da immer Kram-Schatten-Redaktion, wie er das nennt. Während ich finde, man kann mit Klots Hilfe auch ganz einfach einen Diskurs betreiben, wo sich dann wie bei uns die Nutzer einfach mit ihrer E-Mail-Adresse anmelden und fertig ist. Und da kann man sich nämlich sozusagen neben so einem Unternehmen, von dem wir jetzt wissen, wie es drauf ist. Also das ist einfach ein Indikator dafür, wie ist Discord so drauf. So, aus diesen ganzen Dingen zu freien.
Die sind jetzt zurückgerudert, zumindest vorerst aufgrund dieses Protests.
Ja, aber sie haben jetzt trotzdem für mich bekannt gegeben, wie sie drauf sind, egal welche Urschläge sie erlebt haben.
Wir hören mal weiter, also das war noch nicht alles, was da gesammelt wird, Datenabgleich.
Und da findet ein Abgleich mit einem globalen Netzwerk vertrauenswürdiger Drittanbieter statt. Dazu gehören Regierungsdatenbanken, Einwohner, Melderregister, Kreditauskünftein, Mobilfunkanbieter und Postdatenbanken.
So, war denn jetzt endlich genug? Nee, immer noch nicht.
Aber das ist nicht alles. Denn es gibt Leute, die haben sich mal die Daten angeschaut, die so öffentlich, und das muss man auch sagen, öffentlich auf Personaservern gelegen haben. Also das sind alles Daten, für die brauchte man keinen Hack. Man musste keine Sicherheitstricks drauf haben. Sie haben 2.456 öffentliche Daten gefunden oder Dateien gefunden, die auf Prozesse schließen lassen, die genau passieren, wenn man bei Persona so eine Verifikation durchführt oder dort seine Daten liegen hat, die übrigens laut Persona für 30 Tage auf dem Server gespeichert werden. Was passiert dann? Und zwar, es werden 269 Prüfschritte durchgeführt, wenn du dich verifizieren lässt. 269. Dabei wird nicht nur das Alter geschätzt, sondern eben 269 Prozesse durchgeführt. Umzugucken, bist du echt. Dann wirst du mit Listen abgeglichen. Zum Beispiel bist du eine politisch exponierte Person oder bist du auf einer Fahndungsliste. Dafür muss man natürlich Zugang zu diesen Regierungs-Servern oder den Regierungslistendaten haben, um sie abzugleichen. Das tun sie. Es werden aber auch belastende Informationen über dich gescreened. Adverse Media heißt es.
So, nun vergleich mal zu dieser Sammelwut, die da stattfindet. Du hast dieses kleine Gerät vom Bund an deinem Rechner. Das liest also deinen elektronischen Personalausweis. Und in dem Moment wird einfach kryptographisch verifiziert, ein Bit umgelegt mit dem Signal, ja, ist vorherig, Punkt. Wir wissen nicht, wer das ist. Wir wissen nicht, wo. Wir wissen gar nichts. Wir wissen einfach nur, ist vorherig.
Ja.
Das ginge auch.
Offenbar nicht gewollt, geht noch weiter.
Und es werden weitere Daten erfasst wie IP-Adressen, deine Geräte, Fingerprints und so weiter und so weiter. Selfie-Analysen und das alles eben gemeinsam auf diesem Persona-Server, der im Zweifel in den USA steht oder selbst wenn er in Deutschland steht. Sie benutzen auch Server, die in deutschen Rechenzentren stehen, mit Hilfe des Cloud Act jederzeit von amerikanischen Behörden überprüfbar sein könnten.
Fröhlicher Datenaustausch. Frederik von Kastel fragt man nach.
Darf ich kurz eine Zwischenfrage stellen? Wieso wird das Alter geschätzt?
Das bieten sie auch an. Also du kannst sozusagen durch deine Nutzungsweiten, bei Discord zum Beispiel kannst du dein Alter schätzen lassen. Wie du dich verhältst, wenn du dich einloggst, sowas. Aber auch durch ein Selfie zum Beispiel.
Also im Abgleich quasi mit deinen Angaben auf deinem Personausweis. Theoretisch könnte man dann dadurch in einem Abgleich herausfinden, ob zum Beispiel eine jüngere Person einen falschen Ausweis benutzt, um sie zu machen.
Genau.
Dann gibt es noch die Drittanbieter.
So, es geht noch ein bisschen weiter. Und zwar kann man sich genau anschauen bei Persona, mit welchen Daten eigentlich deine Daten abgeglichen werden können. Wer sind diese Drittanbieter? Und dazu gehört Entropic, OpenAI, GROCK Cloud, alles Datenanalyse, alles KI-Unternehmen. Entropic und OpenAI kennen wir, GROCK Cloud machen Datenanalyse auch, sitzen in San Jose USA. Dann AWS, also Amazon Web Services, weil wahrscheinlich auch die Daten zur Verfügung stellen. Google Cloud gehört dazu. Dann gehören da aber auch MongoDB, Snowflake, Fingerprint.js zu, also Datenbank-Unternehmen, Datenanalyse, Sigma Computing, Stripe Kreditkartenabwicklung, Persona Identities, Canada, Kundensupport. Insgesamt sitzen Unternehmen, 16 davon sitzen in den USA, kein einziges in der EU.
Das ist die Situation. Jetzt ja noch interessant, denn auch wenn man das so machen würde wie du, dass man jetzt sagt, wir machen diese anonymisierte Altersverifikation, dann gibt es ja noch einen Schritt, der dadurch nicht gemacht werden kann. Nämlich, ja aber von welchen Inhalten sprechen wir dann überhaupt? Und das ist ja wiederum eine politische Debatte, die ja geführt wird jetzt gerade nicht aufrichtig. Dann würde man es nämlich genauso benennen, sondern man sagt ja zum Schutze der Kinder. Zum Schutze der Kinder wurden ja Horrorfilme und alles zensiert. Und jetzt ist ja die Frage, zum Beispiel in dem konkreten Fall Discord für die Erwachseneninhalte, wer entscheidet das denn? Denn wir sehen bei der Heritage Foundation und sehen bei gerade den Politikern, die umtriebig sind in den USA, denen war jetzt doch ein bisschen zu viel Gaser-Solidarität in TikTok und soetwas. Aber wer entscheidet so auf Dauer? Das machen dann zum Beispiel ja welche Freunde.
Das Ding ist auch, das brauchst du bei Discord ja nur für Erwachseneninhalte. Und ob dein Server Erwachseneninhalte fest darstellt, abbildet, das entscheidet eine KI.
Das heißt, die KI wird dann wieder diese Rolle spielen zu sagen, oh, das ist aber ein Inhalt, der nicht geht. Und wir wissen auch um die enorme Prüderie der KI. Ich bin auch da verblüfft, dass wir da nicht...
Aber nicht bei GROG.
Nee, bei GROG nicht. Bei GROG nicht, darum nicht, ja. Aber da sehen wir einfach, es ist auch wenn man, selbst wenn man anonymisiert Age-Verifications durchführt, ist eben die Frage, was zeigen wir wo an? Und da sehen wir im politischen Diskurs nicht das, was du meinst. Aber du sagst, du willst nicht, dass Kinder Menschen sterben sehen. Und ich würde auch sagen, generell sollte man nicht auf diesen Plattformen Menschen sterben sehen, im Sinne von, da springen die aus Häusern runter und unten werden sie doch nicht aufgefangen und so Geschichten, die da gemacht sind. Aber ich würde zum Beispiel schon sagen, wenn da etwas vom Krieg gezeigt wird, dann will ich das sehen. Ich will nicht plötzlich einen Bann haben über das, was in Gaza angerichtet wird und will sagen, das ist ein Inhalt, der hat hier auf der Plattform nichts verloren. Genau diese Entwicklung aber nimmt das natürlich dann sehr stark. Dass also plötzlich es nicht nur darum geht, bei Pornografie ist es noch relativ einfach. Aber wir haben ja schon da bei Instagram früher die Debatten gehabt, die total verstummt sind. Warum dürfen eigentlich Männer sich mit freiem Oberkörper zeigen, Frauen aber nicht? Da hatten wir schon genau diese Sachen. Wir hatten die Beispiele aus Kunstmuseen, die in einer Ausstellung gepostet haben. Da war dann irgendein Bild von Egon Schiele oder so, das wurde zensiert, weil man sagte, das ist eine Sexdarstellung, die darf da nicht sein. Da können wir in diesem Bereich das eine sehen. Das andere ist dann eben diese ganzen politischen Bereiche, wo man auch gleich sagen kann, der hat nicht so viel Gewalt. Also zum Beispiel sagt man dann, keine Videos mehr bei Instagram, die zeigen, wie gewalttätig Eis auf der Straße vorgeht.
Ja, das sehen wir übrigens gerade, also die Videos sind ja weg.
Richtig und da sehen wir einfach, wie sehr das dann mit einer politischen Unterstützung nochmal stärker werden kann. Ich sehe übrigens ja einen Vorteil in diesem Social-Media-Verbot, sollte das relativ restriktiv kommen. Dass es eine Möglichkeit sein könnte, dass sich die jungen Leute auf andere Plattformen begeben und es wirklich mehr Wettbewerb gibt.
Wolfgang, wir machen hier nur das Play-Dohier für eigene Webseite.
Ja, sowieso. Aber du meinst, du weißt, was ich meine, also dass sich neue Communities, neue Dinge da entstehen können, weil diese, das kann ja auch nur die paar großen dann und so, sieht die Politik, das ja auch Big Tech betreffen. Aber dass da möglicherweise nochmal so eine Sternstunde für das Internet, was man mal so anfangs gedacht hatte.
Denn wo kommt das her? Klo schreibt es uns.
Dazu brauchen wir natürlich eine gewisse, dass sie jetzt nicht, es werden ja noch, sollen ja noch andere Dinge reguliert werden. Dazu kommen wir gleich ganz kurz nochmal Haken dran. Gavin spricht über Irland.
Irland überlegt offenbar ein Social-Media-Verbot für Menschen unter 16 einzuführen.
Und er rätselt ein bisschen, warum gerade Irland?
Dass aber jetzt ausgerechnet Irland sich hier so einen Vorstoß traut, obwohl sie ja eigentlich wissen, sie sind sozusagen der sichere Hafen der Tech-Unternehmen, die sich alle wohlfühlen, ist zumindest bemerkenswert.
Aber kein Widerspruch. Denn ich würde sagen, Big Tech will ja gerade, dass da was passiert. Deshalb sehe ich das nicht als Widerspruch. Wir hören jetzt drei Clips aus.
Ich meine, die jungen Leute kann man echt einfach aus dem Internet raushalten, weil die kaufen eh nichts bei Instagram.
Ja.
Also U18 hat gar kein Geld.
Taschengeld?
Naja, aber das ist ja genau das Ding. Die jungen Leute sehen zwar Instagram-Werbung, aber die haben ja nicht wie Erwachsenen einfach so einen Shortcut auf sofort kaufen.
Ach so.
Weil das Konto ist nicht hinterlegt, welches Konto und so.
Hast du jemals schon mal was bei Instagram gekauft?
Ich habe mal was bei Instagram gekauft. Das geht halt wirklich sehr easy, weil du klickst auf eine Werbung. Die Webseite ist sofort wie Instagram optimiert. Da ist der Pay-Button von Apples. Ein Klick und dann hast du Sachen bestellt. Adresse wird mit dem Klick übermittelt. Das haben wir Kids gar nicht, weil die haben keine Apple Pay hinterlegt.
Presseclub, es war verrückt, weil dort...
Welcher Presseclub?
Der Presseclub, in dem auch Gavin war. Ich weiß nicht, ob du den gesehen hast.
Den hab ich gesehen. Aber warum steht da Jakob Hanke?
Und da war Jakob Hanke-Wähler vom Handelsblatt zu Gast, der sich wie folgt äußert.
Wir haben ja immer noch diese Ausnahme für Plattformen, das Plattformprivileg von der Haftung. Also Medien, wenn wir etwas Falsches verbreiten, bewusst, oder Verleumderisches, dann haften unsere Verlage. Und wir müssen das richtig stellen. Wir müssen im Zweifel dann auch Entschädigung zahlen. Das gilt für Plattformen nicht. Seit dem Jahr 2000 haben die dieses Privileg. Da hat die Lobby sehr gute Arbeit geleistet. Und auch der DSA hat dieses Privileg nicht aufgehoben. Also es gibt immer noch eine Aufnahme.
Das heißt, wo müsste man Ihrer Meinung nach nachbessern?
Das ist nicht ein Privileg für Big Tech. Wenn diese Section 230, so heißt die in den USA, wenn dieses Privileg der Plattformen fällt, dann bedeutet das, dass wir zum Beispiel unser Forum einstellen können. Weil dann müssten wir plötzlich dafür haften, wenn dort der eine den anderen beleidigt. Das wäre nicht zu regeln. Da müssen wir jemand einstellen, den ganzen Tag nur Content überwachen.
Warum betrifft das Big Tech nicht?
Big Tech betrifft es natürlich, also ist das ein Privileg, von dem Big Tech profitiert. Nur wird hier so getan, als sei Section 230 gemacht worden, um Big Tech zu schützen. Das wurde aber auch in den 90er Jahren umgesetzt, um das freie Internet zu schützen. Denn das bedeutet, wenn ich jetzt, sagen wir etwas, Volksverhetzendes poste in den sozialen Medien, dann wird nicht Mark Zuckerberg dafür belangt, sondern ich werde dafür belangt. Also das ist nicht, übrigens, das muss man auch verstehen, es ist nicht ein Gesetz, das sagt, ihr könnt machen, was ihr wollt, ihr User, sondern die User sind schon verantwortlich dafür, was sie da schreiben. Wenn wir aber jetzt sagen, das muss wie eine Redaktion behandelt werden, und ich weiß, wer das auch will, nämlich Jürgen Habermas, wir haben damals über diesen Text gesprochen, über den neuen Strukturwandel der Öffentlichkeit, als er diese Update mache, dann würde man damit das freie Internet kaputt machen. Das ist aber etwas, was vor allem Verlagshäuser gerne wollen, damit sie weiterhin ihre Vormachtstellung da haben. Es ist völlig falsch, das so darzustellen. Dann war ich doch auch erstaunt darüber, wie von der Zeit jetzt Laura Herkleiter...
Kennst du sie?
Nein.
Ein totales Mysterium.
Weiß nicht, wer das ist.
Also sie war Süddeutsche für die Torchefin, ist jetzt Zeit für die Torchefin und es scheint die erste öffentliche Auftrott zu sein.
Ja, zumindest hat sie nicht nochmal nachgedacht über das Thema Klarnamen.
Bundeskanzler Merz hat sich für Klarnamen ausgesprochen, hat er diese Woche gesagt. Und dazu gibt es auch bei uns hier die Frage, traut sich überhaupt noch jemand Kritik zu äußern, wenn es eine Klarnamenpflicht gäbe? Was macht denn so etwas, wenn man auf einmal sagt, hier stehen wirklich jetzt alle Namen so, wie sie sind?
Ich hoffe doch. Ich glaube, die Umsetzbarkeit ist die gleiche. Auch das muss man ja dann irgendwie vorweisen können. Aber eine Klarnamenpflicht ist auf jeden Fall ein gutes Vorankommen.
Also ich war wegen zwei Sachen sehr gespannt auf diesen Presseclub. Das ist ein natürlich Gevin's Premiere sehr gut. Und dann die Laura, weil ich so nachlassen dachte, wow, beeindruckende Biografie. Sie muss ja schon ein paar Mal eingeladen worden sein. Hatte offenbar immer alles abgesagt und dachte mir, aus irgendwelchen Gründen wird sie ja wohl zugesagt haben, jetzt in diesem Presseclub. Und dann stellte sich raus, das Mysterium ist geblieben.
Ich verstehe das gar nicht. Ich glaube, dass da die Leute immer so aus ihrer eigenen Position rausdenken, ja, wenn man in der Öffentlichkeit publiziert, dann ist da mein Name dabei.
Die Klarnam-Diskussion ist doch nun wirklich ein Jahrhundert alt. Ja, das sind doch wirklich alle Argumente. Da kann man doch nicht so hier, als ob man zum allen Klarnamen, ja, doch, finde ich gut.
Schön, dann gut, die, die da jetzt irgendwelche Oppressionen zu... Ja, ich habe aber noch mal drüber nachgedacht, warum ist das so? Und das hatte ja auch Taylor Lawrence sehr gut beschrieben. Sie war bei irgend so einem Ding dabei, wo lauter Influencer eingeladen waren aus den USA. Und die wurden dann auch nach Klarnamenpflicht gefragt und haben die alle hurra geschrien. Und ich erinnere mich auch noch...
Die sind ja mit Klarnamen im Internet.
Ja, die denken das für sich, aber dann haben sie ja Kritik. Also ich habe es ja auch erlebt, dass viele Influencer, vor allem Influencerinnen, die Kritik, die ich geäußert habe am Influencertum, als Hass im Netz darstellen. Also für die ist ja eigentlich schon Kritik, Hass im Netz. Das hat sich ja so ausgebreitet, dass inzwischen alles, was man sagt, Hass im Netz geworden ist. Und die wollen eigentlich die Anwälte losschicken. Die wollen, dass das ständig irgendwo nicht mehr frei berichtet wird, damit sie ihr Geschäftsmodell nicht gefährdet sehen. Diese Leute haben sowieso kein Verständnis von dem, was im Internet noch sein kann, nämlich dass man aus nicht-kommerziellen Interessen vielleicht politische Ansichten vertritt, die unter Repressionen stehen. Diese Leute gehen alle immer nur von dem Staat aus, der nur wohlmeint ist, der nur alles gut findet. Und deswegen sagen sie, ja, da können wir doch die Meinung sagen. Und die anderen, die sind ja sowieso Demokratiefeinde und deswegen müssen wir. Und das ist so ein Denken, dass alle diesen Schulterschluss jetzt gerade machen. Ich halte das jedenfalls für sehr gefährlich, was da gerade stattfindet. Aber wir können das noch überbieten. FAZ.
Wer hat geschrieben?
Oliver Weber. Schreibt da rüber Social-Media-Verbot für Jugendliche. Alles gut und schön, aber was so mit den Erwachsenen? Er sagt 70 Prozent der jungen Erwachsenen verbringen mehr Zeit am Handy, als ihnen selbst lieb ist. Zwei Drittel befürchten sogar andere Dinge, deshalb zu vernachlässigen. Mehr als die Hälfte will ihren Social-Media-Konsum reduzieren, schafft es aber nicht. Offenbar stößt das Ideal der Selbstbestimmung in der digitalen Welt an eine Grenze. Kein Wunder, Tech-Konzerne beschäftigen ganze Bataillone von Entwicklern, die daran arbeiten, die Screentime ihrer Kunden zu maximieren. So, die Diagnose ist ja nicht neu, aber jetzt können wir erstmal sagen, gilt das nicht für ganz viele andere Dinge auch? Also könnte man nicht auch sagen, 70 Prozent der jungen Erwachsenen essen mehr Zucker, als ihnen lieb ist. Zwei Drittel befürchten sogar, dass sie viel früher dadurch sterben werden. Mehr als die Hälfte der Konsumenten von zuckerhaltigen Produkten schafft es nicht, davon loszukommen. Offenbar stößt das Ideal der Selbstbestimmung in der analogen Welt an eine Grenze. Der Artikel würde auch funktionieren. Da sehen wir schon mal, aha, wir können das nicht jetzt mal so mit einem Verbot klären. Aber trotzdem geht es weiter. Probleme dieser Art, also das war jetzt meine Paraphrasierung des Textes von Oliver Weber, das war nicht seine Idee. Probleme dieser Art sind grundsätzlich auch in der analogen Welt bekannt, schreibt er dann. Auch im Fall von Drogenspiegelsochten und Zigaretten kämpft der gute Wille des Konsumenten gegen seine Begierden. Im Digitalen kommt jedoch noch was hinzu, die Kraft der Netzwerke. Und dann sagt er dann, ja, man will eigentlich raus, aber man schafft es nicht, da rauszukommen, sonst wäre man ja sozial isoliert. Und dann würde ich sagen, nee, über Messenger-Dienste läuft eigentlich die Nahkommunikation. Und da geht es ja jetzt nicht darum, dass da Leute exkludiert werden. Und da würde man jetzt nicht den Anschluss verpassen zu den Freundschaften, wenn man nicht mehr in den sozialen Medien ist. Denn wir haben ja gerade festgestellt, junge Leute posten dann gar nicht unbedingt so viel von sich und haben auch ihre Profile meistens so gestellt, dass man gar nicht Zugriff auf sie hat. Dann sagt er hier, ja, die Mehrheit würden die sozialen Medien lieber abschaffen. Aber das sind so Äußerungen, die sind ja nicht in dem Sinne ernst zu nehmen, wenn die Leute das sagen, so als seien sie so sehr abhängig davon und nur noch ein Verbot kann mich davor retten. Das ist doch unsinnig. Es heißt hier, deshalb verschwenden die befragten Studenten einen Großteil ihrer Zeit mit Kurzvideos. Nicht, weil sie sich gerne auf den Plattformen aufhalten, sondern weil alle anderen dort sind.
Nee, das stimmt nicht. Das stimmt bei TikTok ausdrücklich nicht.
Da hat man ja gar keine Community in dem Sinne.
Das heißt zwar for you, aber ob das wirklich die Freunde vorher auch gesehen haben oder nicht, spielt doch gar keine Rolle.
Das ist doch Quatsch. Vor allem könnte ich ja dann auch sagen, deshalb verschwenden die befragten Studenten den Großteil ihrer Zeit mit Laber-Podcasts, weil sie gerne danach mit Freunden darüber reden wollen.
Also ich finde, und das ist halt wirklich, so differenziert geht ja niemand vor, aber Social Media hier und Short Video hier sind zwei völlig unterschiedliche Sachen.
Zum Beispiel.
Und dieses Short Video-Ding hat auch gar nicht so viel mit Leuteposten selbst, sondern das ist halt wirklich so ein Brain-Rot-System. Das hat aber mit diesem Social-Teil wirklich gar nichts mehr zu tun.
Zudem bist du ja jemand, der viel häufiger als ich in der Insta-Story Short Videos verlinkt, die interessant sind. Kürzlich hattest du, das habe ich dann sogar selbst mal geteilt, ein Short-Video verlinkt von Karin Lay, die dort einen wunderbaren Sketch aufführen.
Wir referieren kurz. Also sie spielt eine Omi, die in die Behörde geht und sagt, ich habe das Haus meiner Oma geerbt. Die Wohnung für 100.000 Euro. 100.000 Euro. Ja, dann macht das 30.000 Euro Erbschaftssteuer. Und dann kommt sie in der zweiten Szene als…
Nein, die Geschichte ist anders. Wir müssen die korrekte zählen. Die Geschichte ist, ich will meiner Freundin Trude meine Wohnung für 100.000 Euro verschenken. Und darauf kommt eine Schenkungssteuer von 30 Prozent.
In der zweiten Szene kommt sie dann als… Hallo, Döpfner, mein Name. Ich habe gerade eine Milliarde geerbt. Und diese kleine Pointe, die dann jetzt kommt, die ist nämlich wirklich superwitzig. Okay, wie viele Schenkungssteuer muss ich jetzt zahlen? Ich kann ja gar nicht, weil ich habe gerade kein Bargeld. Aber warum haben Sie kein Bargeld und dann Ihre Pointe? Ich habe mit meinem Bargeld gerade Springer-Aktien gekauft, deswegen habe ich nichts. Ach so, ja dann, okay, 0 Euro.
Ja, sehr gut.
Das ist einfach genial. Ja. Und sie war toll verkleidet.
Ein Hoch auf das Kurzvideo.
Genau.
Ja, also ist schon die Frage.
Sagen wir hier doch einfach kurz filmen.
Soziale Medien richten, anders als Zigaretten, viel diffuseren Schaden an, heißt es dann im Artikel, der sich nicht in Lebensjahren beziffern lässt. Ihre Folgen sind aber womöglich ähnlich gravierend. Da ist dann von der Atomisierung der Gesellschaft die Rede. So, was folgt jetzt daraus, wenn wir diese Analogie ziehen? Ja, Einsamkeit, wir kennen dieses Problem, aber wir wissen auch, wenn wir den Leuten jetzt Social Media wegnehmen, dann sind die nicht plötzlich zweisam. Dann bleiben die erstmal einsam, nur ohne Social Media.
Dann merken sie es auch, dass sie einsam sind.
Er sagt dann selbst, dass ein Verbot für Erwachsene von Social Media höchstwahrscheinlich, schreibt er, gegen die verfassungsmäßig garantierte Handlungsfreiheit darstellen würde.
Ja, ich glaube, auch die große Hoffnung, dass sie dann alle zu faz.net gehen.
Ambitionierter wäre ein höherer Steuersatz auf Digital-Werbung, wo ich denke, naja, dann macht man das Digital-Geschäft damit ein bisschen schwerer.
Vor allem da schießt sich die FAZ ja selber ins Bein. Wer lebt denn von Digital-Werbung?
Eben.
Auf beiden Seiten übrigens.
Also es ist ja nicht so, dass dann die Leute sagen, dann schalte ich keine Werbung mehr auf den Plattformen. Also ich weiß gar nicht, wo das hinführen soll. Und wie gesagt, ich will auch nochmal sagen, das ist so eine Konzentration hier in dem Artikel auf Social Media. Was ist mit Twitch? Bei Twitch sind junge Leute fünf Stunden lang, gucken sich was an. Ich will das gar nicht als positiv oder negativ darstellen. Ich stelle nur fest, dass das so ist.
Also als ich bei Gavin im Haken dran Podcast war, haben wir eigentlich so eine kleine Zäsur eingeschlagen und gesagt, jetzt ist irgendwie so ein KI-Zeitalter, keine Ahnung, was es bedeutet. Aber das Social-Media-Zeitalter ist vorbei. Also alle Verherlichungen zum Thema auch hier und da und mystisch und so kann man jetzt abhaken, wir wissen jetzt, was das ist und so weiter und so fort.
Und Weber wünscht sich dann eine größere Reformbewegung. Er will am Ende zu den Algorithmen der Plattformen durchdringen. Und dann frage ich mich, ja, wir haben jetzt das mit dem TikTok-Algorithmus schon 100 mal durchgesprochen, aber was ist dann jetzt generell mit Algorithmus? Also dann bekommt die FAZ-Seite ein Problem. Reddit funktioniert ja zum Beispiel auch mit einem gewissen Algorithmus. Da werden auch Dinge, die viel diskutiert werden, viel geliked werden, nach oben geschoben. Also in diesem Forum, in dem vor allem ja Textliches stattfindet, neben bisschen Video und Foto ist es ja vor allem Text und Diskussion dann dort, ist es ja auch ein Algorithmus, der da greift. Aber würden wir jetzt auch sagen, ja, die jungen Leute sind redditsüchtig. Man müsste dann erstmal in der Tagesschau erklären, was ist der Reddit. Ja, eben. Genau. Da kennt man nämlich einige, die da sind. Oder Discord. Discord ist für viele das soziale Leben am Nachmittag, wenn sie aus der Schule kommen oder auch am Abend von Leuten, die aus dem Beruf kommen. Discord ist auch etwas, was diese enorm vielen Stunden bedeutet, die da immer so zusammengezählt werden, wie viele Stunden die Leute am Computer oder am Smartphone unterwegs sind. Nachrichtenseiten sind algorithmisch gesteuert. Ich weiß wirklich nicht, warum die Diskussion gerade, die ja schon uralt ist, so maximal blöde geführt wird.
Ja, ich weiß es schon. Also ich vermute einfach, dass hier die Konzerne ihre große Transition planen.
Ja.
Dazu brauchen sie ein bisschen mehr von uns. Das soll jetzt aufgeschlossen werden.
Wir haben ja, das ist für mich immer noch einer der wichtigsten Salons. Wir haben ja über das Buch von Alex Karp gesprochen. Und da geht es in den ersten Seiten ja darum, dass er sagt, dieses ganze Consumer Electronics und Social Media Ding, die Next App entwickeln, das hat uns ja ganz kaputt gemacht. Wir müssen doch eigentlich an den wahren Kern vordringen. Wir müssen jetzt sehen, wie können wir Sicherheit herstellen, Anti-Migration, wie können wir stark werden in allen Belangen, militärisch dann auch. Und er sieht ja die Menschen noch viel mehr als diese Leute, die irgendwelche süchtig machenden Apps entwickeln, als eine Verfügungsmasse, die jetzt seinem höherem Ziel der westlichen Zivilisation entsprechen soll. Diese Verfügungsmasse. Und was jetzt eigentlich da stattfindet, ist, dass man sagt, die haben jetzt die ganze Zeit so konsumiert, haben sich nur Kurzvideos angesehen. Mit denen ist es so eine heere nationale Aufgabe, so eine westliche Zivilisation nicht mehr zu retten. Deshalb müssen wir jetzt sehen, dass wir denen das entsprechend regulieren. Wann wir da an Daten kommen, wir müssen es auch so regulieren, dass gewisse Inhalte, die nämlich z.B. gegen uns sind, nicht mehr in den sozialen Medien angenommen werden. Und da ist es gut, wenn wir im Schulterschluss mit der Politik gehen, weil die ja sowieso schon immer sagen, ja genau Big Tech müsste man doch irgendwie mal regulieren und einschränken. Und dann kommen sie zu solchen neuen Entwicklungen. Also eigentlich muss man gerade sagen, ist jetzt nicht etwas gewonnen aus der Diskussion, sondern man hat sich eigentlich jetzt von dieser Seite aus diese kritische Diskussion über die sozialen Medien angeeignet und versucht jetzt zu ihren Gunsten, versuchen die Tech-Konzerne jetzt dieses Spiel zu gewinnen. Und die Politik und auch die Journalisten, die in diese Richtung gehen, sind eigentlich dort verpartnert bzw. sind ja Kameraden im Kampfe gegen eigentlich das, was man wünschen sollte, nämlich ein freies Internet.
Genau. Und im Zuge dessen treffe ich hier eine redaktionelle Entscheidung und modele ein Thema rein, das ich vorher gar nicht mit angesagt habe. Ich bin gespannt. Hollywood schieben wir auf. Lars Weißbrot und Ijoma Mangold auch, die ja mit Nina Power über dieses Lesen sprachen. Das sind so fast zeitlose Themen. Wobei, wenn ich jetzt sage, wir warten einfach einen Monat, um uns diese Hollywood-Dinger anzugucken, dann ist vielleicht wirklich schon kein Hollywood mehr da.
Meinst du, es ist so schnell?
Es ist wirklich gruselig.
Also ich habe gestern den neuen Film von Scream gesehen. Da würde ich auch sagen, bitte lass das eine KI das nächste Mal machen.
Wir waren es so. Wir nehmen ja nächste Woche schon den Salon auf, aber publizieren ja erst später, wenn wir dürfen, wenn das Buch dann da ist. Weshalb ich mein Vorschlag wäre, wir treffen uns ja nächste Woche eh hier, besprechen dann die Hollywood-Sachen und den Teil veröffentlichen wir auch schon mal und dann kommt der Salon trotzdem erst zehn Tage später.
Okay.
Dann haben wir aktuell kurz über Hollywood gesprochen.
Wir werden das hinbekommen und nicht nur Verwirrung stiften.
Genau. Weshalb wir jetzt kurz über Metas Neues anliegen, und zwar genau in diesem Tenor, an dem wir jetzt darüber sprachen. Also eigentlich weiß Mark Zuckerberg, Instagram ist schon mehr wert als Facebook, aber irgendwie steht immer noch Facebook, wenn auch Namensänderungen im Aktienkurs. Und so richtig gerechtfertigt ist das ja noch nicht. Es muss ja auch psychologisch bei Investoren verankert werden, dass da ein großer Shift stattfand. Was also mit Facebook tun, nachdem man ewig lange diese Idee hatte, da habe ich ja einen Text damals mit Christoph R. Herr, er weiß nicht mehr genau, ist auch schon zehn Jahre her, als ich geschrieben habe für die FAZ, Facebooks großes Ansinnen, jetzt endlich das Identifikationssystem zu bauen, nachdem die amerikanische Regierung seit 30 Jahren sozusagen Ausschau hält. Bislang ist das ja noch nicht so gekommen, aber sie haben ja noch nicht mal ein analoges ID-System so richtig. Und Meta hat jetzt hier einen großen neuen Aufschlag gemacht mit Named Tech. Man soll zumindest mit der KI-Brille mal rumlaufen und dann angezeigt bekommen, wem man denn hier so begegnet. Wirklich verrückt, wird hier im The Verge Podcast ganz kritisch begleitet.
Dieses Feature wird nametag genannt. Und dieses Dokument, das ich glaube, von Ende Mai war, legt den Plan auf, nametag zu starten. Und die Idee war es, es an einer Konferenz für blinde Menschen zu eröffnen, um diese dort zu beobachten. Das ist bereits ein bisschen zynisch, wir werden das Ding nehmen und die beste mögliche Version der Spin auf den Plan legen, in einer Art, dass es ein Feature für die Anwendung und es wertvoll ist für diese Gruppe von Menschen. Einfach alle anderen Verwendungskassen und Schreie ignorieren. Aber egal, es gibt auch eine Linie in der Memo, die sich spezifisch, ich werde dich nur diese Linie lesen, weil es einfach, ich könnte es aufstehen, aber es sagt auf sich selbst. Es sagt, wir werden während einer dynamischen politischen. Das ist der erste Teil der Podcastshow, in dem viele zivilistische Gruppen, die wir erwähnen würden, ihre Ressourcen auf andere Sorgen konzentrieren würden.
Ruhig.
Das ist einfach, ich meine...
Eis ist, wenn man Kinder in den Gefängnis bringt, dann ist das ein guter Zeitpunkt, eine weltweite Faschistik zu eröffnen.
Niemand wird Zeit haben, uns darüber zu verraten.
Muss man noch irgendwas dazu sagen?
Eigentlich nicht, nein.
Und kranke Zeit nicht mehr verhindern.
Ich habe es so viele Jahre lang gesagt, so viele Leute haben mich über das gepinkelt. Das ist die Killer-App. Die digitale Information über das Real-Welt auf ein Paar Gläser ist die Killer-App für die nächste Generation von Geräten. Es sind keine Chatbots, es sind keine VR, es sind keine anderen Sachen. Es ist wirklich die digitale Information über das Real-Welt, und es erhöht deine Realität. Und die Killer-App für das ist, du kannst in einer Konferenz alle Namen kennen. Die zweite Feature ist veröffentlicht, und jeder wird diese Klassen kaufen. Und du solltest sie nicht machen. Denn der soziale Kosten von diesem Produkt ist, eine weltweite Datenbank der Faktenkennung und Beherrschung zu bauen, die für nefarische Gründe benutzt werden. Und Metta sagt laut, dass wir nicht denken, dass die Leute uns dort hinsetzen werden, weil sie mit den restlichen Zivilverbrechen beschäftigt sind.
Das ist so zynisch, wie es geht. Corporate Therapy mit Humann und Mary schon mal besprochen. Dieses KI-Zeitalter erlaubt uns ja, so ein bisschen Obskurität wegzunehmen. Plötzlich steht jedem Coding zur Verfügung. Man hat so einen riesigen Auftrag von seinem Steuerberater, such mal bitte alle Rechnungen raus, was auch immer. Und man so, hier mach mal. Die KI macht es einfach. Also Leute solche Sachen, aber hier halt auch. Die natürliche Welt, also die materielle Welt, man geht in einen Raum und es wird einem sofort aufgeschlüsselt, wer da ist.
Ja, das ist ja dann hat man Klarnamenpflicht.
Genau. Das ist ein bisschen wie bei Google und Apple, die immer schon sagen, wenn man so navigiert, halt das Handy aufrecht. Dann sehen wir die Häuser und dann sagen wir dir auf der Karte, wo du rechts und links und so weiter.
Ja, jetzt stell dir mal vor, bei Demonstrationen sagt man auch, wir müssen da mal wissen, denn es gab in den vergangenen Jahren immer wieder Ausschreitungen oder Positionen, die sich nicht decken mit diesem und jenem. Sollten wir da nicht mal auf diese Technologie zurückgreifen. Das sehen wir. Also ich finde das so interessant, dass wir so einen enormen Wunsch haben nach mehr Partenalismus, dass wir so einen Wunsch haben auch bei jenen, die sich als liberal bezeichnen würden oder links liberal bezeichnen würden, nach dem Staat, der soll das jetzt mal klären. Also wenn ich Diagnosen habe über unsere Gegenwart, zum Beispiel Einsamkeit oder Konzentrationsschwäche, dann kann ich das auch verbinden mit den sozialen Medien und würde auch sagen, wer sich konzentrieren will, Bücher lesen will, muss das Smartphone aus dem Raum verbannen. Da geht kaum ein Weg dran vorbei. Aber was ich doch nicht sagen würde ist, ich muss jetzt mal nach dem Staat rufen, der soll mir das doch bitte jetzt mal entsprechend regeln für mich, damit ich einen solchen Patternalismus habe, wie der jetzt da bei Oliver Weber in der FAZ ausgebreitet wurde. Oder jetzt hier sehen wir, dass die Unternehmen ja schon ganz deutlich machen, worum es hier geht. Also das als Killer-App zu bezeichnen, also Leute zu identifizieren, ist ja genau der richtige Begriff dafür. Und dass das eine Möglichkeit ist, dass diese Tech-Konzerne nicht mehr gegen den Staat operieren, sondern mit dem Staat operieren. Weil ein Staat, der entscheidet ja eigentlich über Leben und Tod, so ist ja der Souveränitätsgedanke, der braucht eigentlich die Killer-App. So muss man es doch begreifen. Eis und alles ist ja auf der Straße. Ich kann gar nicht verstehen, wie man jetzt, wo Eis, wo also Silicon Valley und Washington wirklich zusammen Menschen auf der Straße selektieren und auch töten sogar. Dass man in dem Moment sagt, ja toll, dass die Politik in Washington mal gegen das Silicon Valley kämpft.
Wo? Ja, es ist genau so, wie du beschreibst. Plus, dass da halt wirklich böse Leute am Zuge sind.
And the thing that's gonna happen is you can't product your way out of glasses getting ripped off of people's faces, right? You can't product your way out of people physically demanding that you take the thing that's tracking them off of your face. We saw it with glass holes.
So, damit meint er nur, man kann das Produkt nicht so gestalten, dass es nach unseren und seinen Wünschen richtig einzusetzen geht. So. Weshalb Mark Zuckerberg auf eine besondere Idee kam.
I guarantee you, if this product is released, that we'll see it again. And there's a line in the story where Zuckerberg is saying he thinks they should turn off the recording light.
Oh, wow.
Or not have it be so prominent. And you know why, it's because that is the social cost that will make people say turn that off or take those off.
That becomes the problem.
You're watching the ring outcry and then you're like, and then we'll put the glasses on everyone's face. These are not compatible ideas.
Ja, mit dem Ring outcry meint er die Werbung im Superbowl, die da lief mit von Amazon. Wir können alle Hunde finden, weil wir die Türklingelkameras nutzen, um streunende Hunde zu finden. Und dann alle so, für die Hunde. Ja, wer geht jetzt auf die Hunde? Dann wird das auch ja menschlich arg gesagt. Ja, wirklich übel. Wir hören einen kurzen Clip von Pivot dazu.
His testimony show me once again, he is absolutely intractable.
Damit ist jetzt er gemeint, weil ich eben sagte, Zuckerberg ist so böse. Das ist ja eine neue Technologie. Die alte Technologie ist ja Facebook, Silicon Valley. Und da ging es ja um die Frage, ist Instagram mit Schuld daran, wie es jungen Frauen geht und so weiter. Und Mark Zuckerberg soll jetzt vor Gericht aussagen, worauf Carys Wisher kommentiert.
Wir haben die Hunderts, wenn nicht tausende Familien, die Kinder sich selbst getötet haben. Es gibt Millionen Familien, die mit Angst und Depressionen kämpfen. Und es gibt viele verschiedene Faktoren hier, aber das hat definitiv etwas schlimmer gemacht.
So, wir haben also eine 20-jährige Geschichte, die hier vor Gericht aufgearbeitet wird. Und Mark Zuckerberg nutzt die Gelegenheit, um die nächsten 20 Jahre vorzubereiten. Hier ein Video von Instagram.
Die sehr erste Sache, die ich gemerkt habe, als Mark Zuckerberg in die Social Media Trial in LA in LA war, wie viele Mitglieder seines Entourages Meta Ray-Ban AI-Glöckchen hatten. War das eine präzise Marketing, ein absurdes Social Media Moment, ein gigantisches FU zu dem legalen System, vielleicht alles über dem. Mark Zuckerberg war in der Karte zu testifizieren, dass der Meta die Kinder der Verbrecher verbreitet. Seine Sicherheitsgruppe wanderte in die Karte, mit den Ray-Ban-AI-Glöckchen. Diese Glöckchen können alles verringern, Video, Audio, alles. Das Verringern ist gebannt im Bundesverfassungsgericht. Er sagte, wenn du alles verringert hast, dann eröffne es jetzt oder face die Konsequenzen. META hat diese Klassen gemacht, sie sind ein Team.
Auf der Nase rum, es ist wirklich unglaublich. Ich bin jetzt sehr interessiert, was mit dieser Bibi los ist. Du hast mir angeteasst, lass uns das doch als letztes Thema machen.
Bibi, Bibi Claßen, die mit Julienco lange Zeit zusammen war und verheiratet war.
Bibi's Beauty Palace, es gibt ja noch eine zweite.
Damit begann das. Dann haben die zusammen natürlich sehr viel Content gemacht. Kinder, haben sie auch ein Leben in der Influencer High Society, also die wahrscheinlich erfolgreichste Influencerin Deutschlands und darüber hinaus extrem erfolgreich. Bibi jedenfalls hat sich dann irgendwann zurückgezogen, hat sich auch getrennt, lebt in einer neuen Beziehung jetzt, war bei Ben Ungeskripte, dort war ich auch schon mal zu Gast, um jetzt von ihrer, sagen wir, neuen Personality zu berichten.
Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt zurückgehe in deinem Leben fünf Jahre ungefähr, da war Geld, Fame, alles da, alles mega cool. So und du sagst aber, das war trotzdem nicht die beste Zeit deines Lebens. Was genau hat dir gefehlt?
Da hat mir definitiv am meisten gefehlt, dass ich nicht im Einklang mit mir selbst gelebt habe.
Nicht im Einklang mit sich selbst. Wir sprechen jetzt nicht darüber, um zu sagen, wie geht es eigentlich Bibi, das interessiert uns, denke ich, eher nicht und wird die meisten nicht so interessieren, sondern was uns interessiert ist, welcher Neu-Diskurs ist da eigentlich aufgekommen, dass jetzt alle die ganze Zeit von ihrem Selbst reden, dass sie mit sich im Einklang sein wollen, sich entdecken sollen, wollen. Wir erleben also hier eine Generation von Influencern, die extrem erfolgreich und reich geworden ist. Und diese Generation jetzt stellt sich aber auch zunehmend zu einer Frage nach dem Sinn und nach dem Ich. Beziehungsweise meine These wäre, wir haben Peak-Influencertum, wie Ole und ich das im Buch beschrieben haben, erreicht. Wir haben damals schon angedeutet, viel mehr wird jetzt auch so Mental Health und alles diskutiert.
Und jetzt kann man durch den Medienwandel auch, der darauf hinausläuft, dass alle die ganze Zeit im Podcast sitzen und von ihren Mental Health-Problemen berichten, so eine neue Personality sich schaffen und auch einen neuen Einflussbereich, möglicherweise, das werden wir sehen, auch neue Geschäftsmodelle. Dabei geht es immer um das Selbst. Und wenn man mal so drauf achtet in den Diskursen, dann haben wir natürlich so eine Selbstfindungssituatur schon sehr lange. Aber wir merken jetzt so, dass das Selbst noch mal so als Gehirn, wie kommt man da noch mal ran? Die Seele, ist die im Einklang mit irgendetwas? Also was Spirituelles ist da auch mit drin. Das muss nicht gleich so religiös sein wie dabei, ist das Lena oder Lisa oder eine dieser Zwillinge? Da sehen wir auch so, dass die so im freievangetischen Bereich unterwegs sind. Wir sehen also so eine neue Hinwendung ja auch zur Religion. Jedenfalls wird so dieses Ich gesucht und ein Sinn soll hergestellt werden, der aber essentiell irgendwo verankerbar ist. Man kann fast so sagen, man sucht jetzt die Seele, ob da doch irgendwo so eine Substanz ist, dass ich sage, hier da oben, da sitzt sie, die Seele, was auch immer. Hören wir mal weiter.
Ich habe ein Leben gelebt, was eigentlich gar nicht zu mir gepasst hat und habe gedacht, dass das das ist, was ich brauche und was ich will, weil das ja auch von außen so gefeiert wird und weil das ja das ist, was gesellschaftlich überall angestrebt wird. Und habe herausgefunden, dass dieses Leben nicht mein Leben war und ich nicht im Einklang mit mir selbst gelebt habe.
Lebt also ein Leben der Superreichen?
Meinst du, sie wurde entfremdet von ihrer Arbeit?
Das schildert sie jetzt gleich. Ja, wir müssen uns das einfach jetzt mal so vorstellen. Also ich verstehe auch eigentlich nicht, nichts muss anders werden. Wir haben damals, Ole und ich, nie verstanden, warum in den Kommentaren alle immer so positiv gestimmt waren, wenn die in den Privatjet gestiegen sind, um zu ihrem Ferienhaus zu fliegen, das 15 Mal größer ist als in einer normalen Wohnung in Deutschland. Da war nie in den Kommentaren eine Kritik daran zu lesen, sondern alle fanden das irgendwie toll, obwohl sie eine ganz andere Situation haben. Und jetzt finde ich interessant, und das kann man bei ganz vielen Promis beobachten, die die ganze Zeit von ihren Innerlichkeiten sprechen und wo sie da schwierige Zeiten hatten und gestruggelt haben, wie sie dann sagen, dass auch da alle immer so sagen, ja klar, kann ich so nachvollziehen. Aber jetzt stellen wir uns mal vor, ihr würdet so eine Angestellte sprechen, die Mediangehalt bekommt. Die sagt jetzt hier.
Und dann wurde oft der Alltag so gestaltet, dass es zum Content passt. Also ich habe oft gar nicht so gelebt, wie ich mir das persönlich gewünscht hätte, sondern so, wie es notwendig war. Weil mein Leben war ja mein Content.
Das ist jetzt auf den Content bezogen, aber wir können das jetzt mal auch normalen Abhängigkeitsverhältnis der Lohnabhängigen sagen. Ja, die meisten müssen arbeiten, um Geld zu verdienen.
Da wird das Leben typischerweise danach gestaltet.
Richtig.
Wecker gestellt zum Beispiel.
Ja, da kann man nicht sagen, ich drehe mich heute morgen nochmal um. War sowieso so regnerisch da draußen.
Bibi sagt, also erstmal lebe ich jetzt mein Leben für mich und nicht für Content?
Wer kann sagen, ich lebe jetzt mein Leben für mich? Da gibt es nur ganz wenige, also sie in solchen Positionen. Und dann gibt es dann Leute, die sich künstlerisch ausdrücken können, die erfüllt sein können. Und ich würde auch sagen, dass bei mir ein Krater reicht ist, wo ich sagen kann, ich mache die Dinge aus einer großen Lust heraus, ja, das gibt es dann. Aber die meisten Leute können ja so frei gerade nicht agieren.
Das bedeutet, mein Wohl und meine Bedürfnisse stehen im Hier und Jetzt an oberster Stelle. Und ich verbiege mich nicht.
Wer kann es sich leisten, sich nicht zu verbiegen? Die meisten Leute müssen sich laufend verbiegen, um irgendwo weiterzukommen.
Wie lange ist sie da?
Ich habe mir das drei Stunden angehört. Ich habe wenige kurze Clips dazu gemacht. Also keine Sorge, es wird jetzt nicht ein Endlospodcast hier für uns werden. Aber das ist das, was jetzt unglaublich beliebt ist. Also wir müssen sagen, Bibi ist jetzt Schifre. Es geht jetzt nicht darum zu sagen, ah, Bibi ist so, sondern das könnte ich jetzt auch aus tausend anderen Podcasts so zusammentragen. Diese Talks. Bibi erzählt erst mal so, wie sie rangegangen ist, wenn sie sich erinnert an ihre Zeit, als sie mit Bibi-Beauty-Palace gestartet ist und schnell groß wurde.
Ich habe natürlich am Anfang sehr viele Sachen gemacht, die mir Spaß gemacht haben, aber ich muss dazu wirklich auch sagen, dass ich auch die allerersten Videos habe ich geguckt, hey, was ist im Trend, was kommt gut an? Ich hatte selten Momente, wo ich einfach überlegt habe, worauf habe ich jetzt wirklich Lust? Was will ich jetzt machen?
Das heißt, sie hat das Internet zugemüllt, das ist ja genau das, was wir auch immer kritisiert haben, um damit sehr viel Geld zu verdienen. Jetzt, wo sie das Geld verdient hat, sagt sie, ich muss jetzt aber auch mal über was Sinnvolles nachdenken. Also denke ich mal über mich nach. Interessant ist hier, wie sie das Luxusleben beschreibt. Auch das kann man doch ganz gut dann verstehen, wie das so funktioniert. Der Privatschutt, den habe ich schon erwähnt. Wie war das jetzt mit diesem Luxus? Sie hat also sieben Tage die Woche im Prinzip Content produziert. Sag dann.
Du möchtest irgendwann Ausgleich dafür schaffen. So war es bei mir. Also habe ich gedacht, okay, wenn ich das schon alles auf mich nehme, da muss ich ja auch irgendeinen positiven Impact für mich herausholen, der auch nicht normal ist. Weil ich erlebe ja auch Dinge, die nicht normal sind. Also habe ich angefangen, nur noch Luxussachen zu shoppen. Habe voll das krasse Auto gehabt.
Stellst dich heraus.
So, und das machst du. Und am Anfang ist das total geil. Und dann fliegst du zweimal Private Jet. Und irgendwann wird das alles normal. Und dann brauchst du wieder was Krasseres. Und das ist, glaube ich, der Moment, der so ungesund in meinem Leben geworden ist.
Ja, und wenn du dann ein 60-jähriger Mann bist, der schon alles erlebt hat.
Dann meldet man sich mal bei Jeffrey Epstein, ob der noch eine Idee hat für einen. Ja, das ist die Sache. Sie hat festgestellt, Geld allein macht nicht glücklich. Kommen wir aber gleich noch mal zu, wie sie das denn so sieht. Nur finde ich immer so interessant, das ist ja für ein Publikum, da hören ja nur Leute zu, denen es schlechter geht. Ja. Und zwar wesentlich schlechter. Und ihr Publikum war eines, das sagt, jetzt hat sie wieder einen neuen Hoodie auf den Markt gebracht, wieder neue Creme. Ich habe aber eigentlich die 100 Euro noch gespart, weil ich vielleicht da noch wegen der Miete, muss ich mal gucken, aber ich will eigentlich den Pullover noch bestellen. Also für dieses Publikum ist das ja gemacht. Und jetzt kommen die nochmal gesagt, ja, das war so leer. Das war alles falsch. Kennst du dieses kitschige Lied, I've been to paradise, but I've never been to me?
No. Von wem?
Ich glaube, die heißt Charlene.
Ach so, ein aktueller Pop-Song.
Nein, nein, das ist ein ganz altes Lied, ich glaube aus den 80ern oder Ende 70er-Jahre.
Das passt auch hier. Da gibt es auch eine deutsche Version von Paola. Ich hab ins Paradies gesehen, doch das Glück ist anderswo. Da geht es um eine Frau, die das Jet-Set-Leben führt, in Saint-Tropez und sonst wo ist, in Nizza, was auch immer. Und dann gibt es aber dann die Ansprache, ich kann mich an die deutsche Version erinnern, da sagt dann Paola, aber weißt du, was wirklich Glück ist? Das Gefühl, gebraucht zu werden. Einem Kind die Tränen vom Gesicht zu wischen, auf den Mann zu warten, der müd von der Arbeit kommt. Nur das bedeutet etwas. Und dann singt sie in der letzten Strophe, ich träume oft davon, ein Zuhause zu haben, wo ich geborgen sein kann. Ich möchte genau wie du einen Christbaum schmücken und auf den Urlaub sparen. Und das ist so eine Ideologie, die jetzt hier nochmal so mitgegeben wird.
Super reichen Romantik. Ich als ostdeutsches Kind habe natürlich nur Schlapps und Schlumbo gehört, die zwei Pantoffel, die sich auf die Reise begeben, nach einem besseren Kuschelsofa im viel besser Land. Und dann wandern sie um den großen Berg herum und kommen bei ihrem Zuhause wieder an. Und das war bei der DDR anders gemeint.
Ja, leuchtet mir auch ein. Hab die Metapher verstanden. Sehr gut. So viel zur Ideologie im Kinderzimmer. Wir hören mal weiter. Wie war das denn jetzt, sich zu entschließen aufzuhören?
Ich also wirklich, ich hab aufgehört zu posten und in dem Moment hab ich angefangen zu leben.
Würde ich auch sagen, weg mit der Lohnarbeit, einfach leben.
Hier wäre ich doch jetzt dafür, wir haben sowas leider nicht, aber offizielles Hearing. Diese Sätze müssen einmal politisch beglaubigt werden im Zuge der Diskussion, die wir eben hatten. Ich habe aufgehört zu posten und angefangen zu leben. Bibi, das ist doch genial. Das versteht auch jeder in der siebten Klasse. Wenn man denen sagt, du kennst Bibi nicht, dafür bist du zu jung. Aber hier, also da schnappen ja sofort alle Register. Vielleicht sollte man ihr nochmal eine politische Karriere geben.
Bloß nicht, wer weiß, wohin das dann führt. Jetzt ist es interessant, dass wir ja viel in solchen Podcasts hören über so eine latente Ideologiekritik, die geübt wird. Also man sieht ja schon, das Thema Entfremdung ist das maßgebliche hier. Sie leistet jetzt auch so eine halbe Ideologiekritik.
Was in meiner Kindheit, in meiner Jugend hat dazu geführt, dass ich am Ende solche Lebensentscheidungen getroffen habe und dieses Leben geführt habe. Und ich bin irgendwie nicht so zu einem Schlüsselmoment gekommen. Und dann habe ich viel tiefer gegraben und habe gecheckt, ja klar, wir werden ab Tag eins konditioniert von unseren Eltern, von unserer Familie, von unseren Freunden, von der Gesellschaft, von der Schule, von Werbung, jetzt von Social Media. Und es baut sich wie eine Identität über unsere eigenen Identität auf.
Kommt sie auf den Gedanken vielleicht noch, das wäre eigentlich, wenn sie sagen, ich finde darüber sollte man mal ein Buch schreiben.
Sie hat das Buch schon geschrieben. Du kannst es schon kaufen.
Deswegen ist ja auch da.
Natürlich.
Meinst du, wir sollten einfach nur das Literaturregister, sofern es das gibt, Quellenverweise mal lesen?
Wäre eigentlich interessant, oder für einen Salon? Oder?
Es ist schon verlockend. Es ist verlockend, oder? Es ist sehr verlockend.
Ja, obwohl ich auch sagen würde, es gibt wahrscheinlich nicht so viel dann her, weil das ist so ein Selbstfindungs-Ding.
Wir müssen es ja nicht zwei Stunden lang besprechen.
Ja, wir gucken mal rein, oder?
Ja.
Wäre eine Idee?
Ich glaube schon. Es würde mich einfach interessieren, ob überhaupt irgendwelche Verweise drin stattfinden.
Sie hat gesagt, dass sie sehr viel gelesen hat während der Zeit, als sie nicht online war. Doch, doch, das hat sie gesagt, wer weiß. Erich Fromm hat sie auch gelesen. Mhm, okay.
Also ich finde, wir sollten kurz zugreifen.
Wir greifen mal kurz drauf zurück. Ja, ich denke auch. Wir schauen mal rein. Jedenfalls haben wir jetzt hier schon gehört, da gibt es so etwas, was sich über die eigene Identität stützt. Und das ist das Interessante jetzt. Bei vielen Diskursen. Viele gehen jetzt davon aus, dass es so ein Ich gibt, das einfach da ist. Und zudem muss ich jetzt mal vordringen. Und dass es so unveränderlich als Kern in mir, wie so ein Herz, einfach da ist. Und da kann ich sagen, hier schlägt es. Das ist jetzt diese Idee von Ich, dass ein Ich sich in der Regel entwickelt und man sich manchmal wundert, was man vor 15 Jahren gesagt und gedacht und geliebt hat. Ist ja schon mal etwas, was eigentlich darauf hindeutet, dass es so diesen Kern, zu dem man da einmal so durchdringt, nicht gibt. Aber das ist so ein neuer Essentialismus, weil der Himmel vielleicht doch ein bisschen leer ist und sonst sind so die Beständigkeiten nicht da. Also kann ich jetzt vielleicht nochmal in mir selbst so einen Anker legen, wo ich sage, aber der ist wirklich fest, der sitzt, da bewegt sich nichts.
Ich habe eben von meinem Onkel geredet, mit seinem erheblichen Rentenanspruch. Wir kennen andere, das läuft immer auf das blockierte Leben. Das blockierte Leben brechen wir offenbar nicht auf, indem wir Bibi noch einen zweiten Privatjet hinstellen oder meinem Onkel einfach 8.000 Euro Rente zahlen. Sondern es ist irgendwo noch, vielleicht ohne, dass ich es wollte. Du weißt ja, in dem Buch, der immer mehr drinne als der Autor reinschreibt, finden wir doch noch einige Sachen.
Jaja, nur dieser Essentialismus des Selbsts, der ist doch jetzt so ein neues Phänomen geworden.
Nennt man, ähm, wie soll ich den Namen vergessen? Gib mir mal meinen Buch.
Auf welcher Seite steht das, Kori? Ich kann mich spicken. Es baut sich eine Identität.
So, warte.
So ein Überich ist was anderes.
Nee, Pseudoich. Ein Pseudoich.
Ein Pseudoich. Hast du ein Pseudoich oder hast du dann ein wirkliches Ich?
Na, gute Frage.
Ben, will mal wissen, wie ist das dann mit einem Leben ohne Geld?
Könntest du auch ohne Geld glücklich sein?
Also, wenn ich jetzt nicht verhunger und darüber im Kopf habe, ja.
Glaubst du, dass, also...
Momentchen mal, da muss man doch fragen, heißt das jetzt mehr als wie oder weniger als 20.000 im Monat, oder?
Genau, das ist die Frage, die sich in diesen Dimensionen ja stellt.
Kein Hunger und Dach über dem Kopf. Also, das ist ja Bürgergeld. Da kenne ich Leute, die sind mit 100.000 Euro im Monat nicht zufrieden.
Ja, deswegen hat der jetzt noch mal nach.
Man spricht ja immer von Geld macht nicht glücklich und da, da, da. Aber wenn man das einmal hatte und es dann nicht mehr hat, und auf einmal ist jetzt, man muss ja nicht unbedingt privat fliegen, aber bei der Ryanair in der Schlange zu stehen und dann kommt irgendwer und sagt, ach, pass mal auf hier, also dann, dann, der Köpferchen ist aber ein bisschen zu groß, drei Zentimeter, du musst jetzt nur mal 49 Euro bezahlen. Wenn du die nicht hast, das ist schon scheiße.
Klar.
Und dementsprechend wäre jetzt meine These, dass ein gewisses Maß an Geld durchaus sehr, sehr hebelnd ist auf Glück.
Ja, das kann, also es kann dir Dinge einfacher machen, aber das sollte nicht, also das sollte keine Bedingung für dein Glück sein.
Das ist ganz typisch, was wir ja auch in Hollywood-Filmen ganz häufig erleben können. Die Leute, die jetzt einfach reich sind, sagen, aber das sollte jetzt nicht Bedingungen für dein Glück sein. Und ich würde sagen, doch, bis zu einem gewissen Grad ist das so. Mag sein, dass das mit dem Privatjet dich nicht noch mal weiter glücklich macht, das glaube ich sehr gern. Aber es ist schon ein großer Unterschied, ob du dich fragen musst, kann ich mir das Zugticket leisten, mit dem ich irgendwie den Freund besuchen gehen will oder nicht?
Ja, wir haben auch kürzlich zwei große Aufklärungen wissenschaftlicher Art über so Kennziffern, die lange Zeit im Diskurs so festgetagelt waren. Das eine ist die 10.000 Schritte. Wir wissen schon seit einer Weile, dass das so mehr so ein ausgedachter Wert war. Aber was wir heute auch wissen ist, man kann das gar nicht irgendwie sehen. Also Leute sind mit 5.000 Schritten fit oder mit 20.000 halt KU. Und das Zweite ist, man wird nur glücklich bis ab 80.000 Euro im Jahr und danach nicht mehr. Und das stimmt auch nicht. Die Leute werden immer glücklicher.
Bis zu einem gewissen Punkt, bis sie dann irgendwann sagen müssen, jetzt muss ich mal bei Epstein mal anrufen.
Bis zur absoluten Verelendung jenseits des Ökonomischen, was wir vorhin besprochen haben. Aber typischerweise ist es...
Dass man auch privat dann trotzdem irgendwelche Probleme haben kann. Also wenn man Liebeskummer hat, dann hilft einem vielleicht auch die Million erst mal nicht direkt, aber indirekt dann schon, weil es doch, wie Reich Rannitzke ja zu sagen pflegte, angenehmer ist im Taxi zu weinen als in einer U-Bahn. So. Deshalb finde ich das...
Wobei man in der U-Bahn natürlich Trost erfahren kann. Das geht dem Taxi nicht so leicht.
Vielleicht beim Taxifahrer.
Ja, das ist eins, zwei, eins. Die kennen sich ja aus.
Das sind ja die Philosophen, die wahren Philosophen.
Weil das alles Soziologen sind.
Worum geht es Bibi? Nun, ihr geht es darum, wenn sie dann mehr so die Welt besser zu machen. Und wenn man die Welt besser machen will, sind wir erstmal nicht dagegen. Da muss man aber auch sagen, wie. Also man kann nicht einfach nur so allgemein die Welt besser machen, denn das kennen wir ja noch so von 2010 aus dem Silicon Valley. Die haben auch immer alle Bilds of a better world gesagt.
Oder von 1990 aus den PewDie Sachen von Trump.
Ja, alles soll immer besser werden. Aber was heißt dann eigentlich besser? Sie versucht dann mal ein Beispiel zu bringen. Nun ja.
Was manchmal nur ganz kleine alltägliche Entscheidungen sind, wo du vielleicht eine andere Entscheidung treffen musst. Das ist nicht ein Ich muss jetzt mein Leben von heute auf morgen komplett umändern und darf nichts mehr und bin voll eingeschränkt. Und ja, alles, was ich will und was mir Spaß macht, fällt weg. So ist es ja gar nicht. Aber ich glaube trotzdem, ja, dass es teilweise ganz kleine Sachen sind, die wir ändern können. So guck mal, ich gehe raus und bin unfreundlich zu der Bäckereifachverkäuferin. Die hat auch gerade nicht so einen guten Tag und dadurch, dass ich ihr unfreundlich begegne, ist ihre Laune so im Keller. Die pumpt die nächsten 20 Kunden an und die sind auch negativ dadurch gestimmt, geben das auch wieder weiter. Und plötzlich haben wir 500 Menschen negativ beeinflusst dadurch. Das Ganze hätten wir auch positiv machen können. Und das ist nur der kleine Satz, den ich mit einem Menschen wechsle. So machtvoll sind wir. Und wenn wir das verstehen und positiv nutzen wollen, dann kann die Welt, glaube ich, wirklich zu einem ganz, ganz tollen Ort werden.
Es erhärtet sich meine Vermutung, dass sie wirklich null Bücher gelesen hat.
Also sie beobtont in dem Podcast die ganze Zeit, wie viel sie gelesen hat. Ich weiß ja nicht, es kommt immer drauf, welche Bücher man gelesen hat.
Ja, aber ich glaube, jedes Bücher besteht aus irgendwelchen Worten, die ein bisschen Sinn ergeben.
Was ich festgestellt habe, sie ist jetzt auch im öffentlich-rechtlichen Formaten gewesen. Denn die lieben das jetzt auch so, die Geläuterte, die jetzt nochmal erzählt. Das ist so wie das Maschmeier-Phänomen, der jetzt auch der ist, der uns sensibilisiert für die moderne Arbeitswelt.
Und der Belegschaft mal Urlaub.
Ja, genau.
Neue Post auf LinkedIn von Carsten Maschmeier.
Oder wenn ich mit meiner Belegschaft auf Dienstreise bin, schlafen wir alle im selben Hotel.
Genau.
Solche Sagen.
Auch auf gleichem Stock oder ist einer genau?
Wir können uns ja mal fragen, hat sich überhaupt was an der Personality jetzt gerade verändert von Bibi? Ja, die postet jetzt nicht mehr rund um die Uhr irgendwelche Haarshampoos und Parfums. Aber es war doch eigentlich immer eine unglaubliche Hypris, dass man Leute in den Alltag mitnimmt und jeden Kram, den man im Alltag macht, ausstellt und sagt, seht her, heute habe ich das gefrühstückt, damit habe ich mir das Gesicht eingecremt und so weiter. Also das ist ja wirklich eine Auffassung von einem selbst, dass man sagt, ich mute mich den anderen die ganze Zeit voll hinzu, weil sie das schon interessieren wird. Man könnte ja auch sagen, ist mir scheißegal, womit du dir die Haare gewaschen hast. Aber nein, das Publikum wollte es und sie fand es auch selbstverständlich. Und eigentlich hat sich doch daran an dieser Hybris nichts geändert, denn diese geläuterten Influencer sitzen doch jetzt wieder da und belästigen einen von morgens bis abends mit irgendwelchen Inneligkeiten, wo ich sage, sei doch mal freundlich, klär das mit dir, ich will es nicht hören. Jetzt kann man sagen, ich muss den Podcast hören, aber was ich so interessant finde, ist, dass man sagt, ich setze mich da mal vor ein Mikro und erzähle das drei Stunden lang, wie ich mich da gefunden habe oder immer noch suche. Ben, überlegt jetzt, wie ist denn das überhaupt mit diesem Verbessern gemeint? Können wir denn überhaupt sagen, was eine Verbesserung herstellt?
Ich würde mir natürlich wünschen, dass die Welt besser wird. Ich weiß aber gar nicht, was besser ist. So und deswegen kann ich nur sagen, ich schaufle quasi, ich habe hier einen Gast, dann versuche ich zu verstehen, wer der Gaste ist und mit mir viele, viele andere Menschen.
Ja.
Und was daraus entspringt, ist möglicherweise positiv, möglicherweise ist es aber auch erst mal negativ.
Dann danach wieder positiv.
Ich glaube, Ben hat auch nichts gelesen.
Wenn irgendwelche Rechten dort sitzen und sagen, wir brauchen dringend einen Migrationsstopp.
Wie hat Ben das denn gemeistert, das Gespräch? Fandest du das gute Fragen?
Naja, das sind, ich weiß nicht, die unterhalten sich ja so über Innerlichkeiten, wo ich denke, da will ich überhaupt gar nicht reinkriechen in so Leute.
Willst du nicht wissen, wie die Leute tippen?
Will ich überhaupt gar nicht.
Ich glaube, ich warte auf ihr Gespräch bei Matze, denn dann weiß ich, da ist es aus einem Guss. Da kommt nicht so ein skeptischer Moderator, sondern der Matze weiß genau, was die Bibi meint.
Mich wundert es eigentlich immer, dass das Publikum wissen will, was Bibi meint. Für mich war das ja so, dass ich dachte, diese Idee des Influencer-Seins habe ich ja nun mal verhandelt in dem Buch und dachte, ich muss aber noch mal so gucken, wo haben die sich eigentlich hinentwickelt. Was wurde eigentlich aus? Das war so die Frage, die ich mir stellte. Und dann merkte ich, okay, das Influencer-Business geht jetzt auch in eine ganz andere Richtung. Also geht jetzt ans Eingemachte, könnte man auch sagen. Auch hier wieder eine leichte Nostalgie bei mir. Ach, was war das damals schön, als sie einfach nur Hautcreme angeboten haben. Ben und Bibi werden sich dann so einig über diese Frage. Man kann es ja nicht wissen, ob man jetzt vielleicht gerade was Negatives macht, was dann Positives ist. Das ist ja eine Frage, die schon kann, stellt. Denn da ist allein nichts in der Welt außer der gute Wille. Sobald du etwas umsetzt, kann das natürlich, ja, du hilfst da einem Menschen über die Straße. Wirklicherweise wird er an der nächsten Ecke überfahren. Dann war das gar nicht gut, dass du über die Straße gehörst. Man weiß es ja gar nicht. Jedenfalls hier.
Auf was für einem zeitlichen Level misst man dann Impact?
Ja voll.
Die erste Emotion oder 30 Jahre später, 100 Jahre später?
Ja, gebe ich dir voll recht. Das sehe ich absolut genauso.
Das ist ein Grund, da sind wir doch beieinander.
Ja, da auch sind wir.
Ja, das freut mich.
Also Bibi kommt da hin und sagt, ich habe meine Maßstäbe überdacht, die waren alle falsch.
Ja.
Ich habe jetzt neue Maßstäbe.
Die Welt verbessern.
Dann fragt er, ja, also wie messen wir jetzt gut und schlecht nach den neuen Maßstäben? Kann ja heute oder in 100 Jahren. Ja genau, ja genau. Okay, gut. Dann sind wir uns ja eigentlich so.
Ja, so kann ja jeder von sich behaupten, ich verbessere gerade die Welt.
Das ist auch so ein neuer Vulgär-Long-Term-Missen. Man macht heute einfach irgendwas. Na ja, irgendwann wird es schon eine gute Seite haben. Ja, wenn es böse ist, dann hat jemand drüber nachgedacht, wie das ist, wenn jemand böse ist, hat deswegen freundlich geguckt und jetzt sind alle freundlich.
Richtig, richtig, sehr richtig.
Das ist sehr gut.
Wir vermessen jetzt nochmal das Selbst.
Und das habe ich zum Beispiel gelernt auf meiner Reise. Das ist völliger Quatsch. Also ich glaube, die größte Inspiration ist einfach ich selbst.
Das ist das klassische Me-Time, was die Influencer die ganze Zeit schon vergöttlicht haben. Es war ja diese Selbstvergötterung, die stattgefunden hat, dass man da Stories hatte von Influencerinnen und Influencern, die sagten, nachdem sie 50 Stories schon gepostet hatten, mit dem, was sie im Alltag alles gemacht haben, so, jetzt ist Abend, jetzt ist ein bisschen Me-Time angesagt. Den ganzen Tag nur um sich selbst gedreht und dann sagen sie nochmal Me-Time.
Ja, das war aber verlogen tagsüber. Abends ist halt true Me-Time.
Jaja, das posten sie aber auch nochmal. Und hier, das ist jetzt sowas, dass man sagt, die Inspiration kommt aus mir selbst. Nein, das ist ja wirklich der Idee, da ist irgendwas tief drin. Muss ich nur mal irgendwo rausholen. Da ist so eine kleine Schatzkiste, wenn ich die gefunden habe und aufmache, dann bin ich reich.
Ja, völlig richtig. Ich habe mich das letzte Mal über Joscha Bach hier eschofiert und habe genug tun gesagt, siehst du jetzt, habt ihr alle den Salat, ihr habt ihn mir empfohlen, er ist aber ein Idiot oder macht idiotische Sachen. Ich will ja nicht persönlich beleidigen. Das ist ja bei Noam Chomsky nicht anders. Noam Chomsky hat ja berühmt halt erlangt darüber, dass in uns allen so eine Grammatik einprogrammiert wäre. Und dann haben wir alle gesagt, ne, also wir haben den Körper aufgeschnitten, wir haben das nicht gesehen. Und dann hieß es aber immer, der Noam Chomsky ist so ein guter Mann, den dürfen wir jetzt auf gar keinen Fall wegen uns kritisieren. Jetzt stellen wir fest, ja dieser Schutzschirm, der ist so ein guter Mann, der ist gar nicht gegeben. Also war eine Lüge. Und schon wieder ist so eine, das ist in der Grammatik einprogrammiert. Also solche Ideen vererben sich ja, wie wir hier hören, überall hin. Das ist ja dieser Trick, ein Buch zu schreiben, in dem Blödsinn steht. Jeder, der das Buch liest, denkt sich, sorry, das ist Blödsinn. Aber es hat so ein Eigenleben neben dem Buch, für Leute, die eigentlich keine Bücher lesen, sondern nur YouTube gucken. Da kommt dann so was an. Und dann sitzen die jungen Mädels in so einem Podcast und sagen, ich selbst.
Ja, und das hat ja immer dieses eine Körnchen Wahrheit, dass es braucht, damit das auch so akzeptiert wird allgemein. Genau. Dass man sagt, ja, immer wieder ist man in Situationen, in denen man sagt, jetzt muss ich mal an mich selbst denken.
Also wir haben eine Gegenprobe dafür.
Jeder kann das nachvollziehen.
Genau, weil die Kritik ja klar ist. Sie ist ja Mutter. Würde sie jetzt in dem Podcast sagen, vielleicht macht sie das in zehn Jahren, wenn sie dann sagt, ich hab mich geirrt, es war gar nicht ich selbst, es war meine Tochter. Ja, es geht eigentlich nur um sie. Dann würden alle genauso, das ist so gut, wie es so geläutet, ich kann so viel daraus lernen und so.
Schauen wir uns dieses Verhältnis an, das Selbst und das Außen.
Ich wünsche mir, für mich so in Ruhe mit mir selbst zu sein und so sicher und im Einklang mit mir selbst zu sein, dass mich nichts aus dem Außen mehr im Innen verändern kann. Das ist mein großes Lebensziel.
Ja, dann muss man sich völlig abnabeln von der Welt und das nicht mehr an sich herankommen. Auch hier wieder das Körnchen Wahrheit. Ja, ich kann nicht bei jedem negativen Kommentar gleich anfangen zu weinen. Das muss ich ein bisschen an mir abprallen lassen. Aber wenn ich sage, ich will, dass nur noch mein Selbst regiert und dass nichts mehr von außen durchdreht, dann verpanzere ich mich eigentlich. Das ist aber auch wieder nur konsequent. Während vorher die Verpanzerung stattgefunden hat, sie beschreibt das auch mit einem teuren Auto, mit den Markenklamotten. Ich habe es geschafft, ein Riesenhaus mit 500 Einbauschränken. Wir haben dieses Haus alle gesehen in diesem Video damals. Findet jetzt die Verpanzerung im Inneren statt, die auch wirklich so ein neoliberales Mantra ist. Lass nichts mehr an dich rankommen. Geh einfach straight durch, mach dein Ding, du wirst es schaffen.
Also typischerweise verhalten sich ja Männer genauso. Und genau deswegen ernten die ja diese ganze Kritik. Und sollen jetzt immer zum Therapeuten gehen und da ganz sensibel sein.
Ja, aber das ist ja das Ding. Da hat ja mein lieber Freund Timon K. Kaleiter dieses Buch Heilung geschrieben.
Ganz zynischer Mann.
Ja, der hat ja dieses Buch geschrieben und da geht ja der Protagonist auf so eine Heilung. Also geht in so ein Retreat und kommt ja dann so bei sich an und im eigenen inneren Ich. Aber da schlummert ja vielleicht gerade was, was nicht so angenehm ist.
Das kann sein.
Zumindest für die anderen. Zum Selbst. Wie gelangen wir denn da überhaupt? Gibt es ein Angebot? Ich kannte das gar nicht. Also ich wusste, dass es so Atemübungen oder sowas gibt. Aber Breathwork. Hast du davon schon mal gehört?
Ja, wir haben im letzten Salon darüber gesprochen, weil ich nämlich diese Pointe so lustig fand, dass die Julia Anders, die es in ihrem Buch dann nicht aufgegriffen hatte, aber dass sie mir auffiel mit eine Zigarettenpause, ist auch Breathwork.
Ach ja, ja, okay, stimmt. Nun, das ist hier auch Thema zwischen den beiden, da kennen sich wohl auch beide aus.
Ist einfach schwerer zu lernen.
Hast du schon mal richtig Breathwork gemacht?
Ja, klar.
Und wie war die Erfahrung für dich?
Gut, also verschiedene Formen mit irgendwie, die heißen ja alle irgendwie anders, aber...
Aber auch mal richtig betreut, eine richtige Erfahrung, okay.
Richtig, ja. Also von diverser Psychedelika über Exzetic Breath, Gedöns, Wim Hof.
Gedöns. Man soll ja mit Breathwork, Psychedelics, ich hab das dann mal gelesen, dann kann man sich wohl in solche äxtatischen Zustände hineinatmen, was auch immer da gerade ist. Und da soll man auch zu einem Selbst vordringen. Also es ist immer diese Idee, da gibt es so ein Selbst, das man dann irgendwann greifen kann. Das erzählen ja auch manche Leute, die so LSD-Trips machen von irgendwelchen Pforten der Wahrnehmung, die sie dann öffnen. Ich würde mal sagen, das sind die Projektionen, die du vorher hattest, die dir dann nochmal begegnen in anderer Form.
Ich möchte auch dazu aufrufen, das nicht mit Latex oder Gummi oder Tüten über den Mund zu machen.
Nein, so ist das glaube ich aber auch da gar nicht gemeint. Nein, das geht ja darum, so betreutes... Betreut, genau. Ich weiß es nicht.
Ich habe da mal Angst, dass so Sachen gemeint sind, die man lieber nicht alleine macht.
Ich rate generell...
Das Gespräch ist sehr gute Comedy, ich höre das sehr gern.
Bibi, deutet dir auch so zaghaft doch an, so ein neues Geschäft?
Es ist glaube ich schon dieses Erlebnis an Menschen zu geben. Ich glaube, das ist echt entscheidend. Und da arbeite ich tatsächlich gerade dran, aber in einem ganz anderen Umfeld. Weil ich diese Buchrelease Party hatte und da ist jemand zu mir gekommen, den ich vorher nicht persönlich kannte und hat mir so ein schönes Feedback gegeben und hat gesagt, Bianca, ich muss dir jetzt mal sagen, ich habe mich nicht viel mit dir auseinandergesetzt und so, aber wenn ich jetzt hier die letzten zwei Tage verbracht habe und weiß, dass das aus dir entsprungen ist, dass das dich widerspiegelt, dann kann ich dich ganz anders greifen und wahrnehmen und verstehen und viel mehr annehmen, was du sagst und das viel mehr verstehen.
Also man hält sich eigentlich nicht mehr aus so. Ich referiere kurz einen Podcast-Clip.
Das ist ja eine Welt jenseits der Argumente, dass man dachte, ich muss da mal so reinkriechen und dann weiß ich, wer du bist und dann kann ich dich auch verstehen und dann berührst du mich.
Ich habe dir ja mal eine schöne Geschichte erzählt von Hans Zimmer, der ausgezeichnet wurde mit einem Oscar für König der Löwen. Und die Erzählung war, er wollte unbedingt mal seine Tochter mit zu einer Premiere nehmen, das geht nur für einen Kinderfilm, also hat er einen Kinderfilm angenommen, hat sich nichts dabei gedacht, weil es ja nur ein Kinderfilm, plötzlich musste er so ein Requiem für seinen toten Vater schreiben und so. Und da hast du ja gesagt, ja, schöne Geschichte fürs Marketing genau richtig. Und ich habe gesagt, nein, dies war. Und ich bin über einen Clip gestolpert, der New York Times oder es ist Wall Street Journal, weiß nicht, eins der beiden. Und zwar Tinder wurde erfunden, weil der Tinder-Erfinder vor seinem Spiegel stand nach dem Duschen und den erst frei wischen musste. Und dann hat er ein paar Mal gewischt und hat dann irgendwann sich gesehen. Und dann hat er sich gedacht, das ist die Business-Idee.
Ja toll, das sind doch Geschichten.
Genial, oder? Das ist genau wie hier. Bibi, also jetzt, wo ich es aus deinem Munde höre, das ist ja deine Geschichte. Wow, ich kann dich jetzt ganz anders greifen.
Ja.
Oh Gott.
Wir machen da mal weiter.
Und es war auch nach, also da war auch Breathwork ein Teil von, zum Beispiel. Danach hat er mir das gesagt. Und da musste ich so viel drauf machen.
Wenn ich das jetzt richtig verstanden habe, gab es bei der Buchrelease-Party auch Breathwork? Also die haben da gemeinsam so ein Happening veranstaltet.
Wenn du das nächste Mal eingeladen bist. Du gehst auf die Bühne und sagst, ihr müsst nicht singen, aber kommt drei Minuten Breathwork.
Ich bin nächste Woche in der Uni Erlang. Vielleicht da gleich mal ausprobieren.
Ich habe Erlang als sehr aufgeschlossene, extrem junge, ja 41 Jahre oder so, ist ja die jüngste Stadt Deutschlands mit Hilseheim und Heidelberg. Und Erlang ist der Ort dafür, sei gespannt.
Daran rumdenken, weil ich dachte, boah krass, ich glaube, das ist voll ein Hebel, der richtig viel bewirken könnte, dass die Menschen echte Erlebnisse haben mit echten, richtigen Emotionen und das wirklich was langfristig in den Menschen verändert und sie dadurch vielleicht auch bereit sind, Dinge, die ich sage, schreibe, wie auch immer, inspirieren will damit, dass sie das ganz anders aufnehmen können.
Die Menschen nehmen das dann anders auf dadurch. Das klingt für mich eher so nach Inception. Man muss die Leute jetzt nicht nur mit einem Argument überzeugen, sondern man versucht sie jetzt auch in so einem größeren Erfahrungsbereich dazu zu bringen, dass sie mich verstehen und mir dann folgen. Will sie jetzt Guru werden?
Was ist die Geschäftsidee? Unter diesen Gesichtspunkten, es geht ja hier darum, sie will ja Leute erreichen, sie hat ein Buch. Meine Kritik ist ja immer Buchverlage, Verkaufen an Buchhändler und was danach passiert, ist ihnen egal. Und ich würde sagen, verkauft doch bitte bis an den Leser. Das heißt aber nur noch nicht, dass gelesen wurde.
Sie möchte jetzt diesen Hebel, dass das Buch auch wirklich gelesen, verstanden, verinnerlicht in die Welt hinausgetragen, ausgebrütet wird.
Und das finde ich schon einen super spannenden Punkt. Und da bin ich auf jeden Fall gerade an ein paar echt coolen Sachen dran. An was? Also es ist wirklich noch alles sehr am Anfang. Deswegen kann ich das nicht so gut sagen. Aber ich möchte gerne ganz besondere Erlebnisse schaffen für Menschen, wo sie in Bereiche vielleicht reinblicken können, wo sie sich vielleicht sonst nicht für geöffnet hätten.
Sie führt uns in diese Bereiche. Ich kann jetzt schon mal sagen, ich sehne mich nach der alten Bibi zurück. Ben fragt nach.
Hast du mal was mit Psychedelika gemacht? Also hast du eine psychodelische Erfahrung gemacht? Du grinst, weil du das natürlich öffentlich nicht verantworten möchtest. Soll ich die Frage wieder zurücknehmen? Weil das ist eigentlich die Geschichte, die im Moment alle erzählen. Alle, die irgendwie große Lebensveränderungen haben.
Ja, dass sie irgendwelche Drohnexkurse als Urlaub haben.
In diesen amerikanischen Podcasts habe ich den Eindruck, sitzt jetzt jeder da und erzählt von irgendeiner Pforte der Wahrnehmung, die da aufgegangen ist. Die Leute sind völlig irre, weil sie irgendeine Vorstellung haben von einem Ich, das sich ihnen dann offenbart. Also dieser Selbst-Essentialismus, der jetzt da betrieben wird überall. Und da ist Bibi nur ein Symptom, ist so flächendeckend vorhanden, dass ich sage, das ist ein gruseliger Trend. Und man ahnt schon mit Neuroenhancement und mit den ganzen Psychodetika und alles, was es da gibt. Wir spielen jetzt gleich noch zwei Clips, dann runden wir das damit ab. Sehen wir, wohin die Reise geht.
Ich möchte einen Podcast empfehlen, den habe ich schon ein paar Mal angesprochen, aber der passt hier wieder. Denn es gibt in der New York Times zwei große, meinungsstarke Podcasts. Das eine ist Israel Klein und das andere ist der Do That, der den Interesting Times Podcast macht. Und die beiden haben zusammen ein Gespräch geführt. Und es handelt zu 80 Prozent nur davon. Weil der Do That ist der Religiöse und der Israel Klein ist der, der davon erzählt, dass er schon mal so ein Drogen-Retreat gemacht hat. Und dann wollte der Do That immer wissen, ob man damit wirklich durch die Pforte gehen kann. Und der Israel Klein so nicht nicht so ganz, aber man sieht die Pforte und der Israel Klein so, das ist voll toll. Meinst du, das kriege ich auch spirituell hin oder brauche ich da unbedingt Drogen? Und dann sagt der Israel Klein ja, brauchst du schon Drogen? Und so wundert sich die ganze Zeit darüber, was da stattfindet. Aber ja, das bringt einige Leute hier also wirklich auf Skiverbahn.
Ja, die Leute nehmen sich unglaublich wichtig. Und es hat sich in dem Sinne nichts verändert hier, sondern es wird nur noch doller. Das führt uns jetzt ganz zum Schluss zu zwei Clips von Christian Angermeier. Das ist einer der Tech-Elite-Angehörigen, die auch mit Peter Thiel sehr eng gefreundet sind. Er ist ein großer Unterstützer von MAGA und Donald Trump. Er war vor einer Weile jetzt auch bei OMR zu Gast. Völlig obskur, was er da alles erzählt. Einmal will er jetzt mit Forschern daran arbeiten, dass man Dinosaurier wiederbelebt. Man glaubt da also, DNA-Spuren zu haben. So ein bisschen wie Jurassic Park. So will man es machen. Und er ist auch derjenige, der diese olympischen Spiele veranstaltet.
Ach, die Enhanced Games.
Die Enhanced Games.
Sehr gut.
Er selbst nimmt auch alles Mögliche. Er zählt hier aber in einem anderen Podcast. Das ist dann quasi der Anschluss an das, was Ben gefragt hat. Bei Glaser und Spangen, wie er sich das vorstellt mit Mental Health und was man da doch eigentlich alles tun könnte.
Wir haben alle mal schwierige Zeiten. Ich muss dir nicht sagen, aber auch euch beiden, der ganze deutsche Aktienmarkt war zwei Jahre lang so schwierig, dass ihr wahrscheinlich alle Stress habt. Jetzt kann man sagen, es wird schon wieder besser. Jetzt kann man aber auch sagen, vielleicht würde man in der Zukunft freventiv zum Arzt gehen und würde sagen, ich gehe gerade durch eine schwierige Phase im Leben, weil der deutsche Demenberg den Markt zum Kotzen ist. Ich gehe gerade durch eine schwierige Phase, weil ich Stress in der Beziehung habe. Jede von uns hat schwierige Phasen. Warum warten und hoffen, dass nichts passiert, mental health wise, und nicht proaktiv ein bisschen Support holen? Ich glaube, der Psychedelics, was ich kurzweise um was ich sagen will, nicht nur, ich glaube 100% daran, dass Psychedelics die nächsten Jahre erproft werden. Und by the way, Atay hat fast alle relevanten Patente. Also Atay und Kompass zusammen, also mit Psilocybin. Wir sind die Psychedelic-Industrie. Also uns gehören diese Compounds.
Herr Doktor, der Bitcoin-Kurs ist runter. Können Sie mir bitte ein Mittel verschreiben?
Wirklich, das ist der irrste Clip, den ich je gehört habe.
Also, dann musste man nach seinem Namen googeln. Ich könnte tausende dieser Art mitbringen.
Wir machen hier einen politischen Podcast. Die Alternative wäre, Nachrichtenlage, Trump wurde gewählt, DHS kauft irgendwie 40.000 für 40 Milliarden Lagerräume für Menschen. Ich geh erstmal zum Arzt und hol mir eine gute Laune Drogen. Das hält ja keiner aus.
Damit, wie Bibi ja gesagt hat, das selbst muss ja geschützt sein. Also ich will jetzt nicht Bibi unterstellen, dass sie mit Christian Angermeyer Geschäfte machen würde. Soweit geht es dann nicht. Aber das selbst will man schützen, dass nicht mehr von außen ein Einfluss kommen kann, der mein Ich, mein Selbst gefährdet. Wir hören noch einmal Christian Angermeyer in einem anderen Format. Denn man muss ja auch den Trip optimieren. Wie viel Zeit hat man und vor allem auch drauf geblickt für die, die diese Trips organisieren. Wie personalintensiv ist das? Weil du machst das ja in Betreuung.
Auch da gibt es eine gute Überlegung.
Das ist ja alles gar nicht so einfach. Die Leute, die drei Tage im Bergheim durchtanzen, wissen jetzt, wovon ich rede. Deshalb hat Christian Angermeyer auch da eine Idee. Dann ist das jetzt in besserer Regel. Du gehst ja auch nicht acht Stunden zum Massage, sondern nur eine halbe Stunde.
Stimmt. Denn es ist viel besser, wenn die Reise oder eine Session von A bis Z mit Vorbereitung, Abkühlung, was auch immer, zwei Stunden dauert, was wir targetieren, nicht sechs Stunden wie Suicide, sondern nicht zwölf Stunden wie LSD. Also ich sage immer, wie bei der größten Liebe, für einen Tag auf der Bühne, in einem Land, wo es Degel ist, liebe ich LSD. Ein tolles Drogen. Aber es ist eine zwölf-Halb-Trip und vielleicht 14. Es gibt so viele kleine Dinge, die du nicht denken kannst, dass der erste Moment ist, das könnte bedeuten, dass du zwei Nursen brauchst, weil die Schifte der Gesundheitsanwalt-Professionen nicht zwölf-Halbe sind, nicht 14. Was ist, wenn der Trip noch länger ist? Kannst du die Leute nach Hause senden? Müssen sie über Nacht bleiben? Müssen sie in der Klinik ein Bad haben? Es gibt so viele Details, die Investoren noch nicht denken können, und wir machen das.
Also Wolfgang, du bringst besser noch zehn solcher Clips mit. Und dann sieht es wie folgt aus, 65 Prozent der Kommentare fragen, was würden die mit einer Milliarde machen? Ich hätte 20 Prozent Entschuldigung, dass ich beschwert wurde, also dass man sich mal dagegen.
Vielleicht ist die Wirklichkeit viel verrückter als mancher Irrsinn.
Das ist ja wirklich schräg, schräg, schräg.
Und das geht nur so. Also bei OMR vergöttert er Trump und sagt, dass wir das alle falsch sehen, dass wir da auch mit viel zu, also selbst auch René Benko war ja auch mit befreundet. Und da würde auch vieles jetzt in den Medien falsch oder nicht uns nicht hinreichend dargestellt. Jedenfalls ist das etwas, was wir jetzt erobern, was wir gerade beobachten können. Wir erleben jetzt eine Eroberung des Selbst, noch nie da gewesen in diesem Punkt. Und natürlich sind die Influencer mit ganz vorne dabei. Das heißt, hier ändert sich jetzt gerade nichts. Wir kommen dann nicht in postmaterielles Zeitalter oder so. Das ist einfach nur ein Geschwätz von Superreichen, die sagen, ich brauch nicht noch mehr. Aber jetzt muss ein neues Geschäftsmodell herbei, mit dem man das Ich kolonialisieren kann. Wir haben ja im Zuge der KI-Debatten so viel über Kolonialismus auch gesprochen, gesagt, das ist eigentlich so Neokolonialismus. Und dieser Neokolonialismus, der betrifft jetzt auch das Ich in einer ganz anderen Weise noch mal als ein TikTok-Algorithmus. Nämlich hier soll wirklich am Ich direkt operiert werden.
Ja, man wünschte sich, die Politik würde mal Marktforschung machen wie die, bevor sie in so einen Podcast gehen und das nächste große Business verkünden. Okay, letzter Clip, weil wir es heute die ganze Zeit so mitgeschleppt haben. Es gibt nur so eine Semantik und dann eine Realität. Und jetzt haben wir Bibi unterstellt. Da ist schon ein Brückenschlag, Marktforschung. Sie weiß da irgendwas. In zehn Jahren werden die Leute so drauf sein. Gerade wenn der ganze Medieninhalt, wir haben uns die Hollywood-Clips von heute nicht geguckt, aber die gucken wir nächste Woche. Und so. Und Leute wünschen sich so einen Eskapismus. Ja. Und der führt manchmal so ein bisschen rückwärtsgewandt. Und sie sehen auch, ist auf jeden Fall irgendeine Veränderung nötig, weil wir vertreiben ja gerade aus Sachsen-Anhalt alle Ausländer und brauchen die aber eigentlich für unseren Servicebereich. Das fällt den Leuten irgendwann auf, dass es vielleicht nicht aufging so. Und die Corinna Budras macht im FAZ-Podcast ein Gespräch und spielt dabei einen Clip von Ulrich Siegmund. Das ist der Spitzenkandidat AfD, also wahrscheinlich der nächste Ministerpräsident von Sachsen-Anhalt.
Rechter Flügel der AfD, wenn man das so sagen kann.
Also da geht es richtig zur Sache. Es wird folgendes Problem aufgeworfen.
Einen Punkt, den fand ich auch ganz interessant, war ja ein Rückgewinnungsprogramm für deutsche Fachkräfte. Das ist etwas, was er zum Beispiel hier im vergangenen Jahr im MDR ausgeführt hat. Da können wir mal reinhören.
In der Wirtschaftspolitik haben wir ein Alleinstellungsmerkmal. Wir möchten ein Rückgewinnungsprogramm auflegen für deutsche Fachkräfte. Wir haben jedes Jahr über 100.000 Deutsche, die Deutschland verlassen, weil sie sich nicht mehr aushalten. Wir reden ja auch von Ärzten, wir reden von Menschen aus dem Handwerk. Und genau die möchten wir zurückholen. Wir möchten ihnen ein Angebot machen, dass sie die Zustände, die sie in Deutschland nicht mehr ausgehalten haben, in Sachsen-Anhalt nicht vorfinden. Dass sie hier wieder das gute alte Deutschland vorfinden, was sie ja woanders offenbar nicht mehr vorgefunden haben, warum sie Deutschland verlassen haben.
Ja, was meint er denn mit dem guten alten Deutschland, Reinhard?
Das kommt wie eine lockere Frage daher, aber es geht um Sachsen-Anhalt. Was ist das gute alte Deutschland, was die Leute mal verloren haben gegen so ein Vogtding, irgendwas und so. Und dass er ihn wieder bieten will. Wenn man es die Jahrzehnte zurückgeht, so viel Auswahl ist gar nicht. Es ist entweder wir sind die Wendeverlierer, der Westen ist über uns reingefallen, oder es ist die DDR, oder es ist die NS-Zeit und davor gibt es keine lebendige Erinnerung. Von daher, wir werden Versprechen in den Raum gestellt. Die Idee ist dann irgendwie, kann man ja nur mutmaßen, angenommen, es hätte die Wende zur richtigen Zeit gegeben, und dann hätte man das ethno-homogenele Westdeutschland, auch in Ostdeutschland, aber ehrlich und so.
Vielleicht so eine deutsche Enklave in Argentinien zurückbewegen.
Irgendwas, ja. Also schon der Zukunftsentwurf, okay, der kann flexibel bleiben. Aber hier ist völlig klar, dieses Statement von dem Typen ist überhaupt, das hat gar kein Fundament. Es gibt dieses Deutschland für Sachsen-Analtina gar nicht, die ist zurück. Das finde ich schon krass irgendwie. Das hält einfach nichts stand, egal was sie da aufwerfen. Na gut, haben wir diesen Februar hier mal abgeschlossen.
Wir sprechen also im nächsten Salon über das neue Buch von Ulrike Herrmann. Es heißt Geld als Waffe. Wir sind sehr gespannt, haben das letzte Mal über das Buch sehr ausführlich diskutiert. Dort geht es ja darum, dass sie das Ende des Kapitalismus eigentlich einläutet, dass sie ja möchte, dass wir eine Kriegswirtschaft bekommen, um die ökologischen Probleme zu lösen. Wir haben das sehr kritisch gesehen. Wir sind gespannt, wie jetzt dieser Kriegswirtschaftsgedanke weitergedacht wird. Wer jedenfalls den alten Salon hören will, kann das auch tun. All das ist hörbar über Steady, Apple und Patreon. Man kann also ganz einfach uns abonnieren. Das heißt, der Salon ist der Zusatzinhalt zu diesem regulären Podcast. Und dann gibt es wie immer auch Empfehlungen. Du hast schon gesagt, du bringst das Buch von Carla Hinrichs mit. Ich halte es mir mal noch offen, was ich mitbringe. Und vielleicht schauen wir noch in das Buch von Bibi rein, wenn sich die Gelegenheit gibt. Denn jetzt sind wir doch auch alle auf der Suche nach dem Selbst.
Ja, ich bin ganz lost.
Bis dann.